[Musique]
de protection des français mais aussi
les crédits d'un ministère qui connaît
le plus de disparition parmi ces agents
publics et évidemment nous avons tous ça
en tête bien évidemment lorsque nous
parlons du travail important est
difficile des agents du ministère de
l'intérieur alors en 2022 monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur
rapporteur général le taux de
consommation des crédits je pense que
c'est le premier point lorsqu'on gère me
semble-t-il les deniers publics a été
très élevé dans un contexte qu'on
pourrait qualifier de très soutenu pour
le ministère de l'Intérieur et je suis
très heureux de constater avec vous que
99% des crédits ont été consommés
c'est-à-dire que l'argent que vous
octroyez au ministre de l'Intérieur et
assez ministre délégué et bien utilisé
en tout cas il est bien utilisé au sens
comptable du terme il n'a pas été
sous-utilisé au sur-utilisé c'est à dire
que 22,3 milliards d'euros d'engagements
ont été inscrits et que 21,3 milliards
d'euros en cryptiquement
c'était dépensé nous avons amélioré
c'est cette exécution d'autant plus
compliqué que les opéras les aléas par
températionnelles ont été très nombreux
nous y reviendrons
la sécurité civile qui a été marquée par
des feux de forêts sont précédents
chacun le chacun le sait 72000 hectares
brûlés la mission immigration asile
intégration qui a pourtant assuré la
prise en charge sans crédit nouveau de
plus de 100000 personnes déplacées
d'Ukraine alors que c'était pas prévu au
début de l'année budgétaire telle que
nous l'avions imaginé dans la discussion
budgétaire c'est également le cas bien
sûr sur l'immigration irrégulière qui
même si elle avait été prévu je n'avais
pas été prévu dans des augmentations
aussi importantes parce que 33%
d'augmentation d'asile par rapport à
2021 et alors même que vous le savez une
partie de la dépense du ministère de
l'Intérieur est une dépense obligatoire
par Lada et par les décisions du Conseil
d'État je veux aussi souligner bien
évidemment les difficultés
opérationnelles que l'on a pu avoir dans
l'action du ministère de de l'intérieur
je pense notamment à son action en
termes d'organisation des élections
2022 a été une élection a été une année
d'élection importante
deuxièmement en 2022 il y a eu aussi des
tensions comme dans tous les crédits
dans toutes les dans toutes les missions
bien sûr au niveau de l'inflation et
cette inflation apportant été maîtrisée
c'est un peu plus facile au ministère
sans doute de l'Intérieur qu'ailleurs
puisque nous avons une grosse masse
budgétaire humaine qui n'est pas
sensible à l'inflation qui est sensible
l'augmentation du point d'indice mais
pas à l'inflation et une discussion plus
réduite sur le rt2 mais nous avons quand
même continué à faire ce travail malgré
cette inflation et nous avons donc pu
être au rendez-vous de l'habillement du
matériel de protection des achats de
véhicule qui avait été très mis en avant
pendant les plans de relance et bien sûr
aussi sur la programmation de rénovation
immobilière puisque l'un des problèmes
du ministère de l'Intérieur structurel
depuis 40 ans c'est une masse budgétaire
qui augmente qui augmente qui soit par
leur recrutement soit par les
augmentations d'indemnités de prime de
prestation
de nos policiers gendarmes et autres
agents de préfecture et une masse de R2
qui n'était pas au niveau du T2 et donc
c'est ce qui explique des casernes de
gendarmerie particulièrement dégradés
des commissariats particulièrement en
difficulté des préfectures qui n'ont pas
fait leur transition énergétique nous
avons réparé cela dès mon arrivée c'est
choisir ministère de l'Intérieur pour la
première fois les crédits T2 sont
supérieures en croissance au crédit T2
mais enfin évidemment il faut beaucoup
d'exercices budgétaires et c'est
notamment le cas de la loterie pour
pouvoir rattraper une partie de cette ce
retard et j'aurai d'ailleurs monsieur le
Président sans doute dans les réponses
aux questions que poseront les
commissaires des propositions de pistes
d'amélioration profonde sans
augmentation budgétaire pour fonctionner
autrement sur ce hors T2 mais je veux
quand même souligner que nous avons en
2021 et 2022 rénové plus de 700
commissariats brigade de gendarmerie ce
qui n'a pas de précédent dans les années
budgétaires du ministère de l'intérieur
avec des des opérations très symboliques
l'hôtel de police de Nice par exemple le
commissaire de Valenciennes qui était
parfois attendu depuis plus de 60 ans et
commissariat de l'ancienne par exemple
était vraiment une demande récurrente
des élus ou les gendarmerie comme la
réalité des logements des gendarmes à
Drancy qui était extrêmement touchés où
la caserne Hetzel à Marseille pour
prendre quelques quelques exemples très
importants évidemment dès 2022 nous
avons commencé à préparer les grands
événements que nous préparons pour 2023
2024 qui vont marquer les années
budgétaires de cette année de l'année
prochaine la Coupe du monde de rugby et
les Jeux Olympiques dans la lutte contre
les drones dans la monisation des salles
de commandement dans la cybersécurité on
aura l'occasion sans doute d'y revenir
je veux aussi souligner que dans la
mission immigration asile et intégration
très contrainte par le contexte
international et par les décisions
judiciaires nous avons au paléziné non
plus sur ce qui relève proprement du
ministère de l'Intérieur et de son
action dans la politique de
l'intégration et je veux dire que nous
avons conformément à la demande du
Parlement mis en place à la fois le
programme agir d'intégration des
réfugiés mais aussi mis en place le
déploiement de l'application FRANCE visa
ce qui permet à nos concitoyens de notre
plus efficace pour l'obtention de leur
visa et du programme manette pour les
étrangers qui eux viennent sur le
territoire national qui jusqu'à présent
a besoin de trois rendez-vous en
préfecture pour avoir leurs papiers
alors qu'un seul rendez-vous va pouvoir
être fait à partir d'ailleurs à
commencer à être fait pour une grande
partie des départements enfin je
terminerai peut-être par là avant de
d'évoquer la le volet de ma salariale et
le constat de la Cour des comptes mais
j'ai déjà en partie répondu à ce sujet
dans l'hémicycle tout à l'heure je veux
souligner que depuis trois ans et donc
l'année du 22 était une année
particulièrement importante pour nous la
transformation numérique du ministère de
l'Intérieur a été engagé au ministère à
l'intérieur il y a une dette numérique
extrêmement importante sans doute un peu
semblable à celle que j'ai connu dans ce
que je suis arrivé à Bercy et que nous
avons mis en place un modernisation de
l'impôt et l'impôt à la source cette
date numérique était à la fois une dette
numérique du fait de l'organisation même
du service numérique du ministère d'un
intérieur je pourrais y revenir si vous
le souhaitez des projets qui avaient pas
été toujours suivis au bon niveau et
surtout sans doute une volonté de chaque
service de travail en silo et pas en
commun
se perdant ainsi parfois dans des
dépenses trop importantes pour des
résultats peu efficaces pour le service
public nous avons engagé les choses
différemment en réorganisant le
numérique au ministère de l'Intérieur je
reviendrai si vous le souhaitez avec
quelques exemples emblématiques de notre
efficacité en tout cas je l'espère et la
bonne utilisation de l'argent public le
réseau radio du futur qui va permettre
grosso modo de passer de radio physique
tel qu'on la connaît des policiers des
gendarmes des pompiers à la radio à la
radio numérique directement sur leur
téléphone Neo avec à la fois un certain
nombre de sujets d'applications de
géolocalisation ou d'image les
parlementaires qui ont participé à la
comité de liaison sur la locmi ont pu
avoir une démonstration je crois tout à
fait convaincante le sujet Nexis qui a
permis de révolutionner pour les 10 ce
qui n'est pas pu être révolutionné
notamment sur l'interopérabilité que
nous a bien manqué notamment lorsqu'on
voit des catastrophes celles que la
tempête Alex l'identité numérique qui a
été lancée en 2022 et qui est désormais
concrète comme vous l'avez sans doute vu
dans la presse et présenté au
parlementaire qui sont venus à ce comité
de liaison qui fait le permis de
conduire des matérialiser les pièces
d'identité des matérialisées demain la
procuration entièrement en ligne et puis
comme je l'ai dit France visa qui permet
de compatriotes qui demandent des visas
d'être plus beaucoup plus efficaces dans
le service dans le service public enfin
je donnerai par là monsieur le Président
sur les volets spécifique de la masse
salariale le médecin intérieur est un
ministère de masse salariale évidemment
vu les 250 000 policiers gendarmes qui
l'embauchent et vu
l'administration territoriale de l'État
et de ses nombreuses agences je veux
dire que nous n'avons pas la même
constat que la Cour des comptes sur une
partie évidemment de son de son constat
notamment sur les démissions j'ai
l'occasion de dire que nous avons eu à
la fois plus de départ du fait que les
policiers ou les gendarmes rentrer en
réussissant plus de concours puisque
nous avons augmenté de 40% de place dans
les concours de policiers de gendarmes
mais aussi plus de départ en retraite du
fait de la création de la réserve
opérationnelle on aura l'occasion sans
doute d'en reparler nous l'avons
d'ailleurs dit dans la lettre
complémentaire à la compte et compte je
veux aussi dire que nous avons un grand
enjeu au ministère de l'Intérieur parmi
de très nombreux enjeux qui est celui
évidemment de recruter beaucoup de
policiers beaucoup de gendarmes avec les
postes que vous nous avez offerts mais
aussi avec la pyramide des âges qui
comme dans tous les ministères
permet de recrutement désormais de
plusieurs milliers de personnes chaque
année pour garder un concours à la fois
dynamique évidemment une sélection qui
mérite d'être au rendez-vous de ce qu'on
attend des policiers des gendarmes
notamment je suis heureux de constater
que des premiers concours que nous avons
lancé avec ces masses plus importantes
de personnes à recruter nous ont gardé
le même nombre de personnes grosso modo
entre les places offertes et le nombre
de personnes qui passent ce concours
permettant ainsi de penser que bien sûr
indépendamment de la formation les
qualités des des jeunes gens souvent des
jeunes gens même si j'ai fait sauter les
barrières d'âge pour passer ses concours
sont de qualité équivalente au moins je
l'espère au recrutement précédent voilà
en quelques mots monsieur le Président
des crédits exécutés quasiment à
l'Europe
virgule près un besoin d'immobilier de
heurté de plus important qu'on doit
continuer à mettre en place et qui paye
la dette immobilière et d'être en
matériel que nous continuons à résorber
mais qui n'est pas totalement résorbé
une dette numérique que nous résorbons
et grâce au crédit de la locmin que nous
résorberons d'ici la fin du mandat et
une salariale qu'il faut évidemment
continuer à bien gérer le mieux possible
mais je voudrais souligner évidemment la
difficulté de Seiller cette masse
salariale dans la mesure où l'éclatée
partout sur le territoire national en
outre-mer dans beaucoup de services très
différents mais aussi à l'étranger où
les policiers des gendarmes servent dans
plusieurs opérations quel est engagée
l'État
merci Monsieur le Ministre on va donner
succession la parole aux rapporteur
spéciaux pour 5000 chacun commence avec
la mission administration général et
territoriale de l'État Charles de
Courson ce ministre monsieur le
Président ne sera pasteur général mes
chers collègues comme vous le savez la
mission administration générale des
territoires de l'État porte les crédits
et des emplois du réseau des préfectures
ainsi qu'une grande partie de
l'administration centrale du ministère
de l'Intérieur ces crédits ont été
exécutés à hauteur de 4 milliards 8 et 4
milliards 6 d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et en crédit de paiement ce
qui représente une consommation
supérieure de 9% aux AE votés en loi de
finance initiale et de 5% pour les
crédits de paiement cet écart provient
essentiellement de la surexécution des
crédits du programme 216 conduite et
pilotage des politiques de l'intérieur
sur lequel je reviendrai dans un instant
mais tout d'abord quelques mots sur le
plus gros programme de la mission qui
est le 354 administration territoriale
de l'État avec 2 milliards 5 d'euros de
dépenses en 2022 l'exécution de ses
crédits est conforme à la prévision et
ce malgré les aléas importants le
premier et l'accueil d'environ 100 000
réfugiés Ukrainiens qui ont fait
l'invasion de leur pays par la Russie à
partir de la fin du mois de février 2022
cet événement majeur en nécessité de
mobilisation rapide des services de
préfecture chargé d'instruire les
demandes d'autorisation provisoire de
séjour et c'est traduit par un
dépassement du souple à fond d'emploi de
presque 100 ETP financé par un
redéploiement au sein du ministère de
l'Intérieur l'autre arrière majeur
réside de la dégradation importante des
délais de l'ivrances des cartes
d'identité et des passeports le problème
que celui-ci pose dans la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens m'a
incité à y consacrer un rapport dans le
cadre du Printemps de l'évaluation
j'aurais donc l'occasion d'en parler de
manière plus approfondie tout à l'heure
avant de passer au programme suivant je
voudrais savoir Monsieur le Ministre
quelles sont les grandes orientations à
venir en matière de renforcement des
effectifs des préfectures j'ai le
souvenir qu'il était question d'un
réarmement lors du dernier PLF c'est en
tout cas un sujet que je compte suivre
de près pour la commission
maintenant au programme 232 ville
politique qui a connu une année
particulièrement importante puisqu'ici
sont déroulés les élections
présidentielles et législatives mais
aussi des élections territoriales dans
quatre collectivités d'outre-mer 489
millions d'euros ont été dépensés donc
414 pour l'organisation des élections je
me réjouis que nous ayons cette fois
évité le fiasco de la diffusion de la
propagande électorale qui avait entaché
le double scrutin local de l'année
précédente je regrette néanmoins que
cette défaillance dans la mise sous pli
et la distribution des professions de
foi lors des départementales des
régionales n'est pas été l'occasion de
revoir en profondeur ce système un peu
désuet j'avais eu l'occasion d'en
débattre lors du PLF et je ne peux que
renouveler mon appel à remettre à plat
les règles de diffusion de la propagande
électorale en particulier des
professions de foi ne faudrait-il pas
les digitaliser pour ceux qui
l'acceptent la suppression des bulletins
de vote à domicile est-ce bien utile de
les maintenir et puis la suppression des
affiches électorales car plus grand
monde
je viens les admirer en ce qui concerne
le troisième et dernier programme de la
mission le 216 conduite est pilotage des
politiques de l'Intérieur j'observe que
l'écart entre la réalisation et la
prévision résulte d'importantes dépenses
et engagement de dépenses en matière
numérique et immobilière l'apport de 368
millions d'euros du plan de relance en
AE et de 191 euros en CP est venu
combler cet écart pour terminer je
voudrais dire un mot sur le fond
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance le FIPD celui-ci est au cœur
d'une actualité brûlante si j'ose dire
qui est celle du fond Marianne il
semblerait qu'une partie des 2,5
millions d'euros de cet appel à projet
censé je cite promouvoir les valeurs
républicaines et combattent les discours
séparasites étaient détournés de son
objectif je rappelle que le parquet
national financier ouvert une
information judiciaire sur ce dossier et
que le Sénat s'est doté d'une commission
d'enquête à ce sujet de manière générale
j'aimerais savoir Monsieur le Ministre
comment est contrôler l'usage des lieux
publics dans le cadre du FIPD parce
qu'au fond c'est finalement de dont il
est question au delà de cette polémique
sur le fond Marianne en 2022 75 millions
d'euros ont été dépensés au titre du
FIPD dont 8 millions de provenaient du
plan de relance il s'agit
essentiellement de subventions versées à
des collectivités mais aussi à des
associations surtout si je me trompe pas
les appels à projets sont principalement
gérés au niveau départemental j'ose
espérer que l'affaire du fond Marianne
ne constitue qu'une exception voilà
quels étaient mes principales
observations concernant l'exécution des
crédits de la mission agte en 2022 je
vous remercie pour votre attention
pour la mission immigration asile et
intégration Stella Dupont Mathieu
Lefebvre
le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues avec Matthieu Lefebvre nous
allons vous présenter donc cette
exécution 2022 cette mission immigration
asile et intégration regroupe les
crédits alloués par l'État aux
politiques publiques pilotées par le
ministère de l'Intérieur en matière de
garantie de l'exercice du droit d'asile
de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière d'accueil des déplacés du
crâne d'accueil et d'indé d'intégration
des étrangers primo arrivants et des
procédures de naturalisation
ces crédits concernent deux programmes
le programme intégration et accès à la
nationalité programme 104 et le
programme immigration et asile le
programme 303 qui comporte les crédits
les plus importants
l'exécution 2022 se caractérise par des
dépenses toujours élevées les crédits
dédiés ont été exécutés à hauteur de 2
milliards 265 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 2 milliards
215 millions en crédit de paiement soit
des montants supérieurs à ceux ouverts
par la loi de finances initiale après
deux années marquées par la crise
sanitaire au cours de laquelle les
dépenses ont connu une baisse les
crédits exécutés ont subi les
conséquences d'une part du conflit en
Ukraine et donc de l'accueil des
déplacés du crâne et d'autre part d'une
demande d'asile soutenue
s'agissant du programme 104 celui-ci a
été sur exécuté de 45 millions d'euros
si on raisonne hors fonds de concours
européen et son exécution n'appelle pas
d'observation particulière hormis les
débuts comme vous l'avez évoqué monsieur
le ministre les débuts de la mise en
œuvre du programme agir conçue pour
permettre un accompagnement personnalisé
des réfugiés nous aurons une question
sur ce point en revanche le programme
303 concentre l'essentiel des crédits et
de nos questions également et je laisse
Matthieu Lefebvre vous les présenter
sur le président monsieur le ministre
d'abord on tient à s'associer à
l'hommage que vous avez rendu aux
policiers décédés dans le Nord on parle
là de chiffres il s'agit là de vies
humaines et nous souhaitons nous y
associer donc s'agissant du programme
303 programme qui soutient le
fonctionnement de l'offre propre la
garantie de l'exercice du droit d'asile
et la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière donc en 2022 le programme a
également servi de support à la forte
mobilisation du ministère en faveur de
l'accueil des déplacés du crâne et ce
programme a connu une surexécution de
275 millions d'euros qui est
principalement imputable donc à
l'accueil des déplacés mais aussi au
niveau élevé des dépenses en faveur des
demandeurs d'asile le coût de l'accueil
des déplacés d'Ukraine est estimé à 472
millions d'euros qui est réparti entre
254 millions d'euros de dépenses
d'hébergement et 20018 millions d'euros
de dépenses d'allocations nous saluons à
ce titre la remarquable mobilisation du
ministère de l'Intérieur de la
coordination qui a été effectuée mais
aussi du monde associatif ainsi que la
société civile en faveur de cet accueil
il s'agissant des demandeurs d'asile le
coût de l'accueil s'est estimé à un peu
plus de 1,2 milliards d'euros répartis
entre 990 millions d'euros de dépenses
d'hébergement et un peu moins de 300
millions d'euros de dépenses
d'allocations les crédits soutenant la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
ont été sous exécutées mais en raison
essentiellement d'un retard un but dans
la réalisation de nouveaux
investissements pour l'aménagement de
nouveaux centres de rétention
administratives à l'inverse et c'est à
saluer les frais d'éloignement des
étrangers en situation irrégulière ont
connu une augmentation significative
grâce à votre action volontariste
puisqu'elles sont passées de 21 millions
d'euros en crédit de paiement en 2021 à
31 millions d'euros en 2022 et sur ce
point je veux saluer la reprise
significative des éloignements observés
au cours de l'année 2022 avec deux
chiffres en 2022 on a eu 11400
éloignement forcés contre 10100 en 2021
qu'on regarde de ces éléments on a
plusieurs questions qui relèvent
essentiellement du programme 303
monsieur le ministre
quels sont vos prévisions de
consommation concernant la location pour
demander d'asile notamment dans son
volet relatif au déplacé du crâne est-ce
que vous nous confirmez par ailleurs que
cette dépense sera comme l'an passé
financée en interministériel
s'agissant toujours du programme 303
quels sont vos prévisions de
consommation concernant l'action 3
relative à la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière et une question relative au
programme 104 pour connaître où on en
est précisément du déploiement du
programme agir
merci pour la mission sécurité police
gendarmerie nationale sécurité routière
compte d'affectation spéciale contrôle
de la circulation et du stationnement
routier madame Nadia
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre permettez-moi
également de joindre ma voie l'émotion
collective suite au décès tragique des
trois policiers à Roubaix rappelons-nous
que ce dont nous traitons aujourd'hui
n'est pas qu'une question technique ou
budgétaire mais c'est une question ou
l'humain domine où le service public
dans ce qu'il a de plus noble à savoir
le service de l'intérêt général et qui
est au cœur de ces nobles métiers en
tant que rapporteur spécial je me
réjouis tout comme vous monsieur le
ministre de constater que l'année 2022
est en ce qui concerne cette mission
considérée par la Cour des comptes comme
une année à la gestion réussie ne
présente présentant pas de sous
budgétisation ni de tension majeure en
effet les crédits de force de sécurité
intérieure et de sécurité routière
représente en 2022 près de 97% des
crédits de paiement exécutés les
dépenses d'investissement n'en ont pas
moins progresser de 46% en crédit de
paiement et 18% en autorisation
d'engagement grâce à une dotation
initiale en hausse sensible de
6,7% en AE et 4,1% en CP je me bornerai
à quelques remarques sur chacun des
trois programmes et sur le compte
d'affectation spéciale contrôle de la
circulation et du stationnement routier
les crédits exécutés du programme 152
gendarmerie nationale connaissent une
progression de 440 millions d'euros en
CP soit environ 4,8% par rapport à 2021
l'écart au montant prévu en loi de
finances initiale et modérée s'élevant à
2% en CP 0,4 ans en AE et si les
dépenses de fonctionnement progressent
de 5,1% en AE et de 13,2% CP la hausse
des investissements est bien plus
sensible
71,6% pour les autorisations
d'engagement et 34,4% pour les crédits
de paiement l'acquisition de véhicules
constitue le premier poste
d'investissement de la gendarmerie
nationale qui a pu commander 90
véhicules blindés polyvalents et 459
véhicules de maintien de l'ordre et les
opérations immobilières demeurent le
deuxième poste d'investissement les
analyses de la Cour des comptes
appellent toutefois de notre attention
sur les emplois mais vous l'avez déjà
évoqué monsieur le ministre donc des
emplois qui représentent 85 % des
dépenses du programme tant les sorties
que les entrées ont été comme en 2021
plus nombreuses que prévu et le schéma
d'emploi réalisé est en retrait de 31
ETP par rapport à une programmation de
154 ETP le plafond d'emploi qui s'élevé
à 110
348 équivalentes plein travaillé a été
consommé à hauteur de 99 754 serait
notamment cause une concurrence avec les
polices municipales et la hausse des
détachements vers d'autres
administrations peut-être que vous ne le
confirmerez monsieur le monsieur le
ministre d'importants efforts ont certes
été fournis au cours de précédents
quinquennat mais nous devons quand même
toutefois rester je pense attentif aux
emplois d'autant que les vacances qui
résultent d'une importante rotation du
personnel réduisent le potentiel
opérationnel des forces de sécurité
comme des secrétaires comme le souligne
la Cour des comptes mais vous avez vous
êtes également très attentif sur ce
point comme vous l'avez rappelé dans vos
propos liminaires
estimant aussi que l'attractivité la
fidélisation ne peuvent être assurées
par les seules revalorisations
indemnitaires dont l'effectivité
apparaît ici limitée la Cour des comptes
insiste sur la nécessité d'une
amélioration des conditions de travail
des personnels et de d'une gestion
dynamique des ressources humaines
pouvons-nous monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer l'état de vos
réflexions sur cette question qui
concerne aussi bien la police que la
gendarmerie et j'en viens précisément
programme 176 comme l'an dernier le
montant exécuté en l'occurrence de 12,14
milliards d'euros en a eux et 11,8
milliards d'euros en CP est extrêmement
proche de la programmation initiale et
les deux principaux postes
d'investissement sont comme pour la
gendarmerie mais dans un ordre inversé
l'immobilier et les véhicules les
emplois représentent 87% des dépenses du
programme et son marquées comme les
emplois de la gendarmerie par une légère
sous-exécution du plafond d'emploi et du
schéma d'emploi pour terminer un mot sur
la sécurité routière les crédits de
paiement exécutés du programme 207
progresse de 22,2% en CP c'est autant
d'argent qui consacrait à sauver plus de
vie sur les routes si elles ajoutent les
crédits de du compte d'affectation
spéciale contrôle de la circulation et
du stationnement routier et après deux
années marquées par la pandémie du covid
19 et les restrictions de circulation
qu'elle a imposées les recettes d'amants
de la circulation ont progressé de 243
millions d'euros et du point de vue de
des dépenses à la forte sous-exécution
de l'année 2021 succède une exécution
très proche de la programmation initiale
pour atteindre un montant de près de 1,5
milliards d'euros se casse est parfois
décrié sa suppression pure et simple et
parfois évoquée donc j'aimerais monsieur
le ministre que vous nous évoquez les
évolutions qui peuvent être prises dans
le sens d'une simplification de ce
casque parce que les tentatives sont
nombreuses et donc nous aimerions avoir
votre avis là-dessus je vous remercie
merci pour la mission Sécurité Civile
Monsieur Florian chauche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues avec l'intensité de
la saison des feux 2022 termes de moins
en moins adapté au regard de l'extension
temporelle du risque incendie les
crédits de la sécurité civile ont
largement été mis à contribution je
tiens à rappeler ici que les crédits du
programme 161 dont je suis le rapporteur
c'est-à-dire les crédits de l'État ne
représentent qu'une petite part des
dépenses de sécurité civile la majorité
de ces dépenses est emportée par les 10
ainsi partant de 568 millions d'euros
prévus en loi de finances initiale
l'exécution du programme sécurité civile
a été porté après de 653 millions
d'euros soit une hausse de près de 15%
du principalement au feu de forêt
dévastateurs que nous a reconnu il en
effet fallu augmenter fortement les
dépenses d'entretien des moyens aériens
acheter davantage de produits retardants
ou encore mobilisés 20 colonnes de
renfort de plus qu'en temps normal ces
dépenses supplémentaires n'ont pas été
assez anticipées par le gouvernement
comme en témoigne l'ouverture nette de
près de 40 millions d'euros en loi de
finances rectificative ou le dégel total
de la réserve de précaution
et encore le gouvernement a pu se
reposer sur d'importants reports de
crédit de l'année précédente près de 70
millions d'euros ainsi qu'une sous
exécution substantielle décritée des
crédits liés à la lutte contre la
pandémie de covid-19 le niveau très
élevé de consommation de crédit 96,6%
témoigne par ailleurs de l'absence de
marge de manœuvre budgétaire dont nous
disions sur ce sujet en 2021 déjà la
Cour des comptes alerté sur le risque
d'un programme budgétaire
particulièrement rigide alors même que
la vocation du programme et de gérer des
crises qui sont donc par nature
imprévisibles l'année de 2022 constitue
donc un véritable signal d'alarme pour
les moyens de notre sécurité civile
qu'il nous faut prendre au sérieux je
vous ai souvent entendu monsieur le
ministre évoqué la saison 2022 comme une
saison exceptionnelle une saison qui
sortirait donc de l'ordinaire hors du
fait du changement climatique ce type de
saison en matière d'incendie relèvera de
ma bien plus de la norme que de
l'exception lorsque j'ai visité la base
aérienne de la sécurité civile à Nîmes
sera d'ailleurs indiqué que l'année 2022
avait été marquée par une activité
intense mais moindre que pour les années
2017 et 2003 par exemple
j'ajouterai que cette saison 2022 aurait
pu et dû être mieux anticipé en effet
dès 2010 un rapport de la Mission
interministérielle indiqué déjà qu'une
augmentation de 30 % des surfaces
sensibles se traduirait pour une
augmentation des coûts d'au moins 20%
d'ici 2040 la mission recommandée
notamment d'adapter le dimensionnement
de la flotte à une extension du risque
sur le territoire national si je salue
vos annonces de renouvellement de la
flotte de Canadair ainsi que des
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile je
regrette néanmoins que des efforts
d'investissement n'aient pas été
réalisés plus tôt et que nous nous
retrouvions désormais au pied du mur
j'ai pourtant constaté que les
rapporteurs spéciaux qui m'ont précédé
avaient eux aussi alerté sur le
vieillissement de la flotte le surco en
matière de maintenance en condition
opérationnelle ou encore le non-respect
du contrat opérationnel pour les
hélicoptères
du fait des délais de livraison les
moyens aériens de la sécurité civile
donc monteront donc pas avant plusieurs
années 2027 2028 probablement et nos
forces de sécurité civile vont donc
devoir faire face à une extension
géographique et une intensification du
risque incendie avec des moyens
insuffisants c'est exécution budgétaire
2022 doit constituer un tournant en
matière de budget de la Sécurité civile
nous devons mieux anticiper j'ai donc
plus plusieurs questions pour vous
monsieur le ministre question que je
n'ai pas pu poser dans le cadre du PLF
au-delà des investissements annoncés
avez-vous prévu d'augmenter le budget
général de fonctionnement de la sécurité
civile en conséquence pour ce qui est de
la flotte aérienne au-delà du
renouvellement des Canadairs envisagés
envisagez-vous pardon l'achat
d'hélicoptère lourd bombardier d'eau
hélicoptère qui sont régulièrement loués
ou réquisitionnés par la DGS CGC mais
aussi par de nombreuses 10 ne serait-il
pas judicieux de procéder à l'achat de
ce type d'aéronef
celui sur la disponibilité des moyens
aériens et différents pour les avions et
les hélicoptères et ne permet pas de
distinguer entre une indisponibilité
résultant d'une surutilisation de celle
découlant d'une indisponibilité
mécanique ou occidentale aussi une mise
à jour de ces indicateurs utiles à la
représentation nationale est-elle à
l'ordre du jour je vous remercie pour
votre attention
merci
on vient maintenant vous rapporter pour
avis j'en ai au moins identifié un Hugo
bernalicis rapporteur pour la commission
des lois sur mission administration
général territoire de l'État 2 minutes
bien merci monsieur le Président de me
donner la parole oui sur le budget
administration général des territoires
de l'État l'année 2022 est une année un
peu
quitte au tournant de l'année 2021
l'année 2023 évidemment mais surtout
d'une politique de se dire que la
dématérialisation a pu être peut-être un
peu trop avancé sur les années
précédentes et de se dire qu'il fallait
remettre des effectifs
opérationnels les effectifs humains au
contact des
usagers et des usagers sur un certain
nombre de procédures dans le cadre de ce
budget administration général et
territoire de l'État qui qui évidemment
concerne les préfectures les
sous-préfectures mais aussi les certes
pour les cartes grises et autres types
de procédures dématérialisés or on
constate dans l'exécution du budget 2022
que sur le programme 354 on a une très
faible augmentation en nombre de TPT
et que cette très faible augmentation au
nombre de TPT est en réalité la
traduction
de d'effectif supplémentaire dégagé sous
forme de vacation de contrats à durée
déterminée pour pallier à des pics
d'activités c'est ce qui est inscrit
dans le rapport annuel de de performance
et qui était déjà d'ailleurs décrié par
le rapport de la Cour des comptes sur le
périmètre préfecture sous-préfecture qui
pointait du doigt un recours excessif au
contrat dit infra annuel augmentant de
fait le coût global de fonctionnement du
ministère sans pour autant avoir une
qualité de service qui était qui est qui
soit au rendez-vous et qui était
pourtant la qualité de service qu'on
avait auparavant avec des fonctionnaires
titulaires dans les différentes
administrations je dis au tournant
puisque la promesse nous a été faite
lors du vote du budget 2022 que en 2023
tout ça ce serait terminé qu'il y aurait
des effectifs supplémentaires et qu'en
fin nous pourrions avoir accès à des
êtres humains pour pouvoir faire les
démarches administratives or quand on
voit l'exécution du budget 2022 on est
resté dans la même trajectoire la
réalité c'est que nous sommes dans la
même trajectoire donc la question se
pose monsieur le ministre avons-nous un
changement de trajectoire sur
administration générale et territoire de
l'État pour enfin avoir des êtres
humains pour pouvoir faire des démarches
administratives merci je crois qu'il y a
pas d'autres rapporteurs pour avis
la parole la parole est à moi juste
avant de passer la parole aux rapporteur
général
quelques quelques interrogations
monsieur mise et comme je vous êtes à
côté de moi j'en profite aussi pour
parler d'avenir
et de budget à venir il y a j'ai lu dans
dans pas mal de médias que l'objectif de
la première ministre était des baisses
demandées des des efforts de 5% dans les
différents ministères et j'ai cru
comprendre que ce n'était pas votre
intention donc j'aimerais bien avoir
là-dessus un éclaircissement de votre
part je pense que ça pourrait intéresser
tout le monde
il va y avoir tout à l'heure un point
sur la question l'incendie mais en fait
les incendies de la sécheresse et de
tout ce qui est provoqué j'allais dire
par les questions climatiques je
j'épuiserai pas longtemps parce que
Florian chauche a pesé pas mal de
questions là-dessus mais en gros
effectivement je suis de ceux qui
considèrent 2022 malheureusement ne sera
pas une exception et que on va avoir à
faire face notamment à des incendies
malheureusement dans des départements ou
autrefois il a été même pas imaginable
qu'il en soit ainsi et donc il y a des
moyens de sécurité civile d'incendie etc
qui seront qui seront évidemment très
importants sont même parler de des
autres catastrophes qui peuvent survenir
par exemple des catastrophes climatiques
en plein été comme ça a eu lieu
notamment encore avec avec quasiment un
cyclone en Méditerranée je pense que
tout ça il va falloir se dire que ça va
malheureusement se répéter année après
année et j'aurais voulu avoir un regard
de votre part justement sur les
financements à mettre en place pour ne
pas pouvoir simplement l'anticiper mais
le réparer voilà donc
je joins mes questions à celle de
Florent le chouch j'ai aussi des
questions j'ai entendu que vous y allez
sur le fait d'avoir un seul rendez-vous
en préfecture bon je pourrais être
honnête j'attends de voir parce que
dans le département de la Seine
il faut beaucoup beaucoup de temps
d'attente pour avoir un rendez-vous en
préfecture je sais qu'il y a des efforts
qui sont faits mais que ce temps
d'attente souvent fait que les personnes
qui demandent un rendez-vous se
retrouvent en situation illégale bien
avec toutes les problématiques que ça
peut
ça peut induire évidemment de d'angoisse
etc c'est quasiment un des thèmes les
plus importants pour ma part dans ma
circonscription les gens viennent me
voir donc là aussi je voudrais savoir si
à partir du moment où vous estimez quel
avenir un rendez-vous sera nécessaire
est-ce que si c'est pas le cas est-ce
qu'on devrait pas avoir une espèce
d'obligation de résultats de l'État qui
fait que quand il y a pas de rendez-vous
donné avant le dépassement d'un certain
délai bah ça vaut à vie positif pour les
personnes qui ont demandé ce ce
rendez-vous parce que ça devient
insupportable vous avez parlé des JO et
vous savez aussi ma circonscription est
très concernée par les Jeux Olympiques
et là aussi j'ai une interrogation sur
les JO nous allons avoir pourquoi parce
qu'on nous a parlé des JO solidaires
écologiques qui sont ouverts à tout le
monde et moi ce que je constate c'est
qu'on parle et vous l'avez dit vous-même
pas mal de déploiement sécuritaire y
compris je le crains à lire certains
journaux par rapport à des populations
de Seine-Saint-Denis notamment des
jeunes qui sont quasiment ciblés à
l'avance comme étant pouvant être des
fauteurs de tout alors que théoriquement
les jeux devraient le retrouver voilà et
donc je m'interroge là-dessus et je
m'interroge aussi sur le coup du
dispositif pour
la cérémonie d'ouverture en gros est-ce
que on n'est pas en train de trop voir
trop grand pour une cérémonie
d'ouverture par rapport au coût que ça
va générer compris en termes de moyens
humains aujourd'hui mobilisable et là
aussi c'est une interrogation est-ce
qu'il pourrait pas en rabattre un peu
pour trouver un compromis acceptable
ma dernière question c'est sur tout ce
qui concerne on y reviendra tout à
l'heure je crois avec un rapport mais je
voulais à me le dire sur les questions
d'immigration bon
il va on va très certainement avoir un
débat dans les mois à venir
moi je considère que
selon les chiffres qui expliquent
qu'entre 2000 2020 il y a 36 %
d'augmentation
d'étrangers en France immigration qui à
peu près la moitié moins que la moyenne
européenne et encore moins que la
moyenne en Europe je considère que le
premier principal problème de
l'immigration c'est le problème de
l'accueil voilà je sais qu'en disant ça
je vais
à rebours de certaines discours et que
notamment j'observe que l'an dernier
l'immigration c'est 54% d'étudiants 27%
pour le travail parce qu'on a besoin de
migrants au niveau du travail et c'est
un constat qui se fait un peu partout et
24% de refuge très peu par exemple pour
les regroupements familiaux je crois que
c'est 4% l'ensemble des titres et donc
la question moi je j'observe que très
souvent on a des gens qui se retrouvent
dans des situations pendant de recherche
d'hébergement
de recherche de lieu qui ont y compris
sont en sont des demandeurs d'asile ou
en tout cas qui sont dans le dans le
dans le parcours d'une vente d'asile et
qui se retrouvent des fois grâce aux
associations qui se retrouvent à
dépendre seulement des associations du
et des citoyens qui veulent bien s'en
occuper donc voilà moi j'interroge sur
les moyens notamment à l'OFI lefras sur
les moyens en terme de cada est-ce que
vous croyez pas qu'il devrait y avoir
une augmentation des moyens de ce point
de vue là de centre d'hébergement
d'urgence c'est-à-dire de tout ce qui
permet un accueil digne de ce nom
administratif de de d'urgence
hébergement etc même si je conçois que
la question qui se pose de l'hébergement
qui est un problème du logement global
de part poser évidemment sur votre sol
ministère pas de souci là-dessus mais
est-ce que vous avez là-dessus un retour
à me faire sur le rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci infiniment pour votre
présentation merci au rapporteur
spéciaux chers collègues
sur d'abord je voudrais m'installer
les fonctionnaires qui
œuvrent notre sécurité quotidienne et
qui sont au service des Français
évidemment avoir une pensée particulière
pour les trois policiers qui ont été
tués cette semaine sur la mission
administration générale et territoriale
de l'État le plafond
d'équivalent en plein été légèrement
dépassé cette année par rapport à en
2022 par rapport à ce qui était prévu
aux particuliers pour réagir à l'accueil
des réfugiés
ukrainiens et puis pour réduire les
délais de délivrance des titres
d'identité je pense que c'est une bonne
chose que l'État a été élu cette cette
souplesse vous aviez monsieur ministre
évoqué l'idée enfin mis comme point
stratégique de renforcer les effectifs
dans les sous-préfectures et les
préfectures est-ce que dans les chiffres
2022 cette tendance à plus déjà se ce
remarquer et quels sont vos prévisions
pour les prochaines années ce que c'est
toujours dans votre petite que de
renforcer les services de l'état des
concentrés sur la mission intégration
asile et immigration
l'exécution a été là aussi supérieure à
ce qui était prévu dans un contexte de
hausse des bandes d'asile et de guerre
en Ukraine le programme 104 45 millions
de surexécution le programme 303 Asie
l'immigration c'est 273 millions de
surexcution bon malgré cette
surconsommation des crédits que l'on
comprend la Cour des comptes la
considéré que les pouvoirs publics ont
bien réagi face à la situation
ukrainienne et que l'exécution de la
mission était était sincère donc merci
pour ça quel est votre prévision de de
l'effort en 2023 par rapport à cet
efforts exceptionnel qui a été fait en
2022 sur le programme sécurité civile là
aussi vous êtes adapté par rapport à un
certain nombre de risques évidemment
n'était pas prévu par définition en
début d'année sur les feux de forêt dans
le cas des lois de finance rectificative
1 et 2 on a porté les crédits à
pratiquement 10 millions d'euros
ça s'est traduit en particulier au
travers des investissements sur les
avions supplémentaires sur des
hélicoptères
supplémentaires voilà monsieur le
ministre
le réchauffement climatique provoque une
intensification des saisons de feu un
peu partout en France l'état répond
présent en pélèbre 2023 il y a une
hausse historique du pack capacité qui a
été voté avec 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires moi je salue évidemment
cet effort pour pour les 10 c'est ce que
vous pouvez nous détailler un tout petit
peu cet effort enfin sur la mission
sécurité
la Cour des comptes précise là aussi que
ce fut une année à la gestion réussie
présentant pas de sous budgétisation ni
de tension
majeure vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure
99,7% d'exécution des programmes ce qui
est assez remarquable de finesse et de
précision ça s'est traduit en
particulier par
une démontant de 21,44 milliards de
crédit
le crédit de paiement donc pour la
police à gendarmerie nationale je peux
vous dire là aussi que ça c'est vu si
c'est vous le permettez l'expression
j'ai de nombreux témoignages
de policiers de gendarmes sur leur
équipement personnel sur les véhicules
cet effort c'est traduit très
concrètement pour pour eux la question
porte et vous l'avez légèrement évoqué
tout à l'heure sur l'effet d'éditions
qu'il peut y avoir entre les frais
personnel et les frais d'investissement
les frais d'investissement étant lieu
sujet à avec une tension forte sur les
matériaux donc c'est un objet qui
augmente un peu plus vite comme voilà
comment vous avez en 2022 gérer cet
effet d'éviction et quels sont vos
prévisions pour 2023 je vous remercie
bien monsieur le ministre je vais vous
poser de répondre aux intervenants et
c'est évident que je m'associe moi aussi
à l'hommage rendu à Paul Manon et Steven
les trois policiers de Roubaix qui sont
décédés
il y a maintenant deux jours dans le
Nord suite un accident commis par un
chauffard qui était dans l'état
manifestement dans lequel n'aurait
jamais dû prendre son véhicule monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
une remarque criminaire pour dire que
quelques-uns d'entre vous sur les divers
sujets évoqués le fait que les crédits
inscrits en début d'année souvent
discuter comme chacun de ces au mois
d'octobre novembre et élaboré dans les
ministères à partir du mois de mai juin
ne correspond pas toujours à ce qui
s'est passé dans l'année budgétaire 2022
je constate que c'est vrai dans toute
gestion
particulièrement au ministère de
l'Intérieur ministère de crise il en est
puisqu'il gère les crises qu'il s'agit
de crise de sécurité de sécurité civile
ou d'accueil des étrangers et donc il
est très difficile de prévoir de prévoir
l'avenir
même paraît-il notre damus n'était pas
tout à fait aussi exact comme il aurait
été à la place du directeur de la
science financière du ministère ce qui
n'est pas prévu pour le nouveau des
papilles que je veux ici saluer pour
pour son premier jour de l'arrivée oui
ça à l'intérieur mais voilà je m'excuse
si jamais les crises correspondent pas
toujours à aux prévisions en tout cas ce
que je peux dire c'est que nous avions
prévu malgré tout les crédits
budgétaires pour ces crises on ne savait
pas lesquelles puisque encore une fois
malgré ces crises 99% de crédit consommé
donc on a su je crois être à la fois
souple parmi des programmes et souples
dans l'utilisation budgétaire ceci étant
dit vous m'avez posé des questions
précises sur beaucoup de sujets
peut-être répondre à monsieur le
Président de la Commission d'abord sur
une question peut-être un peu
existentielle on va dire sur est-ce
qu'on doit ou pas baisser les crédits 5%
de du ministère de l'intérieur j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'écrire à La Prairie je
regrette que les échanges que je peux
après administrés avec les ministres en
charge du grand public soit soit dans la
presse mais paraît-il que générale de
Gaulle disait décrivait jamais rien que
vous ne voulez pas avoir écrit dans le
Canard Enchaîné bon donc j'assume bien
volontiers ce que j'écris je considère
monsieur le Président de la Commission
que lorsqu'elle notre programmation que
c'est la première votée dans le
quinquennat et que les parlementaires
donnent très large majorité au Sénat et
à l'Assemblée nationale leur
consentement sur des crédits en
augmentation et pesé par des arbitrages
qui ont été eux-mêmes annoncés par
présent de la République voilà deux ans
c'est 15 une augmentation que oui il n'y
a pas à raboter de l'autre programmation
votées parce que sinon je vais
programmation savent pas grand chose
c'est pas pareil que lorsque vous avez
inscrit des crédits budgétaires et qu'on
vous demande de faire des efforts
budgétaires en général j'ai été misé
compliqué pendant trois ans je n'ai
jamais raboté je l'ai fait des
propositions de rabotage de l'autre
programmation en portant il y avait la
représentation militaire qui avait été
voté il y avait une autre formation de
la justice qui avait été votée et si
jamais des crédits avaient été non ce
n'est pas c'est pas vrai
c'était une sous-exécution du ministère
de la Justice qui n'avait pas à dépenser
son argent sur les projets immobiliers
de construction de prison ça n'a rien à
voir avec des crédits à voter pour des
raisons des régions du budgétaires et
une autre formation de la recherche qui
n'a jamais été rabotée donc je pars du
principe ce président de la commission
pour répondre parfaitement votre
question c'est ce que j'ai dit à Madame
La Prairie le ministre en charge de
l'économie des finances et des comptes
publics que pour ma part il me
paraissait pas de bonne politique de
raboter les crédits de loi de
programmation de la première année
d'exécution budgétaire bon je crois que
le ministre le corps nu en ce moment
même en train de défendre des crédits
pour la programmation militaire qu'on
soit pas d'accord sur ce sujet Quel
existence pour les parlementaires si
jamais la programmation qui sont censées
être un une sorte de priorité mis en
place par le gouvernement sur tel ou tel
sujet
serait donné si jamais nous les rabots
de sciences tout de suite ensuite le
gouvernement est notamment les mises en
charge des dépôts publics feront leurs
arbitrages bien évidemment mais je pense
pas que ce soit le sujet sur lequel on
doit s'orienter la difficulté peut-être
c'est qu'être droit passion et que du
coup ça régidifie les budgets de l'État
ça c'est un autre un autre sujet mais je
pense que ça laissera dans la réflexion
de votre commission des finances la
suite des événements donc voilà je ne
pense pas qu'il faille raboter de 5% les
crédits je passerai par dire que par
ailleurs faire un rabotage général mais
jamais une bonne solution budgétaire en
tout cas c'est ce que je crois avoir
compris que c'est parce que j'ai demandé
non non j'entends bien mais je vous ai
compris que c'était
mais j'ai évidemment nous rentrons dans
le cycle de discussion budgétaire et je
n'ai pas encore eu cette discussion en
charge de l'économie et des finances
mais je me suis permis de lui écrire
puisqu'il n'avait écrit donc on se
répondait par écrit ceci étant dit
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances de poser d'autres questions
au moins moins philosophiques mais tout
aussi important de voir plus importantes
sur la question des financement de la
Sécurité civile je répondrai en
répondant à monsieur le rapporteur
serait d'accord cela réforme des temps
sur les préfectures et sur le fait que
vous étiez de la nef je peux comprendre
que vous étiez mais j'espère demain vous
rassurer merci d'avoir souligné le fait
que notamment Seine-Saint-Denis malgré
les difficultés importantes qu'on les
agents de la préfecture de syndic qui
font un travail très très important mais
dans les deux sous préfectures qui sont
également équipés si j'ose dire pour
répondre à demander administratif des
étrangers en France les fils physiques
ont été souvent remplacés par des films
numériques et donc du coup effectivement
on crée les difficultés pour les agents
comme pour les personnes qui demandent
des papiers et parfois c'est la propre
incurie de de l'État qui met en
situation régulière des personnes qui
demandent des papiers vous avez
parfaitement raison et c'est évidemment
quelque chose de tout à fait
inacceptable sans aller sur votre
proposition qui consiste à dire qu'il
dit mot consent qui ne pourrait pour
plein de raisons y compris de sécurité
pas être acceptable je comprends votre
interrogation et c'est la réforme de
préfecture que je propose à la première
ministre qui consiste en effet alors
avec ou sans la loi immigration comme il
n'y a rien de législatif je l'ai lancé
avant même d'attendre discussion de la
loi immigration qui je l'espère sera
inscrite en deux jours de vos assemblées
très bientôt du fait que nous devons
changer le nombre d'agents
la place des agents de préfecture pour
être moins présent sur la le primo la
primo demande ou le renouvellement de
cette demande mais plus sur les
contrôles les personnes qui peuvent
poser des questions d'ordre public ou
qui auraient ici ou là pas été accepté
sur le long terme sur le territoire
national et donc sans doute faut-il à la
fois avec les projets informatiques que
nous lançons et la nef je peux vous
l'assurer on vous en fera la
démonstration si vous souhaitez
simplifie grandement le travail des
agents et donc des personnes qui
demandent des papiers puisque de trois
rendez-vous on passe à un seul ce qui
est bien moi je souhaite même passer à 0
pour les renouvellements je pense par
rapport au Shibani ou aux personnes qui
sont depuis très longtemps sur le
territoire national et qui doivent
renouveler sans cesse leur demande alors
qu'on sait tous qui sont là depuis très
longtemps qu'ils ont 80 ans que ça pose
pas de problème particulier les faire
revenir en préfecture me pose même une
question finalement d'éthique vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de donc il y a une réforme
très importante qui serait mis en place
cette année je pourrais tout à fait vous
présenter au lien que la commission des
lois qui j'espère répondra en très
grande partie à votre sujet ce qui me
permet de répondre aussi à monsieur de
Courson notamment et Monsieur bernalicis
aussi c'est la première fois que nous
réaugmentons les nombres de personnes au
sein de l'administration territoriale de
l'État quand je suis arrivé au ministère
de l'intérieur ça faisait 32 ans de
suite qu'il y avait des suppressions de
poste dans les préfectures et les
sous-préfectures 32 ans de suite les
deux premières années de mon ministère
grâce aux arbitrages rendus par le
premier sketex sur ma proposition on a
fait 0 suppression d'emploi alors
c'était la première fois que ça stagné
alors vous me diriez c'était pas très
glorieux parce que beaucoup de baisses
mais c'était déjà ça et c'est dans
l'autre programmation d'où l'intérêt de
l'autre programmation prévoit 350
effectifs en plus à la TV en faut-il
davantage c'est à regarder évidemment
l'utilisateur que je suis il peut
toujours demander des emplois
supplémentaires mais aussi une grande
numérisation du travail de l'État je ne
partage pas les propos de Monsieur
bernalicis puisque il a l'air d'avoir
considéré qu'il y a deux types de
personnes il y a ceux qui seraient
fonctionnaires qui rendra un bon service
public il y aurait des contractuels qui
rendraient un mauvais service public
c'est oublier un peu vite qu'il y a 20%
de contractuels déjà dans la fonction
publique et qui a aussi des contractuels
qui font un travail très important qui
risque leur vie je ne vous ai pas
interrompu monsieur bernalis non ce que
je veux dire à vous-même c'est que les
militaires prenons parti sont des
contractuels et pour autant ils pensent
qu'ils rendent un bon service public
puisqu'ils la première fois jusqu'à pour
la patrie donc je pense que le côté faut
des humains il y aurait des mauvais et
des bons fonctionnaires ou des bons et
mauvaises agences service public je
partage pas évidemment c'est c'est
propos sur la question des JO ça coûte
monsieur le Président 200 millions
d'euros pour le ministère de l'Intérieur
d'organiser des Jeux Olympiques et des
Jeux paralympiques du point de la
sécurité puisque ma question à moi c'est
la question de la sécurité ce que je
suis en charge la sécurité je n'ai pas
le coût complet pour le jour de la
cérémonie d'ouverture mais je pourrais
tout à fait vous le fournir tu avais
quelques mois encore sans doute de
travail et et d'affirmation de ce coup
mais évidemment dans ce qui nous
concerne il est pour l'instant compris
dans ces 200 millions sachant qu'on
n'est pas les seuls organisé à celle de
l'ouverture le caujo à l'essentiel de
cette organisation avec des recettes
d'ailleurs sur les kebabs puisqu'elle
est des billets payés pour les gens pour
venir dans les cent mille places des
kebabs de la Seine et puis évidemment la
ville de Paris qui contribue aussi
grandement à cette organisation mais
pour le ministère d'intérieur nous avons
inscrit 200 millions d'euros sur sur une
année budgétaire pour organiser les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques alors vous
posez la question de savoir est-ce que
c'est pas des jeux trop sécuritaires bon
moi il m'appartient pas de juger les
choix artistiques du Comité olympique ou
du dossier de candidature déposé en 2016
ou des engagements de mes prédécesseurs
je pense évidemment à Manuel Valls à
Bernard cazen il m'appartient de les
appliquer et de vous garantir la
sécurité de concitoyens et les risques
d'aujourd'hui pour votre département à
singulièrement pour la Seine-Saint-Denis
je ne pense pas monsieur le Président on
en reparlera bien volontiers qu'il
s'agit de cibler tel ou telle population
bien au contraire je pense et vous êtes
le premier à me le demander moi je fais
pas de lien entre délinquants ces jeunes
vous le faites manifestement madame la
députée mais moi je ne le fais pas
attendez je propose qui est pas en
commission à distance on le fait pas et
je propose qu'on le fasse pas voilà
merci on continue merci monsieur le
Président c'est un héritage que de
souhaitons
c'est un héritage que nous souhaitons
laisser y compris au département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis que de limiter
évidemment la délinquance ou le désordre
public d'ailleurs le maire de
Saint-Denis lui-même qui ne partage pas
mes opinions politiques chacun le sait
qui fait partie de la configuration
politique qui est différente de la
mienne a demandé par exemple un million
d'euros pour le caméra vidéoprotection à
Saint-Denis évidemment répandu au maire
de votre circonscription je sais que
vous discutez avec lui c'est un point
important c'est un héritage que donne
l'état pour la Seine-Saint-Denis et pour
Saint-Denis d'équiper d'un million
d'euros les caméras de vidéoprojection
d'ailleurs dans la fusion avec
Pierrefitte il y a même demandé
davantage on sera à l'écoute évidemment
des maires de votre de votre cerveau
decription sur la question
et la question de l'accueil pardon vous
avez évoqué donc pour répondre très
concrètement il y a deux inondations en
2023 de de place de cada très important
puisque on est de mémoire à 45 me
semble-t-il 4900 places prévues en plus
pour l'année prochaine je vais
simplement dire monsieur le monsieur le
Président que vous avez dit vous-même
le seul responsable il y a un problème
ou une difficulté de programme
budgétaire et donc de politique publique
entre ce que fait ministère du Logement
est-ce que nous faisons et dans les
difficultés d'accueil du logement pour
les personnes qui sont demandeurs
d'asile
c'est c'est 2500 places en cada et 4900
places en tout merci Romain la
difficulté c'est que quand les gens
viennent dans les spicy du bicar
intérieur c'est censé des gens qui sont
hébergés et qui correspondent aux
demandes d'asile et qui sont en demande
d'asile et ceux qui sont dans le
programme du ministère du logement sont
censés notamment des 110 fixes et on
sait tous que pour plusieurs raisons les
publics parfois sont échangés
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est dans leur asile
qui sont dans le programme logement
alors qu'il ne devrait pas y être il
devrait être dans le programme du
ministère de l'Intérieur et il y a des
personnes qui sont reconduire dans leur
pays pour épuisé tout en cours et qui
doivent quitter le territoire national
et qui sont quand même logés au sein des
crédits du logement ou du ministère de
l'intérieur alors que le Conseil d'État
lui-même a dit que le droit au logement
pour les personnes qui étaient
étrangères pas continuer et que il
devait partir du territoire national et
la difficulté que nous avons c'est qui
gère ses centres parler d'associations
et notamment comment on regarde entre
ceux qui relèvent du statut
administratif du demandeur d'asile qui
nous devons évidemment le logement sans
discuter le centre domicile fixe que
l'histoire du logement doit évidemment
accueillir sans difficulté et celui qui
doit quitter le territoire national et
qui ne doit pas relever de ces deux
programmes budgétaires pour plein de
raisons et vous le savez notamment je
pense à la circulaire que l'onzar il n'a
pas été appliqué cette distinction parce
qu'il y a par ailleurs une difficulté
qu'on peut pas demander aux associations
de faire des contrôles d'identité bien
évidemment quand on accueille les gens
dans des logements dans des difficultés
fortes enfin ça explique aussi les
difficultés végétales dans lesquelles
nous nous trouvons il y a sans doute
dans votre commission à réfléchir
puisque l'État évidemment a des
positions un peu difficiles entre ma
position budgétaire de mise au logement
et la position budgétaire de mise à
l'intérieur à réfléchir à peut-être soit
un programme commun ou une politique du
logement un peu différente qui permet de
sortir du 303 et discussions autour du
303 mais je peux vous assurer que ces
augmentations sont en continu et
notamment dans le budget du ministère de
l'Intérieur si je reprends l'ordre de
passage des déshorateurs je pense vous
avoir répondu sur les augmentations
d'effectifs prévus dans la lothmique que
vous avez d'ailleurs voté je vous en
remercie je choisis souligner que pour
la première fois l'état recréer des
sous-préfectures ce qui n'a pas été le
cas encore une fois depuis extrêmement
longtemps puisque on nous en supprimions
beaucoup en outre-mer d'ailleurs comme
en métropole je veux vous dire que sur
la propagande électorale
nous avons au contraire revisité alors
la façon dont on envoie la propagande
électorale puisque ce que nous confions
hier à des sociétés privées une grande
partie des préfectures le font désormais
en interne ce qui explique sans doute
l'efficacité de cette année de
présidentielle et législatives à ceci
près que la difficulté qu'administer de
l'intérieur c'est que comme c'est comme
pour le vote électronique pour les
organisations syndicales internes il n'y
a il y a quasiment qu'une position
monopolistique de la part d'entreprise
puisque il s'agissait soit de la
soit de
Adrexo pour la distribution de ces plis
et donc c'est cette position quasi
monopolistique empêchée par décision de
faire la concurrence et nous empêcher en
effet puissent par manque de muscles de
la part de l'État qui n'était pas prévu
à l'époque de pouvoir se substituer à
des opérateurs privés qui avaient failli
comme je voulais expliquer lorsque va
bien invité dans votre commission voilà
désormais deux ans je crois que nous
avons tiré ces conséquences pour les
organisations d'élection présidentielle
et initiatives qui sont passées le mieux
possible après c'est du jamais facile
distribuer la propagande électorale dans
les délais à partis par le législateur
cependant la question que vous posez sur
la modernisation de la propagande c'est
la question de sa numérisation et de
savoir si on doit ou pas numériser la
propagande électorale il y a deux écoles
il y a ceux qui pensent oui ceux qui
comme vous sont sans doute à la fleur de
l'âge et très attentif au projet
numérique de chacune et de chacun et il
y a aussi une question budgétaire
puisque de mémoire ça coûte 60 millions
d'euros et que si on devient supprimer
la propagande électorale nous gagnons 60
millions d'euros et puis à ceux qui
pensent que quoi qu'il arrive la
propagande électorale est un moment
important pour notre vie démocratique et
que les personnes âgées notamment
doivent accès à cette propagande
électorale et que quand on distribue pas
propagande électorale il y a moins
d'anticipation aux élections donc il y a
un débat qui n'est pas qu'un débat
budgétaire car un débat de c'est quoi la
vie démocratique aujourd'hui comme on en
discute alors il y a une position
possible du ministère d'intérieur qui
consiste à dire que les citoyens
pourraient dire s'ils veulent ou pas
recevoir la propagande électorale soit
avec un geste actif je vais recevoir la
propagande soit avec un geste moins
actif si vous ne répondez pas alors vous
recevrez la propagande voilà donc nous y
travaillons on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler pour pas avoir de louper
deuxièmement moi j'ai proposé que dans
la modernisation du vote désormais votre
déménagement entraîne votre déménagement
des listes électorales parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que parmi les les les pertes
évidemment de propagande électorale mais
aussi de d'abstention quand les gens
déménagent ils pensent pas toujours à
déménager leur adresse électorale là
aussi ça peut être une liberté de choix
que baisser son vote dans sa commune par
exemple on a sa résidence secondaire
mais on pourrait dire que par défaut
quand je déménage mon compteur
d'électricité et là je ou lorsque je
fais ma déclaration à la mairie et ben
je puisse également avoir
automatiquement ma déclaration
d'inscription sur les sélectorales voilà
des pistes de modernisation possible sur
le FIPD et le fond Marianne monsieur le
monsieur le député alors j'ai exactement
de quoi vous répondre sur le FIPD donc
il y a quatre programmes dans le FIPD le
fond
radicalisation qui évoquait dans le fond
Marianne qui n'est pas tout le fond
Marianne c'est c'est le deuxième plus
petit programme budgétaire sur
l'ensemble du FIPD soit les 74 millions
d'euros d'autorisation d'engagement
c'est 12 millions mais 12 millions
c'était pas simplement le fond Marianne
et je voudrais vous redire que oui 92%
de ces crédits sont déconcentrés et
seulement 8% sont en central les CPD
c'est notamment vous le savez bien sur
les associations de préventionnel
délinquance ou l'installation de caméra
vidéoprotection ou l'équipement des
polices municipales à la demande à la
demande des vous l'avez dit il y a une
enquête ouverte par le procureur par le
parquet national financier il y a une
commission d'enquête ouverte au Sénat
évidemment chacun des fonctionnaires et
toute responsable politique répondra
bien sûr aux exigences de la commission
d'enquête de vos collègues du Sénat le
président de la commission des finances
a demandé des documents qui m'ont été
fournis nous a demandé on n'y a pas
encore répondu mais je réponds
maintenant est-ce qu'il peut utiliser
ces documents la réponse est oui on a
rien à cacher de ces documents qui sont
évidemment public et il y a par ailleurs
une enquête de l'hygia que j'ai demandé
bien avant d'ailleurs l'ouverture
d'enquête du PNF que je rendrai public
je l'ai dit et normalement elle me sera
rendu sous 15 jours elle sera plutôt
rendu d'ailleurs à la ministre bacaisse
qui a la responsabilité comme secrétaire
d'État de l'utilisation de de ses fonds
donc on en tirera toutes les conclusions
y compris s'il y a eu des manquements
dans l'utilisation de ces crédits qui il
est vrai sont assez nouveau puisque je
rappelle que son Marianne a été créé le
lendemain l'assassinat du professeur
Samuel Paty que les ont peut-être pas
les mêmes habitudes budgétaire qui avait
été et qui doivent être mis en place
dans un grand ministère comme le
ministère d'intérieur en l'occurrence au
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté je
vous rendrai donc bien sûr en République
le rapport de Niger qui sera fourni et
qui sera versé aux discussions au
budgétaires que nous pouvons avoir si
vous le souhaitez sur l'immobilier on
m'a posé la question de savoir quels
étaient les pistes dépendamment de la
dette immobilière je pense notamment à
la ministre qui posait la question on a
indépendamment de l'augmentation des
crédits qui sont prévus dans la locmin
ces 300 millions de plus par an en socle
sur l'immobilier ce qui est important
mais qui n'est pas suffisant pour
répondre à la dette immobilière il y a
trois types de d'imagination et les
trois sont cumulables d'abord peut-être
arrêter et notamment nous allons
annoncer les 200 degrés brigades au mois
de juin je sais qu'elles sont attendues
par les par les parlementaires et par
les par les habitants arrêtez de
demander aux élus de construire des
casernes à la place de l'État ça fait 45
ans qu'on fait ça la difficulté c'est
que il y a une forme de concurrence un
peu déloyale entre territoires souvent
des emprunts ont été faits par les mers
et parfois des empreintes toxiques ils
emprunts difficiles qui désormais se
mettent en difficulté financières pour
discuter avec des banques quand on a une
commune de 1500 habitants qui discutent
avec une grande banque allemande comme
c'est le cas dans une commune du nord
que je connais bien évidemment il y a du
contentieux et c'est 7 millions par
exemple pour cette petite commune du
nord de contentieux qu'une banque
allemande donc c'est pas une bonne chose
et les loyers de servent pas à rénover
et 40 ans après l'état n'est toujours
pas propriétaire donc nous proposerions
très très bientôt à Bercy parce que
c'est vrai que c'est Bercy qui gère le
domaine public de l'État et donc à votre
assemblée sans doute dans le PLF de
cette année un changement qui
consisterait à dire que ce n'est plus
aux communes de construire mais que
c'est à l'État d'imaginer cette
construction comme il ne peut pas le
faire avec des socles d'investissement
puisqu'il ne s'accorderez pas forcément
ses crédits on peut imaginer des PPP
avec un certain nombre de grands de
grands majeurs de l'immobilier en
regroupant notamment les constructions
de ces brigades et en prévoir notamment
pas le même la même façon que ceux de
rayades il y a des endroits où on n'a
pas besoin de le CODIR la vue des
endroits on n'a pas besoin forcément des
bureaux en tout cas il faut peut-être
faire des open space et des moments on
peut travailler sur le logement
différemment que la toujours fait la
gendarmerie nationale donc d'abord un
changement de qui est propriétaire et
comment on est au rendez-vous de cette
immobilier le deuxième sujet même la
ministre sur la foncière
l'État a un énorme
programme immobilier notamment ministère
de l'intérieur avec de l'immobilier très
différent les uns des autres l'hôtel des
ministres à Bobo des hôtels dans les
provinces qui sont à rénover je pense à
préfecture de Marseille qui mériterait
une très grande rénovation par exemple
des sous-préfectures en outre-mer des
casernes de gendarmerie ou des gendarmes
mobiles des commissariats bref on voit
bien qu'il y a une multiplicité de
d'enjeux et on n'est pas très bon
gestionnaire pas du fait des agents qui
s'en occupent mais du fait du
fonctionnement général de notre
immobilier et pour avoir été mise de
même public l'état de manière générale
ne s'est pas très bien gérer me
semble-t-il l'immobilier notamment
l'immobilier dans sa transition
écologique donc moi je propose une
foncière à Bercy qui consiste à garder
bien sûr la majorité des voix pour le
public il s'agit pas bien sûr de
privatiser d'amalpes publics de garder
une majorité et très large majorité pour
le public mais de permettre notamment
dans la transition écologique et dans la
gestion de cette immobilier de faire
entrer aussi des gens dont c'est la
profession et j'aurais l'occasion de
vous proposer évidemment cette
modification
c'est plutôt en ce moment à Bercy puis
le troisième sujet ça c'est un point
très important c'est la construction en
PPP des grands sites du ministère de
l'intérieur ça a très bien marché sur le
siège par exemple de la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
beaucoup d'entre vous vont les visiter
Issy-les-Moulineaux c'est un PPP
évidemment comme tout PPP il mérite
d'être challenger il s'agit pas d'être
au rendez-vous simplement de signer des
contrats de performance comme ça sans
rien dire mais je pense que ça fait
partie sur les sept recréations de
casernes de gendarmerie mobile et les
quatre unités de CRS la question se pose
savoir si c'est 30 millions de choses à
peu près chacun pour construire une
caserne on ne sait pas en PPP plutôt
quand le faire en classique puisque
quand on voit la façon dont sont logés
nos CRS le gendarma mobile on se dit que
notre façon de faire d'aujourd'hui n'est
pas tout à fait la bonne sur la sécurité
civile pour répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur merci d'avoir constaté les
efforts fait par l'État et
l'augmentation des crédits importants en
sécurité civile vous avez raison ils ne
sont pas encore assez important en tout
cas dans le conseil 2022
incontestablement puisque les annonces
faites à présent de la République était
postérieure à l'année 20 donc ça se
traduit à la fois dans la lout me et
dans les augmentations budgétaires du
budget qui sera je l'espère voté en 2023
pour 24 pour concrétiser le pacte 10
capacités
alors vous dites les cns10 qui la
plupart du temps le financement je me
permets de corriger si vous ne permettez
de ce rapporteur un peu ce point de vue
d'abord il y a un milliard et demi qui
est versé par l'État OS 10 ce qu'on ne
jette on dit jamais sur les achats
notamment ses achats capacitaires donc
les camions de pompiers les casernes bon
ça c'est rarement évoqué mais c'est
quand même du travail fait directement
par l'État pas simplement par les
crédits dit sécurité civile mais partout
la décide à de TR que nous versons et
qui dit rarement mis en avant par les
élus locaux j'ai été conseillé
départemental je sais malheureusement
que parfois n'est pas toujours remercier
lorsqu'il le fait il le fait bien le
deuxième sujet je voudrais évoquer avec
vous
c'est évidemment notre financement des
10 qui aujourd'hui ne correspond pas me
semble-t-il à la fois à la transition
écologique que vous évoquez au
réchauffement climatique mais aussi il y
a une forme de Dole pour une partie de
ces 10 je m'explique la TSCA qui est la
taxe qui avait été imaginé une taxe sur
les assurances pour permettre aux ises
de fonctionner elle passe par le
département qui reverse tout ou partie
de cette TSR Osis et notre difficulté a
rapport je suis prêt à fournir
évidemment aux assemblées a été commandé
par moi-même pour vérifier si ce
financement était au rendez-vous parce
qu'elle va demander des crédits à l'état
encore faut-il savoir si l'impôt que
collecte les départements correspond
bien à l'affectation qu'on doit lui
donner c'est-à-dire ozis c'est pas le
cas partout et donc la première question
c'est de savoir est-ce que les
difficultés certaines pour les
départements dans la politique sociale
ne mériterait pas d'avoir une autre
réponse que je prends l'argent qui
normalement va au 10 pour payer ce que
je dois payer au RSA ou ce que je dois
payer au mtph donc ça c'est un premier
problème il y a une recette il faut
qu'elle aille directement au 10 les 10
ce n'est pas une collectivité locale au
sens littéral du terme parce qu'il n'est
pas élu au suffrage universel direct
mais enfin c'est une appendice ça
établissement public direct d'un
département il faut que nous régulons
davantage entre le versement la TSA et
les recettes que touche existe
deuxièmement moi je me pose la question
aussi de la péréquation entre
départements puisque la TSR est versée
au département des Hauts-de-Seine mais
le département de Haut-de-Seine ne
connaît pas cette forêt alors que le
sujet d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même
essentiellement les feux de forêts et
les feux de forêts c'est le Jura ou les
Vosges qui ne connaissait pas hier des
feux degrés qui doivent s'équiper
désormais en moyenne capacitaires qui
n'avaient pas ailleurs alors qu'ils ont
moins de recettes que le département des
Hauts-de-Seine donc sans faire
d'insultes envers n'importe quel
département le mec on a eu des
péréquations sur les droits de mutation
ne faut-il pas faire des pères équations
entre les départements qui touchent
beaucoup de recettes pour un disque qui
certes est efficace en l'occurrence il
s'agit de la bftp donc je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail de discussion
mais c'est pour vous d'illustrer mon
sujet
par rapport à ceux qui reçoit une
population pauvre le grand massifs
forestiers et pas assez de recettes pour
pouvoir répondre à cette interrogation
donc je pense qu'il y a oui de l'argent
à mettre en plus de la part de l'État
oui à mieux fléchi le financement taxe
recette que n'ont pas toujours bien
fléchés une partie des départements et
surtout il y a une péréquation à faire
entre départements pauvres avec beaucoup
de difficultés sociales et transition
climatique et département plus riches
avec moins de difficultés sociales et
transition et climatiques moins
puisqu'en général c'est dans les
départements les plus urbanisés j'en ai
beaucoup parlé au président sauvadé qui
partagent en partie cette opinion d'en
discuter et moi je propose que PLF de
cette année évidemment on se pose la
question de même qu'il y a des recettes
qu'on existe pour avoir facilement et
qu'on doit être plus cohérent vous avez
discuté il y a pas très longtemps la
suppression un certain nombre de malus
écologique sur des
camions de pompiers qui ne pouvaient pas
être de façon décarbonée ça peut absurde
de demander que l'État prenne un malus
écolo sur un camion que doit y arriver
le 10 et que l'État remboursera par des
subventions après là je pense
qu'effectivement le réchauffement
climatique est notre conception doit un
peu changer cependant vous avez raison
nous augmentons les crédits donnés à la
sécurité civile de façon très importante
alors c'est l'aviation alors l'aviation
vous avez parfaitement raison c'est une
compétence de l'État on augmente le
nombre d'avions et d'hélicoptère on
renouvelle ces avions et ses
hélicoptères pour Airbus pour les
hélicoptères c'est fait c'est dans la
locmi pour l'aviation la difficulté
c'est de construire l'usine qui va
construire les avions puisque c'est
qu'il y a plus d'usine de Canadair
Canadair étant une marque et nous avons
prévu évidemment 45 millions d'euros sur
quatre ans pour renouveler la flotte de
Canadair des moyens de feux de forêt de
60 millions d'euros en fonctionnement
parce que vous avez compris que comme
vous l'avez très bien dit vous-même
quand on envoie des colonnes de renfort
c'est c'est des pompiers du Nord et les
pompiers de leur qui vont aider leurs
amis des Landes enfin c'est l'État qui
paye ses colonnes de renfort qui
dédommage les 10 et c'est 150 millions
d'euros d'investissement pour participer
au Cap opact capacitaire par c'est à
dire aux achats de camions et
d'intervention des sapeurs-pompiers
alors le personnel vous avez raison de
dire également on a signé une convention
pour les personnels naviguant qui est
très importante et qui était signée à
l'unanimité des syndicats reste et
techniciens il faut effectivement que y
travaillons la première commande que
j'ai faite et qui est désormais
totalement passée c'est que les gens
étaient souvent en CDD de 3 mois et je
vais dans les a fait passer en CDI
notamment je pense à la base de Nîmes
que vous avez visité mais vous avez
raison il faut signer désormais la même
convention sociale avec des techniciens
que nous avons signé avec les personnel
navigants je terminerai peut-être sur
les diverses questions autour de l'asile
et la sécurité routière sur l'asile je
voudrais ici dire que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire dans
les journaux ou entendre parfois dans
les débats migratoires les nouvelles
demandes d'asile sont plutôt bonnes
puisque pour la première fois nous
constatons une baisse continue en 5 mois
des demandes d'asile sur le territoire
national et c'est la première fois
depuis
quasiment une dizaine d'années puisqu'on
était en moyenne à 13000 demandes à la
fin de l'année dernière d'asile en
janvier 13193 demandes en février 11171
en mars 11 1990 et en avril 10351 c'est
à dire le chiffre le plus bas de vente
d'asile depuis que je suis ministre de
l'intérieur alors qu'il y a 60 % de mon
désir en plus en Europe et je pense
qu'il faut constater à la fois
l'efficacité de l'OFPRA qui instruit
plus vite le cas également les efforts
fait par la CNDA même s'il y a encore
des efforts à faire et sans doute le
fait que nous avons pour une partie
d'entre eux resserrer un certain nombre
de demandes et d'instructions et aussi
parce que vous avez accepté de mettre
beaucoup plus d'effectifs qui font
beaucoup plus de contrôle c'est le cas
des deux années budgétaires donc je
pense qu'il faut il faut qu'on le
souligne parce que du coup nos
prévisions budgétaires pour l'année
pour l'année 2023
ne correspondent pas aux esprits
critiques que j'ai pu que j'ai pu
entendre et je constate d'ailleurs que
si l'Allemagne connaît l’augmentation
très forte au nom d'asile comme le cas
en Italie ou en Espagne ce n'est pas
pour l'instant le cas de la France mais
il reste encore 6 mois évidemment je ne
veux présumer je ne veux présumer de
rien je veux dire d'ailleurs aux
questions posées par Monsieur Lefebvre
et par Madame Dupont que oui pour
l'association avec le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale dans le schéma des
demandeurs d'asile que sur la composante
d'hébergement citoyen qui avait été
imaginé par l'Ukraine pour les
Ukrainiens évidemment être mis en place
aussi sur les dispositif national
d'accueil tout court même si c'est pas
la tradition du ministère de l'Intérieur
et qu'on doit évidemment l'étudier que
sur la prévision de pense d'Ada pour
poser la question très clairement et
avec les demandes d'asile qui semble
baisser il me semble que nous serons
tout à fait dans les clous de
l'inscription budgétaire voire même
peut-être avec une légère surexécution
voilà peut-être une économie que l'on
peut rendre un interministériel monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances mais je veux plaisir à Monsieur
Lefebvre que oui c'est d'être coutume
que ce soit une taxation
interministérielle qui qui réponde en
cas de difficulté budgétaire ce qui nous
paraît pas aujourd'hui être tout à fait
au rendez-vous du sujet budgétaire comme
je voulais évoquais avec la baisse de
cette demande cette demande d'asile je
veux dire que ce programme agir évoqué
par Madame Dupont nous allons continuer
sur son augmentation il y a aujourd'hui
2559 bénéficiaires de la protection
internationale qui ont été orientées
vers ce dispositif 26 nouveaux
départements sont prévus en 2023 madame
la députée et nous allons essayer de
généraliser ça en 2000 en 2024 bien
évidemment je sais que vous êtes
particulièrement attaché je terminerai
par dire que pour la sécurité routière
la question terrible posée du casse
terrible parce que le ministre des
comptes publics n'était pas favorable au
cours de l'affectation spéciale puisque
le compte affectation spéciale
l'affectation budgétaire c'est jamais
très bon comme principe il était
budgétaire je reste persuadé que c'est
pas bon les casses bon alors après il y
a dans le casse sécurité routière un
sujet de pédagogie avec les associations
de victimes parce que vous qu'elle
touche une partie des financements pour
la prévention et font un travail
formidable mais aussi des collectivités
locales qui acceptent de faire des
aménagements routiers nous pourrions
imaginer un monde sans casse nous
pourrions garantir ces répartitions
budgétaires là mais
je pense que il y a encore un petit peu
tôt pour proposer sa suppression moi je
suis prêt à étudier avec le Parlement si
nous garantissons évidemment aux
collectivités locales et aux
associations de sécurité routière le
fait que évidemment et je continuerons à
toucher une partie des recettes des
amandes de sécurité routière du
ministère de l'Intérieur j'espère avoir
répondu j'essaie de faire vite j'étais
long je suis parti de vos questions on
va passer aux orateurs de groupe pour
Renaissance 2 minutes chacun Benjamin
Dirks
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues tout d'abord le
groupe naissance vous laisse se joindre
le match que vous avez rendu monsieur le
ministre au trois policiers décédés et
d'ordre plus général rendre hommage à
l'ensemble de nos policiers de nos
gendarmes et de nos pompiers qui
risquent leur vie chaque jour pour notre
sécurité histoire Vic chaque jour pour
nous protéger
vous félicitez monsieur le ministre du
sérieux de l'exécution budgétaire du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui est
d'ailleurs été salué par la Cour des
comptes notamment sur la mission
sécurité qui dit je cite une année à la
gestion réussie ne présentant pas de
souci de sous budgétisation ni de
tension majeure
souligner également l'important si vous
l'avez fait monsieur le ministre des
moyens que vous avez pu engager pour
équiper nos forces de sécurité avec des
nouveaux véhicules notamment qui étaient
nécessaires sur nos territoires et fort
apprécié de nos forces de l'ordre
deux points pour la suite le premier sur
le plan des 200 gendarmerie peut-être
pourriez-vous nous préciser les avancées
sur sur ce plan là vous avez parlé
du rapport que vous pouviez avoir avec
les élus locaux qui pourraient
construire des casernes ceci étant des
conventions pu être passé avec certains
états départements assez récemment
notamment le mien celui de la
Saône-et-Loire nous étions dans des
situations où la réhabilitations de
gendarmerie duraient depuis des années
des bailleurs c'est un désengagé alors
peut-être pourriez-vous nous préciser le
regard que vous avez sur ces conventions
avec des départements pour les
réhabilitations et construction et en
profiter pour vous redire tout
l'attachement que je peux porter
au plan qui vous a été présenté par le
département de Saône-et-Loire et en
particulier pour la commune de Pierre
clos et puis un dernier point
un message important monsieur le
ministre et puis sur l'évaluation
budgétaire comme le disait mon collègue
le fait j'ai pu entendre ce que vous
disiez aujourd'hui et le président
Coquerel l'a repris
le rapporteur spécial du sport donc avec
que l'entendre sur la gestion de la
billetterie gratuite je pense qu'il est
on ne peut pas d'un côté reprocher des
billets très chers pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture pour cent mille places de
l'autre côté c'est mouvoir d'avoir une
gestion gratuite pour certains billets
il y a forcément un coup quelque part
soit il sera pour l'usager soit il est
par l'impôt si l'état vient donc dans
tous les cas saluer la mesure vous avez
prise aujourd'hui puisque la question
était posée enfin de toute façon normale
que la Commission oui je termine il est
normal que la commission des finances
s'inquiète et vous interroge sur le
niveau fin ancier oui mais j'ai pas ce
que fini monsieur
mais par contre non non
les moyens dont vous aurez besoin au
niveau de la sécurité est-ce que vous
aurez besoin des moyens de nos
territoires pour venir renforcer les
équipes de sécurité pendant si Jocelyn
decigny tu n'avais pas été vigilant
rassemblant
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues selon le
ministre
sur le ministre de votre ministère
pardon monsieur le ministre
l'allongement des délais
je reprends
selon votre ministère monsieur le
ministre et l'allongement des délais de
délivrance des titres de d'identité
relève de trois facteurs conjoncturels
rattrapage du covid un effet saisonnier
dû aux vacances qui arrivent et une
anticipation trop précoce des demandes
cependant le rapport d'information mais
en évidence un problème lui structurel
dans le dispositif l'objectif de
productivité et d'économie d'emploi
n'est pas atteint les demandes de titres
sont en hausse selon l'Agence nationale
des titres de sécurité lance elle-même
par votre entêtement ce sont des
milliers de fonctionnaires municipaux
que vous avez jetés en pâture et dont je
tiens à saluer ici un adaptabilité face
à l'électronisme de nombreux de nos
subconscitoyens non anticipé une fois de
plus par votre gouvernement et également
à saluer leur empathie et le calme dont
ils font preuve auprès des personnes en
difficulté et souvent mécont de ne
pouvoir accéder rapidement à leur titre
de alors titre d'identité face à cette
réalité de terrain et dans ces
conditions il est temps de ce ministre
de reconnaître votre erreur votre échec
et de revenir certainement à la
situation antérieure en ce qui concerne
donc l'immigration
donc en 2021 selon les chiffres du
ministère au premier semestre il y a eu
62 207 au qtf prononcé et 3500 une
exécutées soit un taux de réalisation
d'exécution de 5,6% de surcroît il
n'existe que 1800 places de en centre de
rétention administrative un tiers des
personnes inscrites au fichier des
signalements pour prévention de la
radicalisation au caractère terroriste
sont des étrangers en 2020 les étrangers
représentaient 24% des détenus dans les
établissements pénitentiaires
et je passe sur la flux massive de
mineur non accompagné la sur délinquance
est liée inéluctablement à l'immigration
et c'est une réalité incontestable par
ailleurs l'état des finances publiques
exemples en France ne permet plus
d'accueillir toute la misère du monde
l'immigration débordent des métropoles
urbaines et inondent désormais nos
campagnes et avec elles sont flots
d'insécurité et de délinquance monsieur
Macron veut repeupler la ruralité en
ouvrant grand les vannes merci mais non
merci il est temps monsieur le ministre
ne suivez pas le mauvais exemple
précédent on va revenir à deux minutes
progressivement tout simplement pour
qu'on se termine pas tous les tous être
heureux du matin c'est sinon oui il y a
chacun imite l'autre Elisa Martin pour
la France
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président
ma question pose porte sur la mission
sécurité et la dimension emploi
85 % des crédits de cette mission sont
des dépenses de personnel or ceux-ci
sont sous consommés par un double effet
d'abord des difficultés objectives de
recrutement même avec de moindres
exigences sur le plan des acquisitions
lors des recrutements effectués par
concours ce qui bien évidemment
interroge même avec des conditions
indemnitaires bonnes le compte n'y est
pas les mauvaises conditions de travail
connu de tous la surexposition sociale
de par les consignes
gouvernementales d'une façon générale et
les vôtres en particulier
contribuent à cette désaffection
alimente des amours entre la jeunesse et
la police en particulier
des départs en masse ont été constatés
en 2022 année qui aura été pire que 2021
nous en voulons pour preuve c'est les
chiffres de la Cour des comptes plus de
10840 départs donc en cours de carrière
dans le cadre de la police nationale
plus 33 % en 4 ans 15000 départs dans le
cadre de l'ingère d'armurerie plus 25%
sur la même période il est question
d'être noyé sous les dossiers
l'autoritarisme qui a mené la réforme de
la police judiciaire et pointée et d'une
certaine façon les policiers craignent
de voir le service public qu'ils
incarnent le bas et c'est donc l'hôpital
tout simplement qui est évoqué comment
allez-vous répondre à cela je sais que
vous en avez dit de mots pour un pour
autant nous insistons quel management
quelle formation quelle rémunération
mais surtout quel sens donner aux
missions de ces agents qui portent le
service public de sûreté et
malheureusement comme on a pu encore le
constater ce week-end parfois même au
péril de leur vie il ne peut y avoir de
service public efficaces en dehors du
bien-être des agents qui les font
fonctionner et bien sûr du sens au
travail c'est le sens de notre question
merci Patrick Etzel pour les
républicains merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup pour votre présentation je
voudrais concentrer mon intervention sur
la mission immigration asile et
intégration en effet aujourd'hui on
constate que la présentation du du
document budgétaire avec les deux
programmes le programme 104 et le
programme 303 ne permet pas toujours
d'avoir une une bonne approche je dirais
de d'analyse
budgétaire et c'est pour ça que
plusieurs questions méritent d'être
abordées d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser quel est le coût réel
aujourd'hui pour l'état de l'hébergement
des demandeurs d'asile et notamment
c'est un sujet qui revient très
régulièrement pour le périmètre de l'île
de France ou apparemment on a des
hébergements qui augmentent dans le
moteur hôtelier et un chiffre qui semble
revenir à plusieurs reprises mais qui
faudrait documenter donc je j'aimerais
savoir si vous avez des éléments à ce
sujet c'est qu'il y aurait une dépense
annuelle d'un million d'euros pour des
hébergements hôteliers à l'échelle
nationale par ailleurs pour le seul
accueil des des Ukrainiens l'État
français a dépensé alors d'après le
programme 303 on est à
471,6 millions d'euros mais il
semblerait qu'il y ait d'autres dépenses
engagées par l'État sur d'autres
programmes et que le coût global serait
de 634 millions d'euros sur l'exercice
2022 par ailleurs concernant les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français je ne vous apprends rien vous
disant que c'est le gros point noir de
la politique migratoire en France donc
là aussi quels sont je dirais les moyens
que vous avez engagé pour faire en sorte
que les laisser passer consulaires ne
soient plus délivrés au compte-goutte
mais qui dit là un véritable travail
engagé dans ce sens et puis pour finir
comment expliquer vous cette
surexécution du programme 303 c'est à
dire quand on a 20 % pratiquement de
dépenses supplémentaires par rapport à
ce qui avait été initialement budgété
sur des terres
459 milliards d'euros et en réalité vous
êtes vous avez dépensé 277 millions de
plus je vous remercie Marina Ferrari
pour modèle
merci monsieur le Président avant de
commencer je
m'associerai bien évidemment à l'hommage
ainsi que mes collègues du Mouvement
Démocrate à l'hommage rendu aux trois
policiers tombé ce dimanche alors moi je
vais aller très vite monsieur le
ministre puisque dans vos propos vous
avez déjà donné beaucoup de réponses à
nos interrogations en me concentrant sur
les programmes 152 166 et 161 donc tout
d'abord on vous adressant à satisfait
site quant à la qualité de la gestion et
de l'exécution budgétaire avec des taux
exceptionnels dans la réalisation des
crédits nous saluons bien évidemment au
groupe démocrate les renforts en
personnels déjà déployés les objectifs
de la loopmie et les discussions
engagées sur le territoire c'est d'ores
et déjà le cas pour l'implantation des
200 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
toutefois des points de vigilance ont
été levés notamment sur les difficultés
de recrutement et puis également sur la
nécessaire réduction des stocks d'heure
supplémentaires qui a été pointé par la
Cour des comptes donc quelle est la
politique de recrutement que vous
pourriez conduire et également
sur l'amélioration des conditions de
travail sur la gestion des ressources
humaines au sein du ministère concernant
le problème de la construction des
gendarmeries alors vous avez déjà
devancé ma question sur le projet
peut-être de financer directement par
l'État le projet de nouvelle caserne
mais quand serait-il pour les projets
qui sont déjà partis et qui connaissent
des surpris aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
discussions alors moi c'est pas en
Saône-et-Loire sans savoir mais j'ai des
sujets sur le sur le feu et puis sur
ceux qui sont sur le point de partir
voilà donc si vous pouviez nous donner
s'il y avait une doctrine générale pour
l'accompagnement des collectivités qui
seraient en difficulté actuellement sur
le programme 161 malheureusement ça a
été rappelé par plusieurs collègues la
saison 2023 s'annonce tout aussi tout
aussi catastrophique que l'été précédent
donc quid de la réserve de précaution
elle a été consommée à 79% en 2021 à
100% 2022 nous faudra-t-il ajuster le
trait dans les années à venir et
peut-être envisager d'une réhausse de
celle-ci d'une manière pérenne voilà je
m'arrêterai là je vous remercie merci
pour le groupe socialiste Marie Etta
caramelia qui je souhaite la bienvenue
j'ai oublié Souter la bienvenue à Elisa
Martin aussi
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre très rapidement
effectivement beaucoup de missions ici
je commencerai par une immigration et
l'asile effectivement sujet au combien
insensible et enjeux politiques et nous
aurons l'occasion d'emper les aborder
prochainement les dépenses
d'intervention ont augmenté au-delà de
ce qui était prévu en loi des finances
initiales 2022 et ils ont été impactés
par les personnes justement venant de
l'Ukraine pourtant la Cour des comptes
le note de son analyse budgétaire de
l'année 2022 que 38% des suffréflugier
hors se déplacer d'Ukraine n'ont pu être
hébergé dans des structures dédiées et
ont dû le faire dans leur propre leur
propre moyens où ont été orientés vers
l'hébergement d'urgence de droit commun
qui d'ailleurs se relève d'une autre
d'une autre dans notre programme
rattaché à la mission cohésion des
territoires ma question première ici
c'est la prévision a dû être comme elle
a dû être revu comment attendez-vous
faire pour que la législation et les
droits des personnes en demande de
protection ou de statut soit qu'on
aurait et Lada qui a été revue à la
baisse par la loi des finances initiales
en 2023 alors que son exécution a été
plus forte en 2022 les prévisions
sont-elles réalistes alors même que la
guerre justement en Ukraine continue et
que rien n'est prévu au titre des
personnes déplacées du crâne sur le
programme concernant les 10 je voulais
directement rappeler que les femmes et
les hommes du disent se sont en première
ligne face à la montée des interventions
pour des demandes de d'urgence de nature
médicale et sociale qui représente un
quart donc des interventions mais aussi
en première ligne contre les incendies
et les intempéries ça a été rappelé tout
à l'heure mais on voit aussi que la
réforme de la fiscalité locale pèse sur
le département alors comment
entendez-vous faire en sorte que les
insuffisances des politiques nationales
que les 10 doivent en quelque sorte
compenser en apportant secours et
réponse d'urgence soit mieux prise en
compte un amont et un compensation en
aval et concernant aussi l'aviation
quelle réponse entendez-vous apporter
qui concilie la préservation des deniers
publics et l'impératif d'une flotte sur
et efficace merci Gérard pour horizon
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre avant d'évoquer les différents
enjeux budgétaires je souhaite dans la
solennité de notre assemblée revenir sur
le terrible d'arrêt survenu dans le Nord
dimanche dernier évoqué la mémoire des
trois policiers décédés en mission et
leur rendre hommage je tiens à souligner
la mobilisation de votre ministère
auprès des familles et des collègues de
ses fonctionnaires de police ainsi qu'à
votre présence à leur côté lundi matin
en commissariat de Roubaix Roubaix qui
fait partie de ma circonscription pour
revenir à l'application du budget 2022
du ministère de l'Intérieur je souhaite
m'arrêter sur deux enjeux budgétaires
l'enjeu de la mission immigration asile
et intégration et l'enjeu des dépenses
de personnel pour nos forces de l'ordre
de par la réouverture des frontières
après la crise sanitaire et la guerrière
et la guerre
Ukraine entre autre les dépenses de la
mission immigration asile et intégration
et notamment les dépenses en matière
d'accueil des réfugiés et des demandeurs
d'asile sont en hausse en parallèle les
dépenses de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière sont a priori en léger
retarde d'exécution pourriez-vous nous
en dire un peu plus sur ces éléments de
lutte contre les MIG irrégulière et
pensez vous qu'il soit nécessaire de
réorganiser les budgets dédiés à cette
action en vue du projet de loi de
finance à venir autre enjeu budgétaire
les dépenses de personnel pour nos
forces de l'ordre police et gendarmerie
ont vu leur budget exécuter en hausse de
5,8% contre 1,3 % en 2021 ce qui a
permis de voir les effectifs croître de
matière en inédites je pense attendu par
nos concitoyens quel bilan pouvons-nous
tirer de ces hausses inédites d'effectif
de police et de gendarmerie sur
l'ensemble du territoire national je
vous remercie merci Sandra rogol pour
les écologistes qui souhaitent la
bienvenue
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre dans ma circonscription comme
lors de mes auditions et des placements
sur le sujet le constat le même la
France ne se donne pas les moyens
d'accueillir et d'intégrer dignement
celles et ceux qui en font le choix la
surexécution des programmes 104 et 303
respectivement à hauteur de 45 millions
d'euros et 277 millions d'euros
démontrent à elle seule le déficit
structurel de moyen en matière
d'intégration la dématérialisation des
procédures de demande de titre de séjour
sans réelle accompagnement des personnes
en fracture numérique ou d'alternative
physique la déficience d'accès aux
informations aux formations civiques
linguistiques et professionnelle sont
des conséquences directes de cette sous
dotation budgétaire preuve de cette
défaillance ce sont les associations qui
doivent sur le terrain s'appelaient à
pallier au travail de l'État évidemment
cette grave insuffisance étatique a
d'abord une conséquence sur la dignité
humaine comment pouvoir s'intégrer à la
société française lorsqu'on est baladé
d'une administration à une autre que
l'on n'est pas en mesure de remplir ces
demandes ou que les dispositifs
nécessaires à leurs bonnes insertion
sont absents cette défaillance hépatique
a aussi une conséquence spécial
économique sur certaines préfectures les
demandes de rendez-vous prennent
plusieurs mois avec des retards pouvant
aller à deux ans derrière ces dossiers
des matérialisés ce sont des familles et
des vies qui sont mises entre
parenthèses avec des licenciements et
des ruptures de droit à la clé quand les
titres de séjour ne sont pas renouvelés
dans les temps alors la dame
esternalisation a peut-être fait
disparaître physiquement les files
d'attente devant les préfectures mais
elles existent toujours sous une autre
forme
et peut-être une interrogation parce que
d'ici 2050 le changement climatique
risque de provoquer le déplacement de
plus de 200 millions de personnes il
serait peut-être temps de se doter d'une
véritable politique d'accueil ambitieuse
et digne je vous remercie
merci Sabrina sebahi pour le groupe GDR
jean-marcellier oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
lors d'une audition à la commission des
lois Jacques Toubon alors Défenseur des
droits avait affirmé que les droits
fondamentaux ne prévoit pas une
obligation de moyens mais une obligation
de résultats pris sous ce prisme
l'exécution de la mission asile et
immigration ne peut constituer qu'un
échec les points que nous pourrions
soulever sont nombreux mais j'en
aborderai un en particulier le 4 mai
2023 la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a condamné pour la 11e fois
depuis 2012 la France pour sa politique
d'enfermement des enfants la Cour a
ainsi estimé que le renfermement
constituait un traitement inhumain et
dégradant en 2022 ce sont 94 enfants qui
ont été enfermés en CR a dans l'Hexagone
et un chiffre 30 fois supérieur en
outre-mer du fait notamment de
l'enfermement de 295 enfants à Mayotte
dans un interview de décembre vous avez
affirmé monsieur le ministre que vous
souhaitez mettre fin à l'enfermement des
enfants pourtant le projet de loi
immigration tel que déposée au Sénat ne
tient pas cette promesse en effet cette
interdiction d'enfermement ne
concernerait que les mineurs de moins de
16 ans et ne s'appliquerait pas à
Mayotte pourtant principal territoire où
s'applique l'enfermement en outre cette
interdiction serait circonscrite au CRA
et il est certain de crâne un
détournement des placements locaux de
rétention administrative ou en zone
d'attente monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple vous évoquez
régulièrement l'état de droit quand la
France va-t-elle enfin respecter la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme sur ce sujet
merci Michel
Castellani pour
merci président monsieur le ministre
délicat d'intervenir après tant
d'intervention et
seulement deux minutes sur un périmètre
tellement vaste j'irai donc sur deux
questions sur des sujets qui portent sur
une nature très différente d'abord sur
sur l'indicateur du taux de lucidation
des cambriolages dans les résidences le
rapport annuel de performance indique
que ce taux est taux d'hélicitation donc
est inférieur à 10% alors que vous aviez
une cible autour de 15 si j'ai bien
compris est-ce que vous avez pu
identifier les causes de la dégradation
de cet indicateur est-ce que vous pensez
avoir des moyens de à votre disposition
pour pour améliorer ce résultat je
change totalement de sujets je vais sur
les bombardiers d'eau non pas pour vous
demander encore
d'impositionner un certain nombre à
Bastia vous connaissez le sujet je sais
qu'un jour vous serez bien obligé d'y
arriver parce que c'est tellement
évident non c'est pour parler d'autre
chose nous avons tous en contact des
prestataires en privé qui nous proposent
leur service est-ce que vous pensez que
ces prestations pourraient apporter une
action complémentaire je dirais vu les
difficultés à disposer de Canadair et
puis aussi les besoins les besoins de
lutte contre les incendies voilà c'est
tout j'ai été très bref merci merci
alors j'ai si je me trompe pas trois
quatre cinq inscrits supplémentaires
s'il y en a plus j'ai ma cuisine Dalloz
handicarbrate Aymeric salmon Pascal le
camp Frédéric cabrolier
que j'en ai j'en ai
j'en ai d'autres non bon ok donc je vous
passe la parole une minute chacun je
préfère qu'on gagnera du temps
Marie-Christine dalouze
aussi je m'associe bien sûr à l'hommage
qui a été rendu au policier décédé en
service dimanche
j'ai deux questions concernant plus
particulièrement les feux de forêt
vous avez tout à l'heure fait état de la
volonté du gouvernement de d'améliorer
la flotte en matière de d'aviation or
quand on regarde bien le rapport la
flotte de la sécurité civile passera
seulement de 37 à 40
appareils alors vous me direz c'est une
amélioration mais est-ce que cela sera
suffisant à votre sens compte tenu de
l'aggravation et de la densité des feux
aujourd'hui auxquels nous faisons face
et le Jura et vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure a été fortement marqué par ce ce
sujet là donc ça c'est la première
question la deuxième question vous avez
longuement parlé des financements des 10
alors
vous souhaitez une contribution des
départements pauvres attention à ce que
les départements qui est mal géré ne
soit pas enfin une contribution des
départements riches pour les pauvres
mais ce qui serait déjà intéressant
c'est de regarder si dans les
financements des s'il y a bien 50%
commune 50% départements parce que tout
le monde en est pas là et je pense que
ça se pourrait être important merci
Frédéric émollient
alors moi monsieur le ministre je
voulais vous parler des centres
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile qui
par définition sont rentrés bien sûr en
grande majorité illégalement
et quand on voit les chiffres il y a 40
% qui se voient attribué la ville
puisqu'en 2022 ça représente à peu près
40 % les 60% restants n'étant pas pour
la plupart expulsé puisque on le sait
les occultés ça a été rappelé sont très
peu exécutés alors moi dans mon
département sur ma circonscription
monsieur le ministre il y a un petit
village de 4000 habitants qui est
concerné par un cada le maire n'a pas
été consulté vous n'êtes pas obligé de
le faire donc il y a pas eu son accord
et pire la population est vent debout
puisque en plus elle l'a appris par une
annonce de Pôle Emploi
donc
au niveau national c'est 70% des
Français qui sont contre
l'accueil on va dire des migrants là je
peux vous dire que c'est bien plus et
comment pouvez-vous imposer cela dans un
petit village de 4000 habitants sur ma
circonscription
et comment qu'est-ce que comment c'est
possible que les gens la prennent par
une annonce de Pôle Emploi donc ça s'est
fait en définitive en catimini qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez me répondre par rapport
à ça merci
merci
handicarbonate merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous qui
êtes remonté comme un coucou quand il
s'agit de stigmatiser les exilés je vous
trouve un peu mou pour garantir le
financement de leur dignité et de et du
droit en 202 entre 2021 et 2023 vous
prévoyez un effort avec la création de
6400 places de cadavres les dépenses
pour les cadas ont finalement été moins
importantes que la ressource disponible
selon la Cour des comptes alors combien
de place ont été créées concrètement
sont-elles suffisantes alors que la
moitié des demandeurs d'asile ne sont
pas hébergés selon la Cimade mais une
seconde question parce que vous
féliciter de la baisse des demandeurs
d'asile l'OFPRA supprimer plus de 40000
euros plus de 40000 euros de subventions
au cngbt de Nantes sur l'aide à l'asile
car ce ne serait pas leur activité
principale l'aide à l'asile des
personnes LGBT à combien s'élève cette
baisse à échelle nationale
j'ai été à Saint-Brevin deux fois pour
défendre le maire à l'inverse de vous ma
dernière question est simple combien
coûte votre abandon face à l'extrême
droite à Callac Asan Brévin à Tours hier
alors que l'État alors que l'État porte
ses projets de cadas merci personne le
ministre le ministre n'a pas le ministre
n'a pas condamné l'attentat qu'il y a eu
au CLGBT de Tours hier et c'est une
attente que toutes les centres
alors je renouvelle à tout mes collègues
quel que soit leur mouvement que je
demande qu'on intervienne on peut sur le
fond comme vous le souhaitez mais que je
demande que l'intérêt sur une forme qui
soit pas celle forcément qui soit assez
ça vaut pour tout le monde
merci
faut y retourner Pascal le camp
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
je me soucis bien évidemment à l'hommage
rendu par mes collègues et une pensée
forte pour les familles qui doivent
penser à leur disparu moi j'ai une
question de commissaire aux finances et
sur le cadenas de Noël que vous nous
avez annoncé en tant que en tant que
mère qui est bénéficié d'une nouvelle
gendarmerie un petit peu avant qui n'est
pas encore commencé et ça s'ajoute sur
l'ensemble du budget vous venez nous
annoncer c'est vraiment un beau cadeau
de Noël que ça passerait dans le PLF il
est à prendre en charge c'est 200
gendarmerie plus les autres je voudrais
seulement savoir question très simple de
commissaire finance sur les PLF
2023-2024 2003 les trois prochains
est-ce que vous avez estimé le coût
total de cet investissement sachant
qu'elles ont toutes des tailles
différentes elles sont sur des
circonscriptions différentes et aussi au
coût du foncier qui est différent d'un
d'une ville à l'autre merci
merci
Sandra rigole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
merci
Hugo bernalicis
merci je vais faire très vite en une
minute merci monsieur le Président bon
déjà on va commencer par les loyers de
la gendarmerie et généralement les
loyers au sein de l'État c'est quand
même vos amis politique monsieur le
ministre combien en place les loyers
budgétaires qui nous ont mis dans la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve
aujourd'hui
en cause il continue d'exister c'est
supprimer il fonctionne encore bien et
c'est la même logique qui est à l'oeuvre
et qui nous met dans la situation dans
la Canella sans sans compter la
rétention d'autorisation d'engagement
qui n'est pas donné que ce soit aux
gendarmes ou policiers particulièrement
gendarmes pour leur caserne sans compter
ce qui a été fait au collectivité en
disant si vous ne payez pas les locaux
on vous ne mettra pas de caserne de
gendarmerie c'est vous c'est comme ça
que ça s'est passé on pouvait réviser
l'histoire autant que vous voulez
n'empêche que c'est la situation
politique dans laquelle on se trouve
deuxièmement ce programme 176 sécurité
la formation vous est en orgueille
l'année dernière de dire doublement du
budget de la formation et bien vous avez
exécuté que la moitié pour 2022 comment
vous expliquer ça il y a pas besoin de
formation dans la police
c'est ça le fin mot de l'histoire ou
alors on avait peut-être raison fallait
peut-être ouvrir des écoles de police
avant de augmenter le budget merci
Aymeric
salmonent hommage aux trois jeunes
policiers décédés dimanche on se qui
concerne la mission sécurité le plan de
10000 recrutement de policiers de
gendarmes lancé par Emmanuel Macron en
2017 c'était fait en 2022 l'exécution
2022 montre que la mission sécurité
comptait environ 250 000 ETP contre 247
000 en 2017 soit 3000 et TP de plus sur
les 10000 promis il faut connaître que
4000 postes et TP de services support du
ministère de l'Intérieur ne sont plus
comptabilisés dans le budget de la
police nationale bien qu'il existe
toujours ce qui fait un total de 7000
ETTP en plus mais toujours 3000 de moins
que vous engagements ce manque
d'effectifs c'est d'effectif s'explique
en partie par les difficultés de
fidélisation dans les effectifs de
sécurité nos gouvernements n'ont pas
suffisamment soutenu moralement nos
policiers et gendarmes ces dernières
décennies ma question est donc la
suivante monsieur le ministre quelles
sont les actions envisagées pour
renforcer CER l'attractivité du métier
de policier et de gendarme et pour
éviter que les recrutements se concentre
trop sur des postes administratifs aux
dépens des postes opérationnels je vous
remercie
merci
Stella Dupont
merci monsieur le Président moi je
souhaiterais réagir à la prise de parole
du rassemblement national qu'on a eu
tout à l'heure sur la nécessité de bien
accompagner les maires de les associer
au projet d'implantation des centres
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile c'est
une évidence et je pense qu'il est
toujours nécessaire et utile de procéder
à une critique constructive de l'action
de l'État du soutien de l'État au maire
concernés c'est d'ailleurs l'objet de
notre travail qu'on vous présentera tout
à l'heure dans le cadre de l'évaluation
mais moi je tiens à dire que en tant que
mère j'ai moi aussi mis en place un
centre d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
dans une petite commune d'un peu plus un
peu plus importante 6000 6000 habitants
et je crois que les peurs les
inquiétudes le besoin d'information de
nos concitoyens
on peut tout à fait l'entendre face à
une situation nouvelle et qu'on doit
être là que l'État doit être là aux
côtés des mers pour accompagner informer
rassuré mais ce qui est inacceptable
c'est ce que vous venez compliqué chers
collègues 70% des Français seraient
opposées à de telles accueils mais c'est
totalement faux c'est parce qu'on
constate sur le terrain ce qu'on
constate et ce qui est à dénoncé c'est
l'instrumentalisation que vous opérez et
que l'extrême droite au père c'est ce
qui s'est passé encore à Saint-Brevin
les pins c'est ça c'est ce à quoi tous
les républicains doivent s'opposer
aujourd'hui me semble-t-il
Florian chouch pour finir merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
suis assez surpris pour sur votre
réponse par rapport à la TCA et son
usage par les départements notamment
parce que le rapport de l'IGA est les
auteurs m'ont confirmé enfin plutôt même
affirmé que les départs versaient plus
au titre de financement des disques ce
que ce qu'il percevait en TSCA exception
faite d'un département qui qui reversait
exactement le montant de la TSCA et ce
qu'on constate c'est que seulement
parfois la dynamique de la TSCA d'une
année sur l'autre n'est pas totalement
utilisée par un département profit des
10 donc j'aimerais bien que vous me
présentiez l'étude que vous avez évoqué
ou que vous m'éclairciez sur ce sujet
merci merci à vous monsieur Mister
un peu plus rapide puisque beaucoup de
questions ont été évoquées ont déjà
connu soit dans mon propre éliminaire
soit dans les réponses aux
orateurs des groupes déjà des réponses
peut-être pour ceux qui n'ont pas eu les
réponses puisque les questions n'ont pas
été posée sur les 200 brigades c'est
équivalentes en plein de gendarmerie qui
seront spécifiques sur ces deux
cendrillades elles sont rendus public
ces 200 brigades le choix des
implantations à la fin du du mois de
juin après la concentration que les
préfets ont pu avoir avec l'ensemble des
élus et j'aurais l'occasion évidemment
de pouvoir territoire par territoire de
les annoncer sur la question des JO non
les territoires ne vont pas contribuer
financièrement monsieur le député de Rix
à la sécurité de ces Jeux olympiques
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que nous
allons faire un certain nombre de
modification temporaire de zone de
police et de gendarmerie pour pouvoir
réfléchir un peu différemment vu le
nombre de personnes et le nombre
d'événements ou d'équipe qui viendront
sur le territoire national je prends un
exemple je prends la ville de
Châteauroux par exemple qui accueille
les épreuves de te tir à l'arc me
semble-t-il on pourrait imaginer que
imaginer je dis que c'est une
imagination je dis pas que c'est ce qui
va se passer que la gendarmerie par
exemple près de le dispositif autour du
site olympique et que la police occupe
du reste du dispositif faisant ainsi
venir des gendarmes là où il y avait
Janice une zone police le temps de ces
jeux bien évidemment il s'agit pas de
revenir sur les zones police au
gendarmerie donc il peut y avoir des
changements à l'intérieur des
territoires mais évidemment on garde on
garantira la sécurité de deux gros
citoyens même pendant les Jeux
Olympiques bien évidemment
sur la question des titres d'identité
plusieurs questions vous avez posé ce
député parce qu'il y avait une sorte de
mâchoire que j'ai pas besoin de passer
des titres d'entités aux occultés aux
mineurs à la délinquance voilà
j'ai pas toujours tout compris mais sur
les titres entités je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a baissé évidemment le
tempo si j'ose dire de réponse à nos
concitoyens alors évidemment c'est une
moyenne parce que selon les territoires
c'est plus ou moins que que c'est ce que
ces données c'est 58 jours au moment où
nous parlons c'est-à-dire 10 jours de
gagner sur un petit peu plus d'un mois
grâce aux efforts fait par l'ensemble de
la chaîne vous revenir à la situation
hantée j'ai pas bien compris ce que
c'était parce que la situation hantée
c'est l'État qui s'en occupe et plus les
collectivités locales puisque c'est une
délégation de l'État aux collectivités
locales alors après il y a des
collectivités locales qui pour plusieurs
raisons ont souhaité offrir plus de
créneaux d'horaires par exemple alors
concitoyens c'était le cas de la mairie
par exemple de Tourcoing par exemple
voilà et puis il y a ceux qui n'ont pas
souhaité le faire il y a ceux qui ont
souhaité mettre en place les Dr que nous
avons proposé on pouvait pas l'obliger à
le faire article 72 agissons bien ceux
qui n'ont pas voulu le faire par exemple
je prends l'exemple de Tourcoing les
communes autour de Tourcoing n'ont pas
souhaité le faire ce qui fait que la
population de la commune à côté vient
par exemple à Tourcoing faire ses Dr
donc là s'agit vraiment à vous le
responsabilité locale bien évidemment il
n'y a pas eu de baisse effectivement je
sais pas vous l'avez vu de la NTS mais
plutôt une augmentation des effectifs
justement pour répondre à toutes à tous
ces pressions je veux quand même dire
que vous pouvez pas faire comme si
lorsqu'il y a deux ans de covid et
personne de voyage et qui est titres
entités qui tombent à échéance par effet
de 10 ans puisque c'est 10 ans votre
titre identité valable il y a deux ans
et j'en renouvelle pas leur pièce
d'identité et quand on réouvre
évidemment le service public et les
voyages il y a donc 20% de plus de gens
qui se présentent
dans les mairies donc je pense que c'est
un peu démagogique d'expliquer que c'est
l'État qui est responsable vous auriez
été responsabilité soit exactement la
même chose c'est une difficulté
évidemment
importante que de le constater
et alors tout le projet de loi que je
propose c'est notamment de limiter ces
recours dans le temps et dans leur
nombre parce que évidemment vous pouvez
prendre beaucoup de QF si les gens font
des recours vous ne les exécuterez pas
et c'est très malhonnête pardon de la
part des observateurs que de prendre les
sorties par rapport aux entrées puisque
par définition pas de la même base donc
allons-y combien vous serez en
responsabilités vous n'exécuterez pas
ces eqtf dans la mesure où ce n'est pas
la même base de comparaison entre ceux
que nous pouvons exécuter et ce que nous
pouvons pas exécuter deuxièmement
monsieur le député je veux aussi vous
dire que ces recours c'est assez les les
parents les occultés français sont de
l'année 1er janvier au 31 décembre mais
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne on
met pas 132000
qtf le 1er janvier qu'on doit exécuter
dans l'année jusqu'au 31 décembre le qtf
132000 de 2022 sans doute qu'on va
l'exécuter qu'à partir de fin 2023
puisque c'est un an après donc en plus
les comparaisons de pourcentages
pardon non non non
c'est pourcentage sur les bases par
exemple oui je comprends que vous visite
par rapport à la base d'avant
donc oui on part déjà on parle de 30
minutes quasiment de différence donc je
pense que cette cette façon de compter
n'est pas n'est pas très très honnête
mais je crois que vous-même vous le
savez que c'est vous faites un peu de un
peu de politique enfin vous dites j'ai
cru comprendre un tiers des gens qui
étaient au fspect étaient étrangers
alors pardon veut dire que sur les 22
000 personnes pardon
c'est 316 individus qui souhaitent en
jeu session irrégulières 22316 je crois
qu'on est un petit peu loin de de vos de
vos chiffres sur la question posée
madame les Saint-Martin bon je pense que
j'ai Elisa Martin pardon je pense avoir
largement répondu tout à l'heure sur les
sur les effectifs donc je vais pas
revenir sur la porte la Cour des comptes
il y a plusieurs questions sur le sujet
sur la question jeunesse et police comme
quoi il y aura divorce moi je vous
encourage à voir les policiers ils sont
jeunes d'ailleurs les trois policiers
qui sont morts dimanche c'est c'est des
jeunes donc il y a pas d'opposition
entre la police et la jeunesse ceux qui
choisissent la police ceux qui
choisissent sa gendarmerie c'est souvent
des très jeunes gens voilà donc après
qui est des sujets d'amélioration de
discussion de de d'intervention on a une
différence politique et on l'a déjà
plusieurs fois exprimé mais cette
opposition entre police et jeunesse il y
a pas d'un côté des policiers vieux et
des gens jeunes qui discuteraient avec
la police je pense que c'est un problème
important de conception de notre rapport
à l'autre
monsieur monsieur Hetzel alors vous
demandez le coût le coût réel sur les
logements finalement moi je vous
confirme effectivement que c'est un peu
plus d'un million d'euros qui est
utilisé pour loger des personnes
étrangères demandeurs d'asile pas bien
de ce sujet dans des hôtels parce qu'il
y a pas assez de centre et notamment le
sujet vous le savez bien c'est en
Île-de-France ou 50% de la demande
d'asile est concentrée il faut bien voir
que dans l'opération de desserrement qui
évoqué notamment je fais le lien avec
les questions autour des cadas et
notamment dans les territoires
provinciaux la difficulté nous avons est
avant d'intégration c'est que on
pourrait dire que l'Île-de-France en
général et la Seine-Saint-Denis en
particulier sont le réceptacle de
l'arrivée de personnes qui veulent
arriver sur notre sol et qui ensuite
reste en Île-de-France font leur
démarche administratives en
Île-de-France d'ailleurs ils ont parfois
des connaissances soit par leur
communauté d'origine soit par leurs
églises soit par leurs liens familiaux
et donc si on veut intégrer ces
personnes et quand même si on voulait
traiter même leur marché administrative
pour ne pas avoir les difficultés
migratoires que nous avons aujourd'hui
on a intérêt à répartir ces difficultés
évidemment ça pose des questions
d'aménagement si j'ose dire pour ces
personnes elle-même qui n'ont pas
toujours envie de partir de
l'Île-de-France mais aussi pour les
territoires qui l'accueillent donc oui
en attendant c'est cette c'est plus
d'habillants d'euros pour les pour les
hôtels sur la question des laisser
passer j'ai pas le coût réel par
demandeur d'Asie par l'État mais je vous
fournirai bien volontiers évidemment ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs un sujet sur lequel
on a travaillé mais c'est effectivement
une question intéressante soyez laisser
passer consulaires on a augmenté depuis
le 1er janvier là de 20% les laisser
passer consulaires alors même que nous
savons avoir des difficultés avec les
pays du Maghreb qui sont l'essentiel
comme c'est passé considère que nous
demandons donc malgré ces difficultés
avec le Maghreb on a 20% laissez passer
consulaire en plus donc je pense qu'on
est sur la bonne voie je sais qu'il y a
un symptôme de difficultés notamment qui
consisterait ce que nous n'avons pas
encore fait cette proposition des
républicains de conditionner les visas
par rapport
au laisser passer consulaire c'est une
voie qui peut être étudiée et cependant
pas totalement automatique je constate
par exemple sans ma liste monsieur
député que certains parlementaires nous
reprochaient à la fois d'être trop
souple avec quelques pays du Maghreb de
pouvoir pas assez prononcer de rétorsion
tout en dire qu'il faut libéraliser les
visas par exemple avec le Maroc avouer
que les derniers voyages que nous avons
vu dans la presse sont assez
contradictoires avec l'intervention
politique mais sans doute que sans doute
qu'être au gouvernement nous empêche
d'avoir ce genre de d'incohérence dans
lequel j'ai dû moi-même tomber dans la
facilité quand j'étais à votre à votre
place mais oui vous avez raison l'une
des grandes façons de résoudre le
problème migratoire si tenté qu'il y en
a c'est les laisser passer consulaires
et c'est une sur lequel le chèque le
gouvernement de travailler je voudrais
vous faire remarquer que c'est vraiment
une action aussi du ministère d'affaires
étrangère qui en a la compétence dans le
compétence la plus forte
sur la question des des
brigades et à partir de quand ces
brigades de gendarmerie se
reconstruisent c'est les deux questions
de Monsieur le camp et Madame Ferrari
sur le sur la finalement la la est-ce
que ça vaut pour l'avenir et comment on
va faire pour l'avenir
on a inscrit 3 millions d'euros par
brigade de gendarmerie dans le budget
bon
toutes les brigades ne seront pas
construites par l'État il y a des
communes qui veulent d'ailleurs les
construire ou qui veulent rénover des
bâtiments donc on verra bien dans
lesquels sont prises lesquelles
concerneraient le projet que nous
évoquons nous notre idée c'est de faire
des paquets de brigades si j'ose dire et
de faire des PPP voilà donc ça c'est une
première question il faut qu'on
l'expertise il faut qu'on y travaille en
tout cas c'est une proposition que nous
faisons aux élus locaux la deuxième des
choses c'est que pour les brigades qui
ont été construites auparavant non
évidemment ce côté construit par avance
c'est qu'on se reparent parfois c'est
très long ou encore de construction s'il
y a des difficultés financières moi j'ai
nom de directeurs à la gendarmerie je
pense qu'il faut qu'il se rapproche de
vous je sais qu'il nous écoute et de
toute façon on prendra le contact avec
vous-même la député tous les jours nous
aidons des collectivités locales par
exemple on va revoir leur projet de
brigade pour correspondre peut-être un
cahier des charges qui auparavant était
très Jacobins une correspondait pas à
votre territoire par exemple on
construit une nouvelle brigade il faut
pas forcément toujours des locaux de
garde à vue pas forcément toujours des
locaux de police judiciaires parce que
des gendarmes de chez vous peut-être ne
font pas tout à fait ça à ce moment-là
ou en tout cas on peut mutualiser avec
commissariat d'à côté ou la brigade d'à
donc oui il y a des moyens de réduire
des coûts y compris pendant les
constructions effectivement on peut se
rapprocher de de vous je pense que
madame carameli je m'excuse mais je
crois que j'ai déjà très largement
répondu à votre à votre question sur la
Dar en vous expliquant que cette année
très certainement nous ne sous-exécutera
vu la baisse du vendeur d'asile et le
fait qu'il y a moins de personnes
ukrainiennes qui vient sur notre sol
mais
je pense que 2022 n'est pas tout à fait
tout à fait comparable sur le 486
millions d'euros pour répondre à votre
question exacte sur la date
280 millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement sont pour l'Ukraine
[Musique]
à votre à votre question madame Gérard
vous posez une question bien difficile
en quelques instants sans que nous
couchons à 4h du matin sur rapport entre
aux effectifs et actions du ministère de
l'Intérieur je pourrais vous démontrer à
l'envie que là où il y a du bleu plus du
bleu sur le terrain il y a moins des
vacances et tous vérifier notamment dans
votre département je ferai remarquer
d'ailleurs que hormis des violences en
train familiales qui sont des violences
par définition la voie publique ne
change pas grand chose puisque ça se
passe à l'intérieur du foyer tous les
faits de délinquance du département du
Nord sont en baisse et c'est très
important de l'évoquer puisque il y a
une augmentation extrêmement importante
dans le Nord vous le savez d'effectif de
police comme c'est le cas à Marseille
comme c'est le cas à Lyon comme c'est le
cas à Paris on voit on aura l'occasion
d'en parler avec les chiffres entre -10
et - 20% d'ailleurs le Président il
n'est pas si longtemps que ça vous
l'avez vu elle a fait une conférence de
presse après les effectifs sur le
terrain se traduisent aussi par parfois
une augmentation de fait constaté c'est
tout à fait normal d'ailleurs le premier
travail des policiers des gendarmes
c'est pas d'arrêter les voleurs c'est de
faire qu'il y en a pas et d'avoir une
présence beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
forte je pense que je vais pas rentrer
plus grand plus grandement dans la
démonstration ça nous amènerait assez
loin mais je veux ici dire que
évidemment pour moi cette corrélation
sauf violence commise dans le foyer bien
évidemment et est assez est assez
évidente alors les questions qui sont
posées sur les mineurs dans l'écran
pardon monsieur le monsieur le le député
je suis partage pas tout à fait votre
opinion parce que nous sommes le premier
pays je sais pas s'il est encore là
Monsieur le Député non il n'est pas là
mais de là où il est de nous entendre le
premier pays qui va interdire l'écra les
mineurs dans les Crass ce sera la France
le premier pays que l'âge de 16 ans moi
je pense que il a parlé d'enfants
effectivement avant 16 ans on a un
enfant entre 16 et 18 ans je suis pas
tout à fait certain qu'on puisse
qualifié d'enfants mais j'ai toujours
dit que j'étais ouvert aux amendements
des parlementaires pour monter à 18 ans
s'il le fallait que oui Mayotte est
concerné puisque Mayotte c'est 2025 et
l'écran pour les mineurs ce serait
l'année prochaine donc si le texte de
loi est adopté il y aurait un décalage
dans le temps pour Mayotte parce qu'à la
différence du reste du territoire
national les personne à Mayotte reste
moins de 48 heures en moyenne dans les
centres de rétention administratif
contre un mois et demi sur le sol
hexagonal donc pas tout à fait
comparable non plus et pourra visiter
plusieurs fois le crabe Mayotte c'est
notamment le volet famille il est pas
comparable auprès de Vincennes au crabe
de l'eau mais je suis d'accord avec lui
sur le fait que même maillot doit être
concerné on doit trouver des solutions
pour Mayotte et je veux dire que depuis
le 1er janvier je dis à Monsieur député
il n'y a pas un seul mineur dans les
centres de rétention en hexagone donc
non seulement j'ai pas attendu la loi
pour le faire la consigne est claire et
notamment nous avons supprimé dans les
volets famille les places pour y mettre
davantage d'ailleurs d'hommes c'est
vraiment je crois mon nous parlons on
doit être à 96% d'hommes dans les
centres de rétention administratifs donc
je pense que c'est une démonstration qui
compte peut aller d'ailleurs dès ce soir
au Krad Vincennes le constatera donc
j'ai pas attendu la loi pour pour le
faire je pense qu'on devrait on devrait
le souligner je comprends ces critiques
mais je crois que pour une fois quand on
était d'accord sur un sujet il méritait
d'être souligné sur la question de
Monsieur castani sur les taux
d'hélicitations alors il a pris un
chiffre qui correspondait à l'année qui
suivait l'année covid puisque 22
correspondait l'année 2021 donc les 10%
se cassé la nuit pardon ils sont ils
sont ils sont un petit peu ils sont un
petit peu un petit peu un petit peu
différent
désormais il remonte tout doucement je
veux vous dire et notamment pour ce qui
fait du fait des cambriolages grâce à
l'augmentation des moyens de polystes
techniques et scientifiques parce que ce
qui fait les taux d'hélicitations c'est
les moyens souvent de techniques de
police et scientifique et des caméras de
vidéoprotection en déplaisent à certains
dans les cambriolages chez
essentiellement la pts que nous avons
d'ailleurs totalement remodelés nous
créons une école spécifique d'école de
police technique et scientifique nous
augmentons les moyens de la police
technique et scientifique donc plus il y
aura de relevés d'empreintes d'ADN de
génétique y compris sur des petits
cambriolages ou des petits vols de
voiture plus on arrivera à interpeller
des personnes on aura l'occasion d'en
parler si vous si vous souhaitez pour la
Corse je vous ferai remarquer ce député
que cet été la Corse n'a pas connu les
difficultés qu'ont connues de
territoires français et que les deux
avions que nous mettons en Corse nous
ont aidés avec le travail que fait le 10
de la du conseil exécutif vous le savez
bien après on va pas parler à l'envie
des bombardiers d'eau il met des
bombardiers d'eau nos intérêts que
lorsqu'ils sont nombreux arrivés en
moins d'une demi-heure sur une zone bah
tiens moins de 5 hectares de feu après
malheureusement on l'a vu dans les feux
de forêts des Landes c'est d'une gestion
qui ne peut être faite qu'au sol avec
des retardants bien évidemment mais qui
sont quand même moins efficaces que
lorsqu'ils arrivent dans de façon très
rapide donc notre sujet n'est pas tant
les bombardiers donc ne prédisposons que
la flotte que de mobilisons avec Météo
France pour savoir où est-ce que il y
aura la plus grande sécheresse ça pas
été le cas l'été dernier en Corse qui a
dit sécheresse et vent vous le savez
mieux personne mais si c'est le cas
cette année on pré positionnera
évidemment des moyens aériens en Corse
qui évidemment pas pas pas oublier
alors sur les préfectures je pense que
j'ai répondu à Madame la Députée tout à
l'heure et notamment à la question du
président Coquerel sur à la fois la nef
et sur à la fois la réforme des
préfectures c'est un point très très
important qui a déjà été évoqué sur la
sécurité civile la question madame
Dalloz et la question a évoquée encore
par monsieur le rapporteur je veux vous
redire que l'une des réponses est quand
même le lien que nous devons tout savoir
entre jouer au four on dirait la porte
de l'igéa Monsieur le monsieur le député
notamment le premier qui a été commandé
par mon pardon prédécesseur lorsqu'il
est arrivé aux responsabilité au
ministère de l'intérieur mais pour
Madame pour Madame Dalloz il y a quand
même une question qui se pose sur les
financements des départements et leur
péréquation ce qui ne veut pas dire que
l'État doit pas contribuer et pour
répondre à Madame rogol elle a aussi
raison prendre le virage de la
Révolution
qu'engendre les sécheresses les
calamités les difficultés d'accès
d'accès à l'eau et que bon elle
considère que ce sont des petites
avancées au moment il faudrait faire une
révolution plus importante je l'entends
mais c'est quand même
en attendant sans doute une révolution
européenne parce que je voudrais redire
que c'est un sujet absolument européen
la flotte d'avion est payé à 90% par
l'Union européenne que les feux c'est
pas dans un pays il y a des feux chaque
année c'est en général c'est
malheureusement ça tourne par pays
regardez le Canada qui est absolument
touché en ce moment c'était le cas il y
a 2 ans pour l'Italie pour l'Espagne
cette année 2022 c'était la France qui
était parti en toucher il se peut que le
mécanisme européen fonctionne pour
d'autres sujets la base de Nîmes gardons
et d'ailleurs la meilleure base
européenne sans doute apporter sur ce
point donc s'il y a une révolution à
faire elle est aussi vu les moyens et
les interventions au niveau européen
européen à faire alors Monsieur pendant
monsieur député
je suis pas d'accord avec votre première
phrase vous dites-moi dans l'asile sont
très souvent entrer légalement en France
bah non c'est pas le cas si ils sont
dans l'Asie ils sont pas rentrés
illégalement ils sont éventuellement
illégaux lorsque la France leur refuse
d'asile ça c'est un fait mais vous savez
que dans la Constitution et dans la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme en
France ces infos échanger la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et citoyens il
faudrait changer la constitution alors
pourquoi pas en soi on peut toujours en
discuter mais moi j'y suis assez attaché
quelqu'un qui demande l'asile justement
n'est pas considéré comme illégal
puisqu'il fait sa demande d'asile et que
c'est à la fin ça demande d'asile s'il
est ou pas refusé pour être envoyé donc
c'est pour ça que le débat que nous
avons ensemble est un débat intéressant
parce que quand on dit on doit
refuserait tout type de séjour à des
gens qui sont arrivés légalement sur le
territoire national on aborde
l'essentiel des personnes qui sont
illégales viennent par des visas
touristiques et restent ensuite sur le
territoire national donc c'est pas
l'immigration illégale par la frontière
italienne et la frontière espagnole qui
est aujourd'hui la masse intégrant
illégaux comme parfois je peux
l'entendre de la bouche de certains
responsables du rassemblement national
c'est des visas classiques données
classiquement qui viennent en France
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire que tous les
membres politiques ici me demandent sans
cesse d'interventions dire c'est fou le
nombre de gens qui sont contre
l'immigration qui me demande des
régulariser c'est vraiment très étonnant
donc un jour faudra connecter les deux
parties selon ce qu'on connaît tous
quelqu'un qui vient mais lui je le
connais bien parce que c'est le cousin
de quelqu'un qui vient pour le mariage
de ma sœur et en général après on
s'aperçoit que ces personnes peut rester
illégalement sur le territoire national
donc d'abord un la vraie source
d'immigration illégale c'est la
quelqu'un qui vient légalement et qui
ensuite se maintient illégalement et de
le demandeur d'asile c'est important
pour nous pour nos débats il est il est
pas réputé illégal il est réputé
irrégulier lorsqu'on lui a refusé
l'asile et qu'il n'a pas eu de l'autre
titre de séjour donc ça c'est c'est un
premier point sur la question je pense
que Madame Dupont vous a vous a répondu
je pense que ce qu'il faut bien voir
Monsieur député pour répondre à la
question qui a été posée par Monsieur el
50% des demandeurs d'asile aujourd'hui
c'est l'Île-de-France donc on peut pas
dénoncer me semble-t-il dans le même
discours politique à la fois une forme
de communautarisation
vous avez lié tout à l'heure des
vacances étrangers voilà la question
peut se poser pour une partie des
statistiques mais évidemment pas pour
l'intégralité une partie de pauvreté
forte dans certains territoires et je
pense notamment à la Seine-Saint-Denis
mais pas simplement et en même temps
refuser le fait que les vendeurs d'asile
puissent être traités puisqu'ils sont en
demande d'asile donc ils sont légalement
sur notre territoire à qui nous offrons
une prestation sociale qui s'appelle
Lada à qui nous devons l'étude de sa
demande d'asile et leur fusée de devoir
rester concentré dans un endroit ils ne
peuvent pas s'intégrer ou ils ne peuvent
pas avoir accès à l'éducation à
l'intégration et pour certains d'entre
eux à l'école puisqu'on consent des
difficultés dans des quartiers au lieu
de décider de répartir ces difficultés
et vous savez moi j'ai été maire d'une
commune j'ai la première chose que j'ai
accepté ce que faisait pas toujours mon
prédécesseur qui porterait pas de ma
couleur politique c'est d'accepter des
demandes quand le préfet me le demander
quand le préfet du gouvernement vase et
Cazaux me le demander à condition bien
évidemment que à condition que les
choses se fassent en proportion de ce
que peut faire la moyenne non pas
seulement de la commune c'est un peu
ridicule de parler que de la commune
pardon mais du territoire parce que le
département y intervient ou la région
intervient après c'est une question
sensible compliqué on l'a vu encore
extrêmement récemment bon je partage pas
tout à fait votre constat on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler si le maire n'a
pas été consulté par Monsieur le Préfet
ou par la préfète c'est une erreur bien
évidemment puisque la consigne c'est la
consultation après que au bout d'un
moment le maire ne soit pas d'accord oui
bah il y a vraiment il faut que l'État
prenne des décisions même ça c'est comme
les places de prison et c'est comme les
plats centrales moi je voudrais dire
rassemblement du groupe national aux
membres du groupe du Rassemblement
national que j'attends toujours une
proposition d'un maire du rassemblement
national qui me propose une place de
centre de rétention administratif
monsieur le maire de Fréjus je n'ai pas
de réponse le Seigneur d'un abonnement
je n'ai pas de réponse
pour un multiplier Monsieur le Maire
dupontet j'ai pas de j'ai pas de réponse
voilà donc
l'écran c'est aujourd'hui chez les
autres voilà donc je propose puisque
vous aurez des collectivités que vous
puissiez nous en présenter un son de
rétention administratif sur la question
de Monsieur le con je pense que j'y ai
répondu monsieur bernalicis je suis
désolé de vous dire une nouvelle fois
que vous êtes trompé puisque c'est en
2018 que j'ai supprimé les loyers les
loyers budgétaires
voilà donc ça change que vous êtes
trompé c'est pour vous pour vous c'est
pour vous c'est peut-être un détail mais
pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup
sur les heures supplémentaires de la
police sur les heures supplémentaires
dans la police nationale le stock est en
baisse pour la troisième fois
consécutive puisque nous sommes passés
de 16,5 millions d'heures à 14,7 de
chaque année on en gagne 2 millions
qu'on doit aux policiers c'est
évidemment pas toujours suffisant mais
c'était finalement important
sur la formation ce député vous savez
vous-même vous parlez le budgétaire 2022
les quatre mois supplémentaires on les
vit puisque c'est 8 mois plus 4 dans
l'année à cheval sur l'année 2023 donc
on a déjà eu trois fois cette discussion
vous voulez pas avouer que vous avez
tort on a augmenté la formation de
quatre mois bon voilà en tout cas ce qui
est très étonnant pour la part de gens
qui à chaque fois disent qu'il y a pas
assez de qui a pas assez de crédit c'est
que vous votez jamais des crédits en
augmentation de la police et la
gendarmerie donc au bout d'un moment il
y a pas de preuve d'amour autre que le
vote monsieur le député
avec le 49-3
j'ai défendu mes crédits
largement puisque on n'a pas le même
constat du rapport de la Cour des
comptes je pensais avoir répondu tout à
l'heure
on a encore pas mal de sujets donc on
continue on arrive au second temps de la
discussion de s'intéresser au thème
d'évaluation choisi par trois des
rapports spéciaux tout d'abord on
commence par celui de la délivrance des
titres et les indicateurs de performance
présenté par Monsieur Charles de Courson
sur le rapporteur spécial vous avez la
parole pour 10 minutes
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur Géral
mes chers collègues la délivrance des
cartes nationales d'identité et des
passeports connaît une crise sans
précédent depuis plus d'un an le délai
d'attente pour obtenir ces documents
d'identité atteints des niveaux inégalés
qu'il s'agisse d'une première demande ou
d'un renouvellement actuellement il faut
compter en moyenne plus de 4 mois pour
espérer obtenir sa CNI ou son passeport
il ne s'agit là que d'une moyenne les
délais de délivrance pouvant attendre
d'autres extrêmes selon le lieu de dépôt
j'y reviendrai dans quelques instants
l'examen du dernier projet de loi de
finance
j'ai appelé l'attention du gouvernement
et de la représentation nationale sur ce
problème important notamment en déposant
un certain nombre d'amendements hélas
l'engagement de la responsabilité
gouvernement sur le projet de loi de
finances avant l'examen des crédits de
la mission AGT en séance m'a empêché
monsieur le ministre de vous interpeller
à ce sujet
c'est donc pourquoi j'ai choisi de
consacrer mon thème de printemps de
l'évaluation à cette problématique afin
de savoir comment nous étions nous en
étions arrivés là à de tels pour
accomplir une démarche administrative
aussi banale et par quels moyens les
choses pourraient être améliorées tout
d'abord il faut comprendre de quoi il
est question lorsqu'on parle des délais
de délivrance des titres il y a en
réalité une succession de délais qui
débute par le temps d'attendre d'un
rendez-vous pour déposer son dossier
dans une mairie équipée d'un dispositif
de recueil un Dr destiné à recueillir
les empreintes digitales il y en a un
peu plus de 2600 actuellement commune
j'y reviendrai dans un instant ce délai
d'obtention du rendez-vous le plus long
et le plus dégradé actuellement il est
de 67 jours ouvrés en moyenne soit
environ 3 mois et il est arrivé à ce
niveau dès le deuxième trimestre 2022
fin 2018 il était de 11,5 jours mais il
ne s'agit que d'une moyenne dans
certaines communes équipées il faut
passionner jusqu'à 150 jours d'autres
arrivent encore à afficher aucun délai
notamment lorsqu'elle propose aux
usagers de venir sans rendez-vous une
fois qu'un dossier complet a été déposé
par un demandeur il faut encore compter
un délai d'attente de 29 jours en
moyenne actuellement pour obtenir la CNI
ou le passeport contre 15,8 jours en
2018 au total le délai d'attente a
augmenté de 69 jours en moyenne par
rapport à 2018 en réalité ce temps
d'attente comprend lui-même toute une
série de délais qui commence par
l'instruction du dossier dans un centre
d'expertise et de ressources des titres
un certes dépendant d'une préfecture et
se poursuit avec la mise en production
du document par l'Agence nationale des
titres c'est qui tue sécuriser la NTS et
se termine par sa fabrication à
l'abriole nationale avant la cheminement
dans la mairie où se demande où la
demande a été déposée lorsqu'on met tous
ces délais bout on obtient un temps
d'attente d'environ 96 jours ouvrés
actuellement contre 27 en 2018 soit plus
d'un triplement soit plus de 4 mois
calendaires ce qui suscite légitimement
la colère des usagers surtout à
l'approche des vacances d'été lors des
examens du PLF j'avais été étonné par
l'absence de véritables indicateur
relatifs à ses délais dans le projet
annuel de performance de la mission agte
il existe bien un indicateur intitulé
délai moyen d'instruction des titres
mais il ne mesure en réalité que le
temps d'instruction par les certes
d'après le dernier rapport annuel de
performance délai était de 18 jours pour
les passeports et de 21 jours pour les
cartes nationales d'identité en 2022 on
me répondra sans doute que le temps
d'obtention d'un rendez-vous en mairie
n'est pas du ressort du responsable du
programme 354 administration
territoriale de l'État pourtant la
dévérance des titres vient une
compétence de l'État les communes étant
finalement que les points de dépôt de
demande et qui plus est sur la base du
volontariat parlons maintenant des
réponses que le Gouvernement a souhaité
apporter à cette crise des pièces
d'identité le mois de mai 2022 donc il y
a maintenant un an un plan d'urgence
nationale a été mis en oeuvre ce plan a
pour simplifié deux axes le premier
consiste à croître l'offre de
rendez-vous en mairie cela passe par
l'augmentation du nombre de Dr d'une
part et par l'optimisation de l'accueil
des usagers d'autre part le second axe
c'est l'accélération de l'instruction
des demandes qui a impliqué le
renforcement temporaire des effectifs
des certes l'achat du matériel pour
l'imprimerie nationale ou encore la
promotion du site de prédemandes en
ligne de la NTS parmi les dernières
mesures de ce plan d'urgence figure le
contrat urgence titre cette convention
qui peut être conclue entre un maire et
le préfet promet une prime de 4000 euros
par Dr à la commune qui accroît le
nombre de demandes de titres recueillies
d'au moins 20% figure également la mise
en place sur la base du volontariat
d'une plateforme commune de rendez-vous
à laquelle les mairies peuvent
s'affilier afin d'éviter les doublons et
avec une majoration de dotation de 500
euros à la clé
bien entendu ces mesures sont dans
l'ensemble bienvenue mais je ne suis pas
certain qu'elle regroupement le problème
à moyen long terme il est pour leur
difficile de bien évaluer leur impact
sur les délais après une lampe décrue au
second semestre 2022 ils sont à nouveau
repartis à la hausse à mon sens le plan
d'urgence ne peut avoir qu'un impact
limité précisément dans la mesure où il
est conçu pour traiter une urgence un
problème conjoncturel qui serait
uniquement lié à la hausse saisonnière
des demandes de titres à l'approche de
l'été et un effet de rattrapage
post-covide qui engorgerait tout le
système je pense au contraire que la
crise actuelle est révélatrice d'un
défaut de conception de ce système de
délivrance des titres en place dans sa
forme actuelle depuis 2017 la fin de la
pandémie la levé des restructions en
voyage n'a fait qu'accentuer un
dysfonctionnement qui était déjà présent
j'en veux pour preuve que le délai moyen
d'obtention d'un rendez-vous ce qui
s'est déjà à 27,9 jours ouvrés en juin
2019 l'origine des problèmes rencontrés
vient en réalité du fait que nous sommes
passés de 36 000 communes
ou les Français pouvaient accomplir ses
démarches à 2600 seulement actuellement
et ce sur la base du volontariat de plus
ce système est déterréalisé puisque
chaque
usagée peut se rendre dans la mairie
équipée de Dr de son choix la
condensation financière pour
l'installation d'une station d'accueil
des demandes ne guerres intéressantes
financièrement pour les communes jusqu'à
l'année dernière la dotation forfaitaire
pour les petites sécurisés la DTS
s'élevait à 8580 euros par an et par Dr
avec une majoration de 3550 euros pour
les Dr qui enregistrait annuellement
plus de 1875 demandes lors du dernier
PLF j'avais plaidé pour aller vers un
système strictement proportionnelle
j'étais en partie entendue puisque
depuis le 1er janvier de cette date la
DTS se compose d'une part d'une base de
9000 euros à laquelle s'ajoute une part
variable selon le nombre de demandes qui
peut atteindre 12500 euros pour les Dr
ayant plus de 4000 demandes par an soit
une dotation globale si on inclut une
petite majoration de 5 euros pour ceux
qui adhèrent à la plateforme de
rendez-vous commune dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure de somme totale de 22.000
euros par derrière tout cela est une
bonne chose mais je continue de plaider
pour une compensation entièrement
proportionnelle c'est à dire tant
d'euros par titre assorti de malus en
cas de sous-utilisation d'un Dr j'en ai
fait constater qu'il y a des écarts
considérables les 10% des Dr les plus
utilisés traitent en moyenne 500
demandes par mois tandis que les 10% les
moins utilisés n'en traitent qu'une
vingtaine il y a certes une question de
déploiement au niveau territorial mais
aussi des moyens alloués par les
communes certains proposent des
rendez-vous toute la semaine d'autres
sur les crènes réduits d'autres enfin
priorisent bien que ce soit en principe
interdit leurs habitants ou ceux de
l'intercommunalité par rapport à ceux
qui n'en font pas partie c'est pourquoi
je suis favorable à ce que les
conventions avec les mairies fixent des
objectifs quantitatifs en manière de
délai de fixation des rendez-vous au
lieu de ce bordel à régir
question matérielle des Dr enfin je suis
favorable à une augmentation des droits
de timbre sur le titre d'identité afin
de financer une meilleure compensation
pour les communes ça vous intéresser
monsieur le ministre je rappelle que la
CNI est gratuite depuis 1998 en
dernièrement ce n'était pas le cas on
payait 25 euros alors que la détention
de ce titre n'est pas obligatoire sauf
en cas de perte ou l'usagers continue à
s'acquitter de 25 euros sachant que il y
a 5,5 millions de cartes d'identité qui
sont produites chaque année que la
différence des passeports est payante je
pense qu'il y a là une petite ressource
à trouver de 137,5 millions d'après les
calculs je rappelle que les passeports
eux sont payants et un prix très
supérieur enfin je précise que mon
rapport abordera également le sujet des
titres de séjour mais étant donné qu'il
s'agit d'une problématique complètement
différente puisque ce sont les
préfectures qui est sous-préfecture
qu'il est délivre et qu'elle ne fait pas
l'objet d'une actualité aussi brûlante
que celle des cartes d'identité des
passeports je préfère aujourd'hui
concentrer mon propos sur la seule crise
de ces deux titres je vous remercie de
votre attention merci à vous la parole
monsieur le ministre
très rapidement monsieur le député avant
versant du travail que vous avez
effectué on partage beaucoup de vos
constats peut-être pas toutes vos
conclusions d'abord le rétablissement
d'un impôt puisque c'est ça le droit de
timbre c'est une fiscalité
supplémentaire toucherait en premier
lieu les personnes les plus en
difficulté que à choisir entre un des
deux titres d'identité on sait tous que
par ailleurs une partie de ce droit de
Tam empêcher des personnes parfois
d'avoir cette pièce d'identité notamment
dans la république sociale les plus
touchés donc moi je suis pas favorable
rétablissement du droit de temps mais je
vois bien ce que ce que vous évoquiez en
revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que l'État
a continué par deux fois me semble-t-il
à donner davantage de moyens parce que à
l'époque sans doute et je veux bien le
dire devant vous mais cela a été négocié
il y a bien longtemps l'État n'a pas
compensé l'intégralité du coup pour les
communes de la reprise d'une partie des
communes de ces titres d'identité faire
délégation par l'État vous avez raison
de le dire alors qu'est-ce qu'on a mis
en oeuvre pour essayer de répondre à la
question merci d'avoir souligner que des
moyens avaient été malgré tout mis on a
un sujet de parc de machines de Dr qui
ont augmenté de 30%, 600 nouveaux ODR
ont été installés depuis le début de
cette année et notre difficulté n'est
pas le temps d'avoir de nombreuses
machines mais que les communes
effectivement pour une partie d'entre
elles acceptent de les installer puisque
avec EDF c'est évidemment du personnel
municipal ou des horaires étendues qu'il
faut mettre en place l'offre de
rendez-vous dans les mairies a progressé
de 80% depuis l'année dernière depuis
l'année budgétaire de votre rapport
c'est à dire qu'on est passé de 780 000
rendez-vous offerts en janvier 2022 1,4
millions pour mars 2023 c'est un chiffre
que j'ai donc c'est notamment grâce aux
efforts des collectivités aux efforts de
NTS c'est surtout grâce à ces Dr les
certits désormais un nombre de titres
qui est historiquement le plus haut le
plus haut de tout ce que
connaîtres les certes 275000 demandent
désormais traitées par semaine en 2023
nous résorbons assis le retard même si
effectivement dans certains territoires
vous avez raison de dire il reste
évidemment très difficile acceptable et
enfin on a déployé c'est la ministre
fort qui l'a mis en place 31 nouveaux
titres Drôme qui permettront de
rattraper les retards notamment dans les
territoires et les députés que vous
évoquez enfin vous savez que la
difficulté particulière c'était les
plusieurs demandes de rendez-vous fait
par personne en plusieurs mairies parce
que évidemment il cherche absolument un
identité et puis constater au moment du
monde de rendez-vous que la personne
venait pas parce que il avait été à la
mairie d'à côté donc on a fait un
fichier avec un site internet qui permet
d'éviter ces no show et on a donc 60%
numérique qui s'y sont connectés et qui
nous permettent de gagner 30% de temps
je voudrais aussi dire monsieur le
monsieur le député mais vous le vous le
savez bien évidemment qu'on a simplifié
aussi un certain nombre de demandes de
titres par ailleurs dans l'étape
notamment je pense au diplômé qui n'ont
plus besoin des titres en l'occurrence
évoquées ce qui permet également de
gagner du temps maintenant je partage
votre avis que le service public est mal
rendu du fait à la fois du covid mais
aussi peut-être un manque de prévision
de la part de l'ensemble des acteurs je
veux bien le confesser on s'inspira du
fruit de votre rapport pour pouvoir
évidemment répondre dans les quelques
semaines qui viennent à cette situation
qui est tout à fait inacceptable pour
une partie du territoire national
viens vu l'heure et les sujets qui nous
attendent je serai rapide j'entends les
chiffres monsieur le ministre mais
d'abord je suivrai à Charles de caution
a fait ce rapport parce que ça reste
pour nos concitoyens à problèmes à
certains moments insolubles quoi le
nombre de personnes qui certains moments
ont des départs prévus plusieurs mois et
qui se retrouvent y compris des fois
pour leurs enfants à pas pouvoir de
passeport et avec des des risques du
coup de ne pas pouvoir partir c'est
c'est plus que fréquent c'est voilà
c'est un des sujets majeurs que moi je
rentre dans ma circonscrit donc moi
d'abord la question que je me pose c'est
comment on est arrivé là à un moment
donné comment est arrivé d'un système où
on obtenait quand même assez vite des
papiers des passeports et autres et
comment on est arrivé la situation et
quel est l'objectif que vous donnez en
termes vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'objectif un rendez-vous voire 0
rendez-vous pour les titres quel est
l'objectif que vous donnez nationalement
pour la durée d'obtention maintenant
moi aussi envie de dire envie de
commencer en disant que c'est un
problème qui est assez incompréhensible
pour les Français qui est des problèmes
bien sûr qu'on ne soit pas capable de
les résoudre après un an ou 18 mois ou
deux ans c'est assez incompréhensible
sur le les recommandations du rapporteur
spécial bon moi je suis un peu surpris
par le cette volonté de faire payer
le CNI on sait que ce seront
nos concitoyens les plus fragiles qui
plairaient qui serait le plus marqué par
ça alors que comme cette optionnel
aujourd'hui on a quand même besoin en
terme de sécurité ça me paraît mieux que
la carte nationale d'identité soit la
plus partagée par par le plus grand
nombre donc j'avoue je ne comprends pas
bien votre objectif est-ce que c'est de
réduire la demande ou est-ce que c'est
d'avoir une recette supplémentaire ma
deuxième remarque sur
le
territorisation des demandes de CNI
c'est ce qui paraît assez content
contre-intuitif quand on veut régler un
problème de de délai c'est-à-dire qu'on
a plutôt intérêt à massifier si vous
voulez pour réduire les écarts qu'on
peut avoir entre tel ou tel site tel ou
tel mairie donc je pense que c'est cert
au niveau régional
à mon avis doivent apporter une
meilleure répartition de la charge de
travail donc j'avoue que je suis assez
surpris enfin sur la compensation des
collectivités territoriales là aussi je
peux comprendre que ce soit
proportionnel mais voilà si vous n'avez
pas une partie forfaitaire vous allez
mettre dans la certitude les
collectivités territoires les plus
petites qui pourrait être amené à une
plus grande service c'est passé parce
qu'on veut donc un peu contradictoire
est-ce que vous proposez juste avant
seraient la nation donc voilà je passe
certains non plus que ça permet ça
risque de créer un de régler un problème
et d'en créer un et d'en créer un autre
ou je dois aussi je suis spontanément
pas très favorable merci et on va passer
aux orateurs de groupe est-ce que vous
êtes en accord sur le fait qu'on se
contente des orateurs de groupe et qui
est pas d'orateur en plus OK et chacun
n'est pas obligé de chaque groupe n'est
pas non plus obligé d'intervenir Mathieu
Lefebvre
oui merci monsieur le Président
rapidement pour dire que le groupe
Renaissance s'opposera aux créations
d'impôts aux hausse d'impôts proposent
leur rapporteur spécial et deuxièmement
on s'étonne beaucoup des mesures
coercitives comme l'a dit le rapporteur
général parce que votre rapport propose
un de vos territorialiser la délivrance
de renforcer le contrôle de l'offre de
rendez-vous de rendre contraignant les
conventions de mise à disposition des
dispositifs de recueil et un système
punitif de malus pour les communes je
vois difficilement comment ça se
conjugue avec un petit peu plus de de
souplesse qui est à mon sens nécessaire
pour la délivrance des titres par
ailleurs au nom du groupe Renaissance
saluer l'effort budgétaire qui a fait
l'état s'agissant des dispositifs de
recueil en faveur des collectivités la
dotation étant passée de 48 millions
d'euros à 72 millions d'euros pour
recueillir un nombre de rendez-vous
supérieurs et d'ailleurs le nombre de
rendez-vous et singulièrement supérieur
en 2023 qu'il ne l'était en 20 de manger
une question sur la délivrance des
titres relatifs aux étrangers donc les
titres de séjour pour savoir si on
pouvait envisager si vous envisagiez de
passer à une logique intégrale de back
office avec un traitement des dossiers
sans aucune prise de rendez-vous pour
les dossiers qui ne poseraient aucune
difficulté comme vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure aussi Aymeric salmon
rassemblement oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre moi je veux voir
une question un peu particulière sur ce
sujet pour qu'il y ait une moyenne des
livres de papier à 58 jours c'est à dire
qu'il y a des communes ça se passe
beaucoup moins bien monsieur rapporteur
l'a dit des communes où ça se passe
beaucoup mieux et les délais sont
beaucoup plus courts mais on connaît
tous je pense localement des communes ou
ça se passe très très bien ça se passe
très vite moi je le souvenir de
l'éditeur Bretagne encore il y a
quelques temps une communauté devait pas
la cité pour pas la mettre en difficulté
mais où elle est connue régionalement
voire même nationalement pour un
délivrer très rapidement des papiers et
donc elle répond à beaucoup de demandes
quand même parce que beaucoup de gens
voient la
la contacter donc comment se fait-il que
des communes arrivent à résoudre et à
remplir la mission de service public
dans des délais assez courts quel
problème qui fait que ailleurs c'est pas
possible est-ce qu'on peut pas dupliquer
ce que ce qui arrive à faire certaines
petites communes si vous voulez offre
pourrait vous donner le nom de la
commune pour que vos services puissent
contacter le bien en question mais
comment s'est-il qu'aujourd'hui des
communes arrivent à faire à rendre ce
service public correctement voilà ça
sera tout merci
merci
Florian chouch France insoumise
Patrick Hetzel merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président ce ministre je voudrais là
aussi focaliser sur l'un des points
évoqués par le rapporteur spécial qui
est la question de l'indemnisation des
communes on voit bien que aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation où un certain
nombre de communes ont aussi été
réticentes à ce qui est de nouveau
dispositifs qui soient déployés pour il
faut bien le dire pour des questions
financières ce que évidemment
l'appareil est une chose enfin le
dispositif et puis ensuite il faut
évidemment du personnel qui
puisse accueillir le public et faire
faire le travail de recensement et donc
pour cela certaines communes disent et
bien la compensation de l'État ne nous
permet pas de je dirais de financer les
postes en question donc est-ce que
là-dessus vous ne pensez pas qu'il
faudrait peut-être mettre en place de
manière contractuel quelque chose de
plus important quitte à ce que ça ne
soit que ponctuel pour essayer quand
même d'avancer un petit peu plus vite
puisque comme l'indique le rapporteur
spécial la question elle est déjà en
amont la NTS est en train de résorber
même si il y a encore des délais ça
semble être davantage prise en charge
que la montre est-ce que là il y a pas
quelque chose à faire avec une
incitation financière supérieure je vous
remercie merci Perrine Goulet pour les
pour le modem merci
président monsieur le ministre alors
effectivement on peut se féliciter de
tout ce qui est mis en place pour
essayer de réduire le temps d'obtention
et de renouvellement de ses papiers
certes il est de 67 jours en moyenne
mais n'oublions pas qu'il y a certains
endroits ça peut aller jusqu'à 5 à 6
mois comme à Nantes notamment alors bien
entendu nous ne pensons pas comme le
groupe Renaissance que la solution passe
par ce que préconise le rapporteur
c'est-à-dire un droit de timbre sur la
délivrance de ces titres toutefois on
peut peut-être regarder autre chose y
a-t-il des bonus malus à mettre en
fonction de la sous-utilisation ou
l'utilisation correcte du dispositif de
recueil ça peut peut-être être une
solution pour aller accompagner les
communes et ça et alors après autre
chose c'est sur des indicateurs de
performance il s'avère que les délais de
délivrance des types d'identité ne
prennent pas en compte le processus dans
la totalité c'est à dire depuis l'après
demande en ligne jusqu'à la récupération
du titre par l'usager là on n'a pas un
indicateur des documents de budgétaire
ainsi les dés de rendez-vous auprès des
mairies les fabrication d'acheminement
ou de retrait par l'usagers ne sont pas
comptabilisés dans un indicateur de
performance on voulait savoir Monsieur
Miss il serait si vous prévoyez de
mettre en place un tel indicateur pour
avoir effectivement la totalité du
dispositif qui soit couvert merci
Marietta karamans pour le groupe
socialiste
et le rapporteur
il est un nombre des éléments moi je
voulais juste peut-être insister sur la
question de de la plateforme qui a été
créée par l'Agence nationale des titres
sécurisés pour pouvoir répondre un petit
peu sur la prise en la prise de
rendez-vous en ligne et sous les
indicateurs justement est-ce que les
indicateurs monsieur le ministre ne
devraient pas intégrer justement cette
notion de de satisfaction des demandes
présentées en urgence parce que
finalement quand quelqu'un prend
un en voyage de billets ou une urgence
ne pas forcément la même chose que quand
on s'inscrit dans un processus un peu
plus plus normalisé je dirais donc c'est
ça c'est la première question et puis
quelles sont les aussi les moyens qui
engagés dans les mairies afin de
d'accompagner les personnes qui ne
disposent pas aussi de connexion
internet
lorsqu'ils font des demandes de titre
sécurisés il y a une évolution avec la
possibilité aujourd'hui des Francs
services de pouvoir finalement
accompagner mais on est encore loin donc
c'est et puis le dernier élément il y a
un travail qui a été réalisé sur
l'identité numérique voilà est-ce que
un chantier sur lequel il faut qu'on
avance pour pouvoir aussi faciliter un
petit peu l'attribution des titres
Michel Castellani pour
mais je leur donne la parole après en
conclusion monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup non mais quelques
réponses ce serait rapide à la fois
monsieur le Président est au rapport
général à ses orateurs d'abord je vous
rappelle que l'essentiel d'autres
difficultés c'est les années du covid
avant le covid il n'y avait pas cette
difficulté et que sur les titres de
séjour qui sera valable 10 ans pendant
deux ans les gens n'ont pas renouvelé
leur identité parce qu'ils ne voyagait
pas partie de passe autour de chez eux
et parce que de très nombreuses
collectivités locales si l'État est
fermée ces guichets donc là où vous
renouvelez 10% de tous les titres
chaque année parce que ça dure 10 ans
vous renouvelez là trois fois plus de
titres en un an et demi puisque là ça
fait un an et demi que depuis le covid
il y a encore on pourrait parler du
télétravail pour un certain nombre
d'agents ou des difficultés d'accès à
certains services publics malgré la fin
du covid ce n'est que très récemment
qu'on retrouve 100% d'action publique
physique que nous avons cette difficulté
de saut et notamment qui correspondu
malheureusement au départ des vacances
d'été alors j'entends monsieur le
président qui a des gens qui attendent
depuis cinq ou six mois des pièces
d'identité et je suis le premier bien
sûr à déplorer à considérer que ce
service public n'est pas rendu de
manière normale que nous devrons
français que nous faisons tout pour le
corriger il y a aussi des gens qui
déposent leurs pièces d'identité au
dernier moment malgré leur document de
voyage et qui ne peuvent évidemment pas
avoir leur réponse aussi rapidement
qu'il l'avait précédemment parce que
nous faisons passer en premier lieu et
c'est bien logique des gens qui
attendent par avant depuis un certain
temps donc c'est tout à fait vrai qu'il
y a des territoires où et vous éparez la
région nantaise c'est tout à fait exact
où il y a du temps beaucoup plus long
que d'autres mais je voudrais quand même
souligner que cet effet exceptionnel est
quasiment dans tous les autres pays du
monde il y a des pays qui ont pas de les
entités ça c'est un autre sujet je pense
évidemment à la Grande-Bretagne il
prévoit pas que les entités obligatoires
mais nous avons les mêmes difficultés et
qui évoquent de passeport très
différents mais nous avons évidemment
des difficultés des difficultés du fait
de ces indices est-ce qu'on aurait pu
anticiper finalement c'est la question
parce qu'on voit bien que la cause sans
doute mieux oui bien sûr on aurait
peut-être davantage plus anticiper cette
crise nous l'avions pas forcément vu moi
je veux bien plaider la continuité de
l'État puisque j'étais pas en
responsabilité politique au moment de la
crise aiguë du covid mais c'est tout à
fait vrai qu'on aurait pu leur dissiper
et pour cela le gouvernement essaie de
rattraper le temps perdu rien que les
collectivités locales alors pourquoi il
y a des communes ou c'est plus efficaces
que d'autres d'abord ça tient une chose
très bête que sont d'abord la fibre
parce que nous déployons parfois des Dr
dans des endroits où il n'y a pas de
fibres et notre difficulté principale
aujourd'hui c'est convaincre notamment
le gestionnaire orange c'est ce que fait
la ministre de Medic Faure pour mettre
en place la fille dans les territoires
ruraux au moment où les Dr vont être
installés donc d'abord il y a une
question d'accès Internet et de débit
internet c'est pas la même chose que
vous avez un très bon débit ou quand on
avait un moyen deuxièmement il y a les
horaires moi je parfois je constate
qu'il y a des collectivités locales qui
refusent d'étendre les horaires
d'accueil et notamment c'est tout ce
qu'une partie des gens qui demandent les
plus identité se concentrent le samedi
puisque c'est le jour où en général il
ne travaille pas et donc nous anticipons
plusieurs fois par la demande des
préfets que c'est pas simplement
d'ouvrir des Dr et d'accès de Dr le
journée de la semaine mais finalement il
faut l'ouvrir le week-end et c'est
régulièrement le samedi qui pose des
problèmes de gestion de collectivités
locales dans supplémentaires et de
gestion des RH je conteste pas enfin si
on veut résoudre le problème il y a des
mérites qui acceptent de travailler et
de faire travailler leurs agents
notamment le samedi parfois même
d'ailleurs dans certains cas le dimanche
troisièmement ça dépend aussi beaucoup
du territoire dans lequel vous êtes si
autour de vous il y a énormément de
communes qui sont équipées de Dr ça va
structuellement plus vite que que quand
il y a quelques communes qui sont
équipées de Dr et lorsque la population
je le dis parce que je constate dans ma
commune qui commune plutôt pauvre la
demande des habitants évidemment c'est
d'avoir des pièces d'identités ils en
ont moins besoin à l'approche des
vacances que lorsque la population est à
traduit plus aisé et qui a dans toute la
famille a besoin de passeport c'était
pour partir à l'étranger en vacances ou
en déplacement professionnel et donc on
aussi constater que les difficultés les
plus importantes étaient souvent dans
les territoires les plus aisés parce que
la demande faite par nos concitoyens de
plus identité pour voyager à l'approche
des vacances c'était plus importante que
dans les territoires qui étaient plus
touchés socialement donc il y a plein
d'explications géographiques pour
lesquelles les choses se passent pas
forcément partout pareil même si elle
est disparités qui sont parfois
difficilement compréhensibles et qui
s'explique notamment par le fait que il
y a eu un long moment c'est pas de no
show où les gens ont demandé plusieurs
rendez-vous devant le stress que
représentait la non présence de papiers
d'identité et n'allait pas annuler les
rendez-vous une fois qu'il avait obtenu
l'heure voilà et donc ça c'est un sujet
c'est jusqu'à 30% dans certains dans
certains départements donc c'est quand
même un tiers des demandes de
rendez-vous en moi donc vous allez
constater vous-même dans votre rapport
me semble-t-il monsieur le rapporteur
que la NTS a respecté des délais que le
sujet est donc plutôt en amont que du
côté de l'Agence des titres sécurisés le
deuxième sujet
sur les indicateurs de sujets
performance je comprends la demande des
parlementaires alors évidemment nous
dans notre document budgétaire en
présente la performance de l'État bon
ces agences c'était la question qui
évoquait tout à l'heure monsieur le
député de Bourseau moi je suis pas
défavorable du tout regardez la chaîne
du service public alors on peut le
modifier mais pardon je dis à la député
c'est aussi à vous de modifier vous
pouvez si vous le souhaitez le modifier
en tout cas prenons-en quitte que si ce
que la commission des finances c'est le
gouvernement il est favorable on puisse
avoir dans les prochains documents
budgétaires la chaîne du service public
ça m'aura sans doute des éléments qu'on
aura peut-être pas totalement au moment
de discussion budgétaire mais enfin qui
nous paraît effectivement effectivement
importante sur la question de Monsieur
Lefebvre notamment je remercie de
souligner les efforts fait par le par le
gouvernement les annonce de la première
ministre sur le non passage physique ça
me paraît difficile de le faire de
manière généralisée pour être identité
parce qu'il faut prendre les empreintes
tous les 10 ans alors ça si on trouve un
système numérique qui nous permet de
façon
non falsifiable de prendre des
empreintes à distance
ce qui pourrait être imaginé
techniquement enfin je l'explique pas
par nature en tout cas c'est pas dans
les prochaines années donc il fera
toujours au moins un passage pour
prendre le paluchage comme on dit
ministère de l'Intérieur pour pouvoir
récupérer votre votre
identité
des pousses pardon ce qui permet ce qui
permet de vérifier que c'est bien votre
titre votre titre d'identité et pour
répondre oui l'identité numérique c'est
une des réponses mais c'est pas la seule
réponse d'ailleurs je voudrais dire que
l'identité numérique votre pièce
d'identité numérique sur un téléphone
elle est en complément votre pièce
d'identité physique d'ailleurs pour
accéder à la pièce d'identité numérique
il faut avoir une pièce d'identité
physique c'est pas le remplacement par
mais demain ça permettra si vous avez
perdu votre votre titre de pouvoir
effectivement voyager dans un train
prendre l'avion payer un certain nombre
de choses ou faire des duplicata je
voudrais quand même dire que nous avons
réussi parce que cette difficulté
extrêmement forte du service public mal
rendu sur les pilosités peut faire
oublier quand même réussi du ministère
de l'Intérieur qu'elle est 15 millions
de nouvelles pièces d'identité numérique
que nous vous fournissons qui permettent
la nonne usurpation identité grâce à la
puce format permis de conduire qui a été
qui a été donné aux français puisque je
pense que l'un des problèmes monsieur le
Président pour répondre à votre question
la covid est arrivée au moment où on
mettait en place cette pièce d'identité
numérique nouvelle donc par ailleurs on
a changé les process de la NTS on a
changé les process des mairies on a
changé la production de ces périosité de
ce que j'en ai vu il y a pas eu de
retard à cause de ça mais enfin on peut
quand même penser qu'une partie des
équipes était mobilisée par ce projet
numérique et ce projet d'identité
nouvelle qui était importante parce que
800 000 usures passion d'identité par an
ce qui est un chiffre absolument énorme
qui cause plein de problèmes
d'escroquerie que vous connaissez par
exemple et que nous arrivons à résoudre
grâce à cette pièce d'identité qui sera
totalement déployée d'ici 7 ans puisque
c'est le renouvellement par dixième des
pièces d'identité
merci monsieur le rapporteur spécial
vous pouvez conclure l'examen de vos
travaux oui quelques commentaires
j'ai posé la question de la gratuité de
la carte d'identité alors que le
passeport est payant à 85 euros
prix très supérieur d'ailleurs au prix
de revient pour l'État
parce que le cœur du problème ce sont
les moyens mis en oeuvre par les
communes qui ont volontairement choisi
d'avoir un Dr et de délivrer cela et
vous avez des communes qui ont mis de
gros moyens ce qui explique des temps
d'attente extrêmement faibles et que le
gouvernement d'ailleurs a augmenté de 40
millions et cette année je crois qu'on
serait entoure de 100 millions
d'indemnisation des communes et comme je
suis moins très soucieux des finances
publiques monsieur
le porte-parole du groupe Renaissance
c'est un moyen de financer cela voilà
et je rappelle que on peut pas expliquer
pourquoi c'est gratuit pour les CNI
enfin pour les cartes d'identité
pourquoi c'est payant pour les
passeports et à un prix beaucoup plus
élevé 85 et donc je pense que c'est un
moyen de financer les communes
sans affectation bien sûr mais de le
compenser je pense que ça c'est le
problème sur la territorialisation le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez venir moi j'ai une commune dans
mon département qui a un Dr
toute personne qui vient est
immédiatement traiter donc dès l'aide
d'attente 0 il y a des gens qui viennent
de région parisienne est-ce que c'est
raisonnable et la territorialisation ça
consistera à dire tel Dr des serres 10
15 communes voilà et et de répartir les
efforts sinon c'est extrêmement
hétérogène et Monsieur le Ministre les
délais d'attente ne sont pas liés à aux
problèmes technologiques de est-ce que
il y a une oui parce que on se on se
pense pour se voir
notre chers collègues
c'est pas ça le vrai problème le vrai
problème ce sont les moyens mis en place
et quand aux critères qualitatifs que je
préconise se trouve pas normal que
l'État verse de l'argent
sans fixer un objectif avec
éventuellement un bonus malus d'ailleurs
l'État a commencé à faire un début de
bonus je voulais mis dans mon rapport
donc on s'oriente dans cette direction
mais je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
je vois pas pourquoi l'État paye de
l'argent sans dire l'objectif c'est 30
jours maximum 30 jours ou de délai entre
le moment où on saisit et le moment où
on a le rendez-vous et d'encourager la
qualité du service public monsieur
Lefebvre vous voyez je pense que c'est
le programme important la qualité du
service public et de récompenser les
bons voire de pénaliser les mauvaises un
principe de base de la bonne
organisation et de la bonne gestion des
finances publiques
merci j'interroge la commission afin que
l'autorité de la publication se rapporte
d'information sur la thématique
d'évaluation du rapporteur spécial s'il
n'y a pas de position la publication du
rapport
non non
vous autoriserez à reprendre la parole
de minutes qu'on aura fait la pause
toilette que vous venez nous demander
s'il n'y a pas d'opposition la
publication du rapport d'information est
autorisée on fait une petite pause
mais non non mais je crois que collègues
vous compreniez que je fais aussi en
fonction des disponibilités des
ministres
on se retrouve ce soir avec avec autant
de sujets parce que c'est ce que je
disais aussi c'est que vous avez du
succès donc il y a pas mal de succès de
rapports spéciaux
allez je propose qu'on recommence que là
on est en direct
vous vouliez dire répondre quelque chose
est parti je m'en veux lui rappeler que
si j'avais fait bonus palus il me
reprochait comment
des collectivités locales il a parfois
un peu incohérent mais il est pas pour
les effort donc d'accord alors comme il
est pas là pour se défendre on va passer
à la deuxième discussion thématique
l'orientation directive des demandeurs
d'asile en région présenté par un Stella
Dupont mais tu vois Mathieu Lefebvre qui
je pense se sont répartis la parole
merci monsieur le ministre chers
collègues nous allons donc vous
présenter le résultat de cette
évaluation
donc que nous avons conduites sur la
politique d'orientation directive des
demandeurs d'asile qui est mis en oeuvre
par le ministère de l'Intérieur depuis
janvier 2021 et qui a pour but de
rééquilibrer l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile sur l'ensemble du territoire
national c'est la loi du 10 septembre
2018 qui a posé les principes de cette
orientation directive et en 2020 au
moment de la définition du premier
schéma national d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile un constat s'imposait la région
Île-de-France concentrait 20% des
capacités d'hébergement des demandeurs
d'asile et 46% des demandes d'asile vu
de l'extérieur et pour beaucoup de
demandeurs d'asile la France c'est Paris
ou plutôt la France c'est
l'Île-de-France en définitive et afin de
réduire la concentration de de des
demandeurs d'asile constatés en
Île-de-France un rééquilibrage de
l'accueil dans les territoires
s'imposaient d'autant plus que cette
forte concentration de la demande
d'asile sur la région parisienne était à
la routine de situations inacceptables
avec la formation de campement insalubre
des conditions d'accueil indigne et bien
que les campements perdurent et nous le
regrettons la part de migrants et pas
uniquement des demandeurs d'asile à la
rue à Paris a connu une baisse puisqu'en
2022 le comptage toujours trop élevé et
on insiste sur ce point de migrants à la
rue est estimé à un peu plus de 500
personnes en 2018 on était à 2400
personnes donc on voit tout le chemin
parcour
les récents événements survenus à
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins avec la démission
du maire Monsieur Morez ont ramené au
centre des débats cette question de
l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile dans
les territoires et en tant que mère
moi-même je l'indiquais tout à l'heure
j'ai été à l'origine de la création d'un
lieu d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile
dans ma commune de Chalonnes-sur-Loire
dans le Maine-et-Loire et si à l'époque
des habitants ont pu se poser des
questions légitimes nous avons pu y
répondre et ces questions n'ont jamais
donné lieu au moindre débordement et
avec Monsieur Lefebvre nous avons pu
échanger dans le cadre de nos travaux
avec Monsieur Morez ainsi que Monsieur
Laurent Laroche mère de la petite
commune de Belâbre dans l'Indre qui fait
lui aussi face avec courage et dignité à
des comportements inacceptables en lien
avec un projet d'implantation d'un
centre d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile
dans sa commune et nous leur réitérons
tout notre soutien
avant de passer la main à Mathieu
Lefebvre pour vous faire part de nos
conclusions je vais vous partager nos
quatre questions
tout d'abord monsieur le ministre de
quelle manière on envisagez-vous
justement de renforcer la protection des
élus locaux confrontés aux menaces et
violences dont nous avons parlé
qu'elle devrait être l'évolution de la
capacité du dispositif national
d'accueil en 2024 la question de la
capacité du nombre d'hébergements reste
au cœur de notre politique publique
croyez-vous aussi possible d'associer le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale à la
préparation du prochain schéma national
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile puisque
pour les enfants accéder à
l'apprentissage du français est
important partout sur tous les
territoires et une dernière question qui
me tient très à coeur vous avez commencé
à y répondre tout à l'heure sur
l'hébergement citoyen des demandeurs
d'asile dont le développement pourrait
contribuer à favoriser la fluidité du
dispositif national d'accueil et
désengorger parfois et notamment pour
les réfugiés aussi qui parfois ont du
mal à accéder à un logement donc je
crois que l'hébergement
citoyen peut être une piste intéressante
à partir du moment où il est bien
maîtrisé bien encadré bien accompagné
par et bien coordonnées par des
professionnels bien entendu merci
à vous monsieur Lefebvre merci monsieur
le Président oui c'est un rapport que
nous invitons nos collègues du
rassemblement national à lire avec
Stella Dupont pour leur éviter de
confondre demandeur d'asile et étranger
en situation irrégulière et éviter
d'évoquer l'orientation directive comme
une stratégie de repeuplement de nos
campagnes ça n'a absolument rien à voir
je voudrais à mon tour redire toute la
solidarité de notre groupe à l'endroit
des mers qui a évoqué Stella monsieur
Morez et Monsieur et Monsieur Laroche et
je les invite également à se rapprocher
de la stratégie du gouvernement visant à
protéger les élus qui sont concernés par
par ces implantations donc s'agissant de
l'orientation directive on fait un bilan
plutôt positif de ces de ces deux années
quelques chiffres pour s'en convaincre
en deux ans 48000 demandeurs d'asile se
sont vus proposer une orientation
directive 12000 l'ont refusé 36 millions
ont acceptés et un peu plus de 30000 ont
rejoint leur lieu d'hébergement la
première considération c'est que ça nous
avons mis de desserrer fortement la
pression qui était exercée sur
l'Île-de-France de ce point de vue la
part de Primo demandeur d'asile en
Île-de-France est passé de 46 à 35% avec
une cible à 23% à la fin de l'année 2023
le nombre de campement installés c'est
considérablement réduit ce que nous dit
la préfecture de Région
Île-de-France
c'est que le nom de migrants à la rue à
diminué entre 2019 et 2022 passant de
3500 migrants migrants environ chaque
soir à 600 en 2022 et le deuxième point
positif c'est que la part des demandeurs
d'asile hébergé a fortement progressé
compte tenu notamment de la progression
du nombre de places dans le dans le
dispositif national d'accueil
sur les effets favorables et qui
concerne pas uniquement la région
parisienne il concerne également nos
territoires puisque il y a eu plusieurs
plusieurs dispositifs milliers de place
qui ont été créés comme je viens de le
dire
cette stratégie a également bien
fonctionné parce que il y a eu de
l'adhésion de la part des demandeurs
d'asile environ 60% d'entre eux ont
accepté alors on a vu qu'il y avait des
taux de refus qui étaient plus
significatifs parmi certaines
nationalités que d'autres c'était le cas
notamment pour les Turcs et les
banglades c'est d'ailleurs pas du tout
corrélé avec infini la protection non
peuvent bénéficier ces nationalités et
c'est plus lié peut-être à des
considérations d'ordre économique ou à
des réseaux qui sont préexistants et
dans lesquels ces nationalités sont bien
insérées sur notre sur notre territoire
quelques points de fragilité la première
ce que nous ont dit évidemment tous les
préfets c'est lié au volume de la
demande d'asile même si on a on a retenu
les chiffres que nous vous nous avez
donné monsieur le monsieur le ministre
mais aussi au nombre d'indus dans le
maintien d'un dispositif national
d'accueil compte tenu paradoxalement la
réduction des délais c'est-à-dire que
les délais de décision choisi les temps
plus courts gras aux efforts fournis par
le gouvernement fait que les gens qui
sont soit déboutés soit qui ont eu la
protection
internationale reste peuvent être
maintenues indument dans le dispositif
national d'accueil on formule avec
Stella Dupont plusieurs recommandations
pour lutter contre cette indu mais aussi
c'était la Dupont l'a dit pour mieux
accompagner la situation sanitaire des
demandeurs d'asile et pour mieux
associer le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale avec la prise en compte des
élèves allophones et enfin dernière
recommandation consiste à mieux associer
les élus locaux à l'implantation
de 600 pour pour demandeurs d'asile
voilà Monsieur ministre merci monsieur
le ministre par l'État vous
merci beaucoup je vais remercier Madame
Dupont et Monsieur Lefebvre l'engagement
depuis longtemps en tout cas parce que
concerne Madame Dupont sur la question
de l'asile et de l'accompagnement des
demandes d'asile je veux dire d'abord
que sur l'agression des élus je l'ai
condamne bien évidemment que ils sont
nombreux à connaître ces difficultés
qu'il s'agisse de l'agression verbale ou
malheureusement d'agression physique et
que par ailleurs je veux redire que
ces difficultés que vous avez évoquées
madame la députée elles sont bien
portées à la connaissance du ministère
de l'Intérieur et du ministère de la
justice puisque je crois que dans le cas
du maire de Saint-Brevin la question est
à la fois la protection bien sûr
policière ou gendarmes en l'occurrence
mais également la réponse pénale et la
façon dont la République pouvait
communiquer en direct avec les élus je
sais que regarder ça il est très
attentif pour ma part j'ai pris le 16
mars dernier donc avant c'est difficulté
grave qui a connu le maire de
Saint-Brévin une instruction pour les
élus notamment dans le cadre de des
personnes demandant d'asile sur leur
territoire à la suite des demandes
parfois des obligations souhaitées par
l'État je veux dire que sur la capacité
du dispositif national d'accueil on est
passé comme vous l'avez dit à une
augmentation de classe pour ce qui nous
concerne puisque je vais prendre l'année
2023 comme année de référence désormais
de
82362 place en 2017 à quasiment 120000
119 732 places en 2023 en comptant les
donc 5900 nouvelles places qui sont
celles de cette année d'ici la fin
d'année il y aura donc 45%
d'augmentation de place pour les
demandeurs d'asile depuis le début de la
l'élection du Président de la République
et de la majorité parlementaire je pense
que c'est un effort très important en
plus de 50% quasiment d'augmentation de
place avec vous les avez vu et vous le
savez la période particulière du covid
où il y a eu aussi la loger un centre de
personnes qui étaient pas forcément
prévu pour être logé puisque la
continuité de la demande d'asile aurait
dû être poursuit d'un point de vue
administratif et puis surtout une
augmentation des routes migratoires
notamment en 2021 et 2022
les besoins comme vous l'avez dit Madame
député sont très importants alors bien
sûr ça s'améliore mais on doit bien
avouer qu'il y a encore une augmentation
du travail à faire pour le ministère de
la terre parce que à peu près 60 % des
demandes en asile ont des conditions
matérielles qui correspondent à
dispositif DNA alors j'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure pourquoi il fallait pas y voir
simplement il manque 40% de place mais
aussi des gens qui prennent la place des
demandes en asile pardon de parler comme
ça mais alors que ces places sont
réservées aux demandes en Asie il y a
surtout un travail plus fin à faire avec
le ministère du Logement ça pose des tas
de problèmes humains d'accompagnement
bien évidemment mais mais ça à
l'intérieur on est obligé de de le
constater on a donc en 2024 à la fois
imaginer s'autorité de la première
ministre de clarifier cette situation
entre demande de logement
asile demande de logement sans abri et
puis personne qui n'ont pas accès à ces
positif mais également une augmentation
des places on y travaille pour le budget
de 2024 mais je pense qu'on évoqué tout
à l'heure les arbitrages ne sont pas
encore pas encore rendu par là par la
première ministre alors je suis
rapidement évoqué tout à l'heure la
question d'éducation nationale mais je
veux dire que désormais on a proposé au
ministère des questions de participer au
groupe de travail sur le schéma national
de l'asile pour la période qui nous
lirait de 24 à 27 vers d'ici la fin du
quinquennat il participe à ce groupe du
travail notamment pour les enfants qui
sont en âge de scolariser bien
évidemment et donc j'espère que lors du
prochain discussion budgétaire on pourra
vous affirmer qu'ils ont participé et
qu'ils ont contribué sur l'hébergement
citoyen qu'on a rapidement évoqué tout à
l'heure je voudrais redire qu'il a bien
fonctionné pour l'accueil
ukrainien et il fonctionne pas en tout
cas il n'existe pas tel qu'on imagine un
échelle extrêmement limité pour les
autres demandeurs d'asile ou les autres
demandent de protection donc oui bien
sûr il faut le mettre en place comme
vous l'avez dit vous-même il faut
l'encadrer pour éviter les abus des deux
côtés d'ailleurs
j'ose dire mais mais je pense enrichi
d'expérience de de d'accueil des
Ukrainiens nous pouvons tout à fait
l'imaginer alors il y a eu un dispositif
exceptionnel qui avait été mis en place
par les préfectures et par l'État à ce
moment-là il faudrait évidemment que
puissions peut-être avoir deux trois
départements pilote parce qu'en est-il
pour généraliser le sujet si
Maine-et-Loire et candidat ce sera avec
plaisir mais je crois qu'on peut on peut
d'abord peut-être faire un petit un
petit rétexte ou peut-être d'ailleurs
vous le fournir sa ministre bacaisse qui
s'en occupe particulièrement la question
de d'hébergement citoyen et réfugiés
ukrainien à ceci près que pour
l'ukrainiens 90% d'entre eux étaient des
femmes ce qui pose sans doute une
question un peu différente peut-être que
du reste de mon nazis qui sont
majoritairement des hommes comme vous le
savez mais enfin on peut tout à fait
imaginer les choses bien sûr dans le cas
d'une intégration citoyenne comme comme
vous l'évoquez vous-même
en tout cas moi j'ai chargé la DGF avec
la diale d'y réfléchir il y a une
mission qui avait été conduite par
Frédéric Lahaye de Fremainville et
thierrychio qui entre-temps est devenu
président du la section intérieure du
Conseil d'État et donc qui a passé cette
mission à quelqu'un d'autre mais qui a
eu le temps de m'en parler donc sur
l'hébergement citoyen et nous avons déjà
prévu des dispositifs pour 110 personnes
réfugiées pour voir avec la dial comment
sur ses 110 personnes les choses peuvent
fonctionner mais évidemment le faire de
façon plus large dans les quelques
départements expérimentaux que je
pourrais vous proposer enfin sur les
prévisions des consommations de crédit
donc je redire que pour nous vu la
demande d'asile qui restait en version
basse au premier trimestre et qui baisse
au second trimestre et si les choses
devaient continuer à se confirmer nous
ne consommerons sans doute pas
l'intégralité de nos crédits de ces 321
millions par rapport à la loi de finance
évidemment comme vous le savez c'est
toujours propre aux soubresaut David
diplomatique au traversée des frontières
des difficultés que peuvent connaître
nos voisins donc je reste extrêmement
modeste enfin en tout cas on n'a pas de
tension particulière sur sur ces crédits
de la date et pour la question des
bénéficiaires de la protection
temporaire ukrainienne en moyenne sur le
premier trimestre de cette année on a eu
83675 bénéficiaires de la protection
puisque je rappelle que il y a des
doubles comptes avec notamment des
enfants parfois mais donc c'est à peu
près la même chose l'année dernière
qu'on bénéficier de cette Ada pour
l'instant on est plutôt dans l'idée que
on va maintenir à peu près avec un léger
solde peut-être positif vu l'évolution
de la guerre en Ukraine mais enfin on
est plutôt partie du principe que les
choses ne bougeraient pas on voit bien
que tu crées à la fois évidemment pose
des questions de théâtre d'opération la
pandémie militaire mais surtout les
réfugiés Ukrainiens malgré les
propositions d'accueil de la France n'a
pas été premier une destination d'abord
parce qu'il y a une petite communauté
ukrainienne en France contrairement à
l'Italie ou à l'Espagne par exemple mais
aussi à nos amis allemands qui étaient
concombres étaient ceux qui ont le plus
accueillis ukrainien après les pays
frontaliers on a envoyé par exemple des
bus des fonctionnaires pour pouvoir
ramener les gens en France et ils ont
refusé de venir donc voilà donc on
continue à ouvrir nos portes mais hormis
le coin spécifique de Nice où il y a eu
là une population plus forte de
personnes ukrainiennes il n'y a pas de
raison je pense qu'il y a des flux
particuliers du ukrainien sur le
territoire sur le territoire national
voilà ce que je peux dire en quelques
mots on va peut-être redire également à
Monsieur député Lefebvre et à Madame la
député du pont que oui il y a un sujet
d'Ile-de-France et que le desserrement
moi j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
rapidement monsieur hell il est
nécessaire pour les vendredises pour les
élus pour l'intégration et pour le
traitement leur demande voir pour le
refus et la reconduite aux frontières
mais en tout cas laissez les choses
continuent en Île-de-France de ne pas de
ne pas nécessaire et grossesse d'accueil
temporaire je rappelle que au 23 mai
c'est 7 00 qui sont désormais
opérationnels
merci
on aborde à zéro heure 25 mais c'est
l'exercice du genre des sujets qui sont
évidemment importants je remercie
c'était là Dupont et Mathilde Lefeuvre
pour ce rapport qui je trouve pose pose
de vrais questions
parce que moi je suis effectivement
persuadé que la question de
l'aménagement du territoire et la
question de la répartition du territoire
des personnes arrivent en France c'est
une des est une des solutions à une
bonne politique de migratoires bon le
souci à mon avis qui se pose dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes il
est deux ordres d'abord là j'ai bien
compris on parle de demandeur d'asile
mais sauf et là on sera sûrement des
accords monsieur le ministre mais sauf
qu'en réalité tout ça ne fait pas le
compte et notamment en Île-de-France des
personnes qui
ne sont pas régularisés et qui pour
autant ne seront jamais expulsés parce
que si ça fait des années qui vivent en
France parce qu'ils en France etc etc et
que ce qui explique très certainement
d'ailleurs le résultat de 15% de qtf
n'ont pas parce que il y aurait un
laxisme par rapport à ça mais parce que
de manière normale au bout d'un moment
il y a des il y a beaucoup de cas de
personnes qui en réalité ne peuvent pas
être partir du territoire pour plein de
raisons ou pour énumérer moi j'en ai
aussi là tous les jours
de gens qui
sont
dans les parents sont français qui ont
fait des brillants de études en France
qui ont eu juste le malheur d'être
arrivé après leurs parents et qui ne
peuvent pas se régulariser vous
travaillez etc donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que
à un moment donné au lieu de se dire les
personnes qui sont pas régularisées on
va les expulser il faut il serait
peut-être temps de voir à quel niveau
ces personnes il faut pas au contraire
chercher à faire en sorte que elle soit
intégrée la société et je pense que
chacun en aurait on aurait le plus grand
plus grand de satisfaction et si je dis
ça c'est parce que justement
tout s'acclique en réalité
la situation après d’aménagement
spirituoire bon on a déjà un premier
problème pour l'Île-de-France je pense
que
ce qui explique les relatifs échecs de
départ en région c'est qu'on a pas de
centre d'accueil digne de ce nom en
Île-de-France voilà je continue à penser
que c'est un problème c'est à dire dans
lequel ça soit véritable SAS pour les
personnes qui sont qui sont dans cette
situation en termes d'accueil
administratif je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
et qui du coup ou du coup peut-être que
le déplacement vers vers les régions
pour être anticiper mieux préparer moi
il y a pas très longtemps dans mon dans
ma circonscription il y avait plus grand
squats
Unibéton de personnes c'est clair que
quand des gens se retrouvent à été
expulsés
un matin avec avec alors qu'ils étaient
dans un squat les gens qui sont envoyés
en région ne se retrouvent pas dans les
conditions qui sont d'ailleurs décrites
à une fois par Matthieu Lefebvre comme
et comme j'étais là Dupont comme un des
problèmes c'est à dire comment les gens
qui se partent là-bas ne se sentent pas
déracinés ça peut paraître paradoxal
parce qu'il vient d'arriver mais parce
que ils n'ont pas de communauté aux
côtés d'eux parce que etc bon et ce
problème là il se prépare je pense que
il y a il y a un problème de SAS à mon
avis il y a plein de de capital dans le
monde qui ont des centres d'accueil qui
quand même tiennent un peu plus la route
que ceux qu'on a dans le pays alors
après moi je trouve que dans les
préconisations je reconnais plusieurs de
celle qui sont communes qui je trouve
intéressantes j'ai dit tout à l'heure
notamment le l'augmentation de de
demandeur d'asile de centre d'accueil
pour demandeurs d'asile le fait de
favoriser l'accès au marché du travail
pour certains vendeurs d'asile etc il y
a plusieurs populations qui sont faites
je me retrouve aussi dans des
propositions propres à Stella Dupont
parce qu'elles me semble justement de
manière concrète aller
régler enfin pas régler mais en tout cas
améliorer la situation de la personne
qui qu'on déplace et qui du coup va se
retrouver dans une situation de
d'incertitude et qui fait qu'au bout
d'un moment ils vont il va se dire ben
non finalement c'est plutôt en
Île-de-France où je vais retrouver ou
dans des grands centres urbains je
trouve que le la question du supprimer
la possibilité d'orientation directive
sans hébergement est intéressant parce
que au moins ça donne pas à la personne
la pression de qui a pas un retour
possible et je pense que cette chose là
améliore du coup le peut-être la le
l'intégration je trouve également j'ai
vu le le fait d'enrichir l'algorithme
utilisé pour déterminer la région
d'affectation d'allemand d'asile afin
que sous titienne compte de la présence
des tâches particulières de l'intéressé
je trouve c'est intéressant et bien
évidemment aussi aménager l'implantation
territoriale de l'OFI me semble utile
voilà je trouve que là il y a des
recommandations qui vont à mon avis dans
le bon sens et que je voulais souligner
sur le rapporteur
merci beaucoup je suis le président
merci à mon tour les deux rapports
spéciaux pour la qualité de leur
recommandation sur l'orientation
directive des demandeurs d'asile qui
visent donc à rééquilibrer
la prise en charge et de monarchie sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
d'objectif que nous partageons tous ont
dresser un bilan plutôt positif vous
avez
un chiffre 6 sur 10 sont acceptes
l'orientation qui leur est proposé
une remarque et deux questions très
rapide première c'est que il y a quand
même dans les cadavres de demandeurs
d'Asie qui viennent de pays et qui n'ont
absolument aucune chance d'avoir
d'avoir une une réponse positive donc je
voulais faire c'est quand même un vrai
problème donc c'est un taux d'occupation
assez important de nos cadavres avec des
gens qui fondamentalement de ne pas y
être
vous proposez d'associer le ministère
d'éducation nationale ça m'intéresse de
savoir peut-être plus précisément dans
quel but enfin vous proposez de réduire
les possibilités de maintien en présence
indu dans le dispositif national
d'accueil est-ce que vous avez chiffré
un petit peu le coût de ces présents du
merci beaucoup
merci les orateurs de groupe Xavier
roseren prenez soin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs je voudrais remercier à mon
tour les rapporteurs Stella Dupont et
Mathieu Lefebvre pour ce rapport de
qualité la politique d'orientation en
directive des demandeurs d'asile a été
mise en œuvre depuis 2021 et je me
félicite que cette politique publique
soit évaluée historiquement la région
Île-de-France concentrait à elle seule
une grande majorité des mains d'or
d'asile ce qui nuisait à la qualité de
l'accueil cette politique a été
équilibrée sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire les des demandeurs d'asile je
me juris je me réjouis que le bilan soit
globalement favorable et je partage
globalement les propositions qui sont
faites j'aurai deux interrogations la
première porte sur le taux de refus
d'orientation directive proposé aux
demandeurs d'asile 4 demandeurs d'asile
sur 10 refusent l'orientation directrice
qu'il aurait proposé
les rapporteurs mentionnent en deux ans
48 000 propositions d'orientation aux
demandeurs d'asile 12000 refus 36000
acceptations et 30400 on rejoint leur
lieu d'hébergement quelles sont les
raisons qui les poussent à refuser et
comment pourrait-on réduire ce refus et
ma seconde est sur l'intégration de ces
demandeurs d'asile dispose-t-on
d'éléments chiffrés qui permettraient de
comparer si l'intégration de ces
demeures d'asile en région est meilleur
qu'en Île-de-France merci merci Aymeric
salmon
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre une remarque et une question ma
remarque sera en réponse à Monsieur
Lefebvre sur ce qu'il a dit et qui
correspond à peu près à ça veut dire
monsieur le ministre en réponse à mon
collègue de Sidi tout à l'heure sur la
différence entre
demandeurs d'asile et clandestins alors
il y a un point sur lequel on veut
parler calmement pas de s'énerver mais
où on est clairement pas d'accord c'est
à dire que nous nous considérons que
quand quelqu'un franchit la frontière
illégalement
vous serez d'accord pour dire que tant
qu'il a pas rencontré une association il
a pas encore fait ça demande d'asile
donc tant qu'il a pas fait ça demande
d'asile il est illégal en France c'est
un point sur lequel on va pas être
d'accord je suis je reconnais bien
manqué mais et nous parce que nous nous
considérons que toute personne qui
rentre illégalement en France ne peut
plus faire de demande d'asile c'est
notre position je sais qu'on la partage
pas mais c'est notre position nous
pensons que les demandes d'asile doivent
être fait à l'étranger dans des
consulats dans les ambassades ou les
personnes demandant l'asile ou les
personnes devant l'asile et où les
demandes dans des piges voisins de la
Syrie ils peuvent faire la demande
d'asile dans les pays voisins de la
Syrie et ils peuvent être mis sous
protection de la France le temps de
l'analyse de leur dossier dans les pays
étrangers c'est notre position nous et
si ils ont l'asile charge à la France de
les rapatrier après en France avec des
moyens pour leur éviter d'avoir des
trajets compliqués à faire il y a pas de
souci pour ceux qui obtiennent le droit
d'asile vous voyez on n'est pas inhumain
non plus quand même
ensuite enfin j'ai non on n'est pas
inhumain ensuite une question qui va en
relation aussi à ce que dit Madame
Dupont tout à l'heure qu'il contestait
le chiffre qui a donné un de mes deux
collègues je me rappelle plus si c'est
monsieur carolier qui disait que 70 % de
la population est contre Madame Dupont a
dit oh non c'est pas vrai et ben moi ce
que je vous propose monsieur le ministre
c'est quand un centre d'accueil doit
être déployé dans une commune qu'une
consultation officielle légale un
référendum local soit organisé dans la
dans la dans la dans la commune même
Dupont sera très grande qu'elle pense
que ça sera positif et ben comme ça il y
aura plus de soucis le le la population
aura fait son choix et le peuple aura
parlé la démocratie aura parlé bon voilà
je vous remercie Perrine Goulet pour le
modem
du coup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre beaucoup de choses ont déjà
été dites de ce que nous voulions vous
interroger que ce soit par vous même ou
directement par par mes collègues
notamment roseren du coup moi j'aurais
une petite question plutôt en amont de
ce dispositif on a vu que avec la partie
asile
ukrainienne on a été capable d'accélérer
les demandes d'asile d'accélérer
également
tout un tas de papiers on a même eu
l'OFI qui a fait des performances
délocalisées dans certains territoires
pour accélérer ses demandes j'aimerais
savoir Monsieur le Ministre c'est dans
le cadre d'une meilleure prise en compte
de l'asile on pourrait peut-être
généraliser cette organisation que nous
avions mis en place sur l'Ukraine pour
offrir plus rapidement une réponse aux
demandeurs d'asile et en comme ça on
peut agir plus vite que soit positif ou
négatif je vous remercie Marie est à
Caraman libre socialiste
le président monsieur le ministre tout
d'abord je voulais aussi commencer par
remercier les deux rapporteurs à la fois
de l'analyse et à la fois de l'effort de
faire des propositions concrètes et
comme d'autres orateurs et collègues
tout à l'heure l'ombre l'ont exprimé moi
je voulais aussi insister sur deux les
deux questions par la première
proposition de question qui est
finalement concerne
la les orientations directives qui
permettent donc depuis janvier 2021 donc
le transfert déprimant primo demandeur
d'asile de l'Île-de-France vers la
province et ça se fait comme Madame
Dupont le disait avec
à la base d'un algorithme est-ce que
justement on peut pas travailler et la
proposition qui a été faite qui est très
concrète de travailler et d'améliorer
finalement la prise en compte des
attaches particulières finalement dans
la région pour pouvoir permettre la
l'intégration et l'accompagnement que ce
soit le plus affectif comment vous allez
donc finalement vous prendre pour pour
répondre à cette moyenne les personnes
et maintenir donc les liens utiles à
tous et ma deuxième question c'est par
rapport au programme qui est quel
programme on peut opérationnel vous
pouvez mettre en place pour résorber
justement et intégrer les différents
types d'hébergement qu'on a qu'on
connaît depuis maintenant plus de 10 ans
dans un parcours je dirais normé en
fonction justement de la situation de la
personne de demandeur de protection et
de ses besoins selon quelle logique
qu'on pourrait travailler là-dessus et
selon quel calendrier parce que comme il
vient d'être exprimé il y a peut-être
aussi des leçons à tirer de du
traitement d'un certain nombre de
situations comme les réfugiés Ukrainiens
pour les adapter à d'autres situations
qu'on ne connaissons dans notre pays
parce que c'est aussi de la richesse de
savoir reconnaître à travers les
personnes qui ont demandé l'asile que
l'ont obtenu et ça porte aussi un
potentiel également au pays et aux
besoins que nous avons aussi merci
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
d'abord pour répondre au monsieur député
du rassemblement
on sait pas qu'on c'est pas une opinion
en fait
c'est le droit alors après on peut
sortir à la fois la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme de
l'achat des droits fondamentaux de
l'Union européenne de la course de
constitution mais c'est un choix
politique la préambule de la
Constitution monsieur député prévoit une
phrase assez simple qui sous-tend notre
notre discussion et cette phrase simple
c'est celle que vous voudriez abroger
mais pourquoi pas
mais ça c'est quand même un principe
fondamental de notre droit
tout top persécuté en raison de son
action en faveur de la liberté à droit
d'asile soit territoire de la République
c'est-à-dire que on accepte
alors à droite d'asile sur le territoire
de la République mais sur le
territoire République c'est pas c'est
pas dans le consulat au Pakistan c'est
c'est ce territoire de la République on
a pas le droit de refuser l'excès au
territoire donc en ce sens monsieur le
député on peut y retourner
s'il vous plaît j'ai compris que vous
étiez pas d'accord mais c'est la règle
du jeu voilà c'est une ministre qui
répond merci sur le territoire de la
République c'est pas les emprises
consulaires sur le territoire de la
République c'est le territoire de la
République en France exagonale ou en
outre-mer donc la question qu'il faut
poser mais je la pose également aux
République j'ai lu la prose intéressante
dans le journal le weekend dernier c'est
que il faut donc sortir de la CEDH et il
faut donc modifier profondément une
Constitution pour que les dents d'asile
puissent faire il y a pas d'ailleurs des
pays comme si tu es jamais un exemple de
pays qui ont fait ce que vous dites
donc ça c'est intéressant mais ce qu'il
faut c'est dans City au moins un pays
démocratique qui accepte que l'Asie ne
savent pas sur son territoire donc les
gens viennent sur le territoire national
et disent qu'ils sont persécutés pour
des raisons nombreuses que nous
reconnaissons après notre problème c'est
pas tellement celui-là monsieur député
parce qu'après tous les bandits bon 120
000 130140000 on est d'accord ensemble
que ça peut être important mais par
rapport à 70 millions de Français bon la
question c'est ta caisse métier monsieur
la question se député c'est comment soit
on accepte son refuse dans quel délai on
le fait et comment on conduit les
personnes qui n'ont pas le droit dans
notre vie notre pays ça c'est une
question évidemment très importante mais
c'est je peux vous redire que c'est pas
une opinion savoir ces personnes est
illégales sur le territoriales c'est
juridiquement quelqu'un qui n'est pas
illégal sur le territoire national et je
pense qu'une fois qu'on aura admis ça
vous apercevrez que même en
responsabilité politique vous ne serez
pas autre chose que ce que nous faisons
parce que sinon vous sortez et vous
ferez ouvrir un triple frexit quoi frère
frexit d'acdh un frexit de la
Constitution et réussite de l'achat de
Nations Unies ce qui nous donne ce qui
nous passera un peu au banc des nations
évidemment vous ne le ferez pas
d'ailleurs vous avez beaucoup changé
d'avis déjà sur l'Europe alors vous
changerez évidemment sur ça au fur et à
mesure que vous apercevrez que ces
propositions sont complètement
irréalistes le deuxième sujet je veux
dire monsieur le Président de la
Commission que j'entends ce qu'il dit il
a parfaitement raison sur les constats
qu'il fait dans sa circonscription et
sur le territoire je le fais tous les
jours simplement si je peux pas que je
me présente vous vous confondez ou en
tout cas vous n'êtes pas alors je
comprends qu'il y a une unité du
gouvernement et je le prends comme tel
je comprends qu'une unité du
gouvernement que c'est une question plus
politique que budgétaire parce que là je
suis en train de défendre les crédit
budgétaire s'il y a des gens ne sont pas
régularisables et qui pour autant ne
sont pas expulsables ils sont pas dans
le DNA géré par Visa matériel moi je
gère les demandeurs d'asile si vous avez
un sujet de d'accompagnement des
personnes qui sont sans abri qui sont
pour autant sans titre de séjour ces
ministère de logement qu'il cherche donc
moi je suis dans je suis venu dans une
présente commission des finances je
parle de crédit de budgétaire de mon
ministère après qui est des sujets
évidemment pour les gens qui ont des qtf
sont pas expulsables et qui soit dans
des programmes budgétaires de logements
qui sont peut-être pas assez nombreux je
le compenserai bien mais ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas bavardi en revanche qui est
sûr c'est que entre 15 et 20% de gens
qui sont dans la DNA brancher les
vendeurs d'asile qui prennent la place
de vrai demandeur d'asile ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas les mettre ailleurs
ça veut dire qu'ils sont dans les places
que budgétairement nous discutons en ce
moment on reproche qu'on a passé alors
qu'il devrait pas l'être et on devrait
dire dans ces centres là de DNA monsieur
madame vous n'êtes pas demandeur d'asile
ou alors on a épuisé votre demande
d'asile on vous a dit non vous a dit oui
dans ces cas-là vous rentrez dans un
autre dispositif qui est géré par le
ministère du Logement par exemple et
c'est des normes problèmes du ministère
de l'intérieur c'est son programme
budgétaire il vient répondre aux
questions demandez-azil et aux autres
parce que d'autres ministères gèrent
pour plein de raisons difficiles
difficilement la situation donc vous
avez parfaitement raison après l'exemple
que vous prenez de parents qui seraient
français d'un enfant qui ne serait pas
dont les parents travaillaient et qui
seraient dans ce dispositif si les
parents travaillent et qu'ils sont
français et
[Musique]
par exemple les personnes qui déclarent
une orientation sexuelle comme
l'homosexualité ou le fait d'être
transgenre dans tous les pays droits
musulmans quasiment et une condamnation
pénale et à ce titre pourrait demander
l'Asie dans notre pays bon donc on voit
bien que les nationalités pour répondre
à Monsieur rapporteur général il a
raison de le constater que les gens sont
des nains et n'auront pas de à coup sûr
de demande d'asile sauf qu'ils se font
dans son on a dit sur d'autres sujets
que leur nationalité ils se fonde sur
d'autres sujets que nous devons
évidemment étudier pour lequel
évidemment parfois on accorde en accord
de l'asile quand j'y on c'est l'OFPRA
qui est un office indépendant et à la
fin la scène da qui est à juge
administratif présent moi je peux vous
rejoindre sur les centres d'accueil
digne de ce nom je pense que
noircissait un peu le tableau même si je
comprends qu'en Île-de-France et
singulièrement dans votre département
vous puissiez avoir cette impression et
ce constat ce que fait gouvernement
depuis des années 3 ans c'est de créer
c'est ça justement alors est-ce qu'ils
sont assez nombreux est-ce qu'ils sont
assez équipés attention également à à la
façon dont on peut accueillir ces
demandeurs d'asile qui sont parfois en
attente en effet d'un accompagnement
individualisé et d'autres fois il est
pas tout à fait impossible de le penser
sur 100% de leur asile qui cherche un
moyen détourner leur titre de séjour
dans notre pays c'est ça qui a
difficulté du ministère de l'Intérieur
bien évidemment mais je peux vous
rejoindre et rejoindre les propositions
des rapporteurs sur le fait que c'est ça
sont sans doute mieux à organiser sur la
question
évoquée d'éducation nationale je pense
que ce qui est intéressant monsieur le
rapporteur général
des enfants et notamment quand on fait
le schéma ou l'aménagement c'est un
mauvais mot territorial pour accueillir
les demandeurs d'asile je veux souligner
que voilà souvent la scolarisation est
un sujet très très important et
l'acceptabilité sociale et la
possibilité d'ailleurs d'inscrire ses
enfants à l'école et est un sujet très
très important avec les difficultés
extrêmement fortes parfois éducative
qu'on ces enfants qui ont subi des
traversées très lointaines des
difficultés avec beaucoup de sévices
sexuelles pour une partie des jeunes
filles qui nous rejoignent etc etc donc
je pense que du nationale qui a géré
ensuite les enfants c'est mieux s'ils
sont en amont du dispositif quand on
avale si c'est pas la peine de mettre
dans des territoires des endroits où la
scolarité pourra pas être bien suivi
parce qu'on n'a pas le la bonne
pédagogie le bon accompagnement
etc etc
sur le fait d'agir plus vite je vais
répondre à Madame caramoly et Madame et
Madame Goulet c'est bien sûr d'autres
problèmes principal je peux comprendre
l'affirmation du président Coquerel en
introduction tout à l'heure pour lui
dire il y a un problème d'accueil
personne n'a jamais dit qu'il y avait
pas de l'accueil il y a plusieurs
problèmes dans l'immigration que nous
connaissons il y a notamment un problème
une crise de l'accueil bon et cette
crise de l'accueil ça dépend comment on
regarde le verre si la moitié plein
aussi à moitié vide vous allez le dire
parce que vous avez même pas mis assez
de moyens je vais vous dire mais parce
qu'en fait on met trop de temps à donner
une réponse à quelqu'un et et cette
difficulté de se trop de temps il
handicap la personne qu'à l'asile quand
la personne qui ne l'aura pas il
handicap à personne qu'elle dit parce
que attendre un an un an et demi pour
voir valeur ses droits parfois plus
évidemment quand on peut pas travailler
quand on peut pas se projeter quand on a
peur de pays que qui nous entoure des
difficultés administratives c'est
évidemment très long et c'est
inacceptable de la part d'un motard
d'asile qui a le droit à cette Asie
constitutionnelle et conventionnelle et
c'est en même temps un handicap bien sûr
pour l'État comme pour la personne à qui
refuse parce qu'entre temps il a fait sa
vie en France peut-être il a fait un
enfant il a peut-être eu un juridique
qui avait quelqu'un il a scolarisé les
dix enfants il y a peut-être commencé
déjà à travailler chez les entreprises
qui lui ont donné un contrat au black
alors qu'il fallait pas le faire mais
enfin il commence lui à faire son
travail et il est exploiter et puis on
le met tout de suite dans un dispositif
qui consiste à dire que justement
parfois il devient Nick crystal ni
régularisable il peut pas l'avoir au
titre de l'Asie du titre de séjour on
peut pas expulser parce que le juge nous
dira mais cher ami ça fait trois ans
qu'il est là il a fait des enfants
pourquoi vous ne régularisez pas donc je
pense que la grande réponse c'est la
rapidité et autant l'OFPRA les
préfectures et leur prend en fait
d'énormes efforts grâce à leur moyen
budgétaire que vous lui avez accordé moi
je suis fier de dire que les questions
vont me poser dans un rapport budgétaire
c'est les questions de désormais de
l'aménagement des demandeurs d'asile
sont territoire national encore
aménagement est un mauvais mot mais
c'est plus des questions pourquoi le
problème neuf mois pour juger pour
inscrire dans le monde nazis ça c'était
il y a 3 ans aujourd'hui voilà en 5 mois
parfois beaucoup moins les demandes en
asile ont une réponse le problème c'est
la juridiction administrative et c'est
pas pour dire du mal de la CND en tant
que tel mais elle met toujours entre 9
mois et 12 mois pour répondre à l'appel
que peut faire
l'OFPRA ou que peut faire plus souvent
dans l'asile qui se voit des brouter sa
demande et quand on a une un an et demi
de demande évidemment ça pose un
problème d'accueil de personnes de
réponse donc je pense que tu es tout
l'objet du projet de loi que que nous
proposons à l'Assemblée au Sénat de
réduire ses délais non pas pour réduire
les droits des demandeurs d'asile à
faire des recours mais pour quand même
les enfermer me semble-t-il dans un
délai compatible avec le service public
et le capacité d'accueil parce que je
crains malheureusement que ses capacités
d'accueil elles peuvent être très très
très élargies parce que ben voilà comme
j'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois la
l'immigration n'est pas une opinion et
pour ou contre n'a pas beaucoup de sens
puisqu'il y aura quoi qu'il arrive des
vagues migratoires très importantes tout
à l'heure vos collègues du groupe
écologiste je crois évoquer les
migration climatiques c'est évidemment
un sujet qu'on aura dans les dans les
prochaines années donc oui cette
question du délai et était vraiment le
moment le plus important et je constate
puisque vous l'avez pas relevé que
l'OFPRA a fait les efforts tout à fait
considérables les conformes aux annonces
et aux engagements du Président de la
République pour terminer peut-être sur
la protection qu'on a accordé aux
Ukrainiens j'entends parfois le discours
qui est de dire bah voilà Ukrainiens
vous avez fait beaucoup d'efforts puis
vous passer pour pour les personnes non
ukrainiennes bon d'abord ça me paraît
une comparaison un peu un peu douteuse
d'abord je rappelle que nous avons
décidé tous les pays européens ensemble
de déclencher cette protection
temporaire qui a quand même beaucoup de
qualité que n'a pas la demande d'asile
classique un on donne pas l'asile tout
court donc quand les gens me disent il
faut donner à tous les autres ce que les
deux Ukrainiens moi personnellement je
peux dire chiche mais je suis pas sûr
que ça rentre beaucoup de services aux
personnes qui auraient cette ce bénéfice
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on dit aux
Ukrainiens vous n'aurez pas l'asile
vous n'aurez pas les yeux parce que
votre pays sera plus en guerre dans
quelques années vous avez trois ans de
protection et donc du coup bah voilà
vous n'avez pas l'asile et le droit
de jusqu'à la fin de votre vie de rester
dans notre pays mais c'est un CDD
finalement comme ça malheureusement
c'est un CDD donnait à certaines
personnes donc si c'est ce que vous
voulez aussi rien aux Afghans au
pakistanais
ça pas tellement la cause à mon avis de
ces personnes qui fuit les difficultés
de leur pays donc un la comparaison elle
n'est pas bonne pour les autres
nationalités deux on leur dit vous
pouvez travailler immédiatement c'est un
débat qu'on doit avoir est-ce que c'est
ce que souhaite moi quand on a évoqué ce
sujet il y a pas très longtemps je
comprends qu'il y a des gens qui veulent
pas que dedans ils travaillent faut
aussi qu'on soit tous cohérent soit on
fait comme les Ukrainiens ils peuvent
travailler immédiatement soit ils
peuvent pas travailler parce que en
attendant d'avoir leur réponse encore
faut-il qu'on soit rapide nous on pense
que certaines nationalités puissent
peuvent travailler comme les Afghans par
exemple qui sont à peu près certain
Docteur à l'asile pourraient travailler
avant même les 6 mois qui sont prévus
aujourd'hui par la loi bon c'est un
débat politique mais on peut pas
demander tout et le contraire puis
troisièmement je pense qu'on peut pas
comparer
ceux qui se passe pour les Ukrainiens
dont je rappelle que c'est 90% de femmes
avec beaucoup d'enfants avec peu de gens
qui sont sur le territoire national moi
200000 avec les personnes qui traversent
des océans qui n'ont absolument pas
parfois la même culture que nous qui
sont souvent malheureusement j'ai des
hommes parce que ça nuit à l'intégration
que les familles ne puissent pas
toujours être suivies ils arrivent
souvent dans un second temps et qui
évidemment ce compte plutôt en centaines
de milliers que moins de 100000
personnes comme comme les Ukrainiens qui
sont à 3 heures ou 4 heures de leur
propre frontières et parfois leur propre
famille donc je pense que la comparaison
me paraît me paraît me paraît difficile
merci
la parole rapporteur spéciaux
simplement pour
remercier les collègues monsieur le
ministre et peut-être
souligner votre ouverture sur
différentes recommandations que nous
formons et notamment sur l'hébergement
citoyen j'ai bien entendu votre intérêt
pour cette mesure
et
saluer effectivement la mobilisation de
tous les acteurs de l'OFPRA de la CNDA
malgré le fait qu'on voudrait que ça
aille encore plus vite et des agents des
préfectures malgré tout le chemin qui
reste à parcourir ce qu'on constate sur
le terrain et cette orientation directe
l'illustration c'est à dire que les
choses bougent les choses évoluent et
qu'on améliore une qualité d'accueil
même s'il y a encore beaucoup de chemin
à faire merci
j'interroge la commission de
l'application sur un point d'information
sur la thématique de violation du
rapport spécial il n'y a pas
d'opposition l'application du rapport
d'information est autorisé on va finir
sur les incendies
avec la dernière discussion consacrée à
l'évaluation l'adéquation des moyens de
service départementaux d'incendie de
secours à leur mission et au défi à
venir présenter par Florian chauche
rapporteur spécial la parole est à vous
chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues pour débuter je tiens à
remercier l'ensemble des personnes qui
m'ont accordé de leur temps lors des
auditions et visites que j'ai menées
dans le cadre de ce rapport d'évaluation
pour mener ce travail j'ai pu m'appuyer
sur le rapport de l'Inspection générale
de l'administration d'octobre 2022 et
l'audition de ces auteurs ce document
présente l'avantage d'analyser sur un
temps long l'évolution des dépenses des
10 de leurs interventions ainsi que leur
mode de financement j'ai bien évidemment
rencontré les organisations syndicales
des 10 dont je tiens à saluer
l'engagement et que je remercie pour la
qualité des échanges ainsi que leurs
francs parlé je remercie les préfets du
Var et les Vosges qui ont pars qui ont
partagé avec moi leur expérience en
matière de gestion de crise la
comparaison entre deux départements
inégalement confrontés à des incendies
étaient intéressantes puisqu'il était
question du financement des 10 et de son
adéquation au changement climatique j'ai
auditionné des chercheurs de l'Institut
de l'économie pour le climat premier
financeur des 10 il était impensable
pour moi d'écouter les propositions de
l'Assemblée des départements de France
il est indispensable pardon les
départements de France et l'Association
des maires de France je tiens à
remercier aussi la direction générale de
la sécurité civile et de la gestion de
crise ainsi que les personnels et les
représentants syndicaux de la base
aérienne de la sécurité civile de Nîmes
que j'ai eu la chance de visiter et qui
a été particulièrement instructive je
souhaite aussi avoir un mot pour les
personnels de lensops et de l'Entente
valable que j'ai visité et où j'ai pu
mesurer le professionnalisme et le degré
de compétences de nos forces de sécurité
civiles
la France dispose d'un pot d'un pôle
d'excellence que beaucoup de pays nous
envient en matière de formation et de
préparation aux incendies à la gestion
de crise je clôt donc ces remerciements
et j'aimerais maintenant vous dire
pourquoi j'ai retenu ce thème spécifique
j'ai été frappé lors de l'examen de
projet de loi de finance de voir à quel
point la sécurité civile était un sujet
transpartisant tous les groupes
politiques avaient ainsi déposé des
amendements au PLF sur l'exonération de
malus écologique et le tarif réduit de
TICPE de nombreux de nombreux groupes
pardon avait également déposé des
amendements pour faire évoluer la
fraction de taxes spéciales sur les
conventions d'assurance dédiée au
financement des 10
nous sommes nombreux sur ces bancs à
vouloir agir pour offrir à nos 10 des
moyens supplémentaires et je regrette
que le gouvernement ait usé à répétition
du 49-3 pour l'examen du projet de loi
de finance je crois sincèrement qu'un
débat et des accords étaient possibles
et qu'ils le sont toujours nous l'avons
d'ailleurs observé la semaine dernière
lors de l'examen de la proposition de
loi de lutte contre les risques incendie
où nous avons voté à la quasi unanimité
pour l'exonération de malus écologique
pour nos 10 et un tarif réduit de TICPE
ainsi que pour rejeter les amendements
de suppression de coût du gouvernement
sur ces sujets puisque nous n'avons pas
pu débattre dans le cadre du PLF du
financement de nos 10 je vous propose
donc de le faire ici
nous avons aujourd'hui un modèle qui
fait face à deux problèmes majeurs d'une
part une sur sollicitation de nos
sapeurs-pompiers dans le domaine
sanitaire et d'autre part le défi
climatique qui va induire une forte
augmentation des crises et de leur
intensité pour lequel nous sommes
insuffisamment préparés entre 2002 et
2021 le nombre total d'interventions
réalisé par nos sapeurs-pompiers et
passer de 3,6 millions à 4,7 millions
parmi les différentes interventions
réalisées par nos sopper pompiers seuls
les interventions de secours aux
personnes ont augmenté et représentent
aujourd'hui plus de 80% d'intervention
ceci n'est pas sans conséquence puisque
les 10 ont logiquement priorisé des
investissements vers les véhicules de
secours et d'assistance aux victimes au
détriment des véhicules d'intervention
et de lutte contre les incendies comme
les CCF
surtout près de 20% des interventions de
noce 10 ne révèle pas ne relève pas
aujourd'hui de leur mission on parle ici
des fameuses carences ambulancières ou
des activités dites à la personne
cela pose plusieurs problèmes financier
tout d'abord puisque l'indemnisation des
carences ambulancières ne couvre pas le
coût réel de l'intervention et que le
nombre de carences ademnisés est encore
trop faible opérationnel ensuite je suis
certain que vous avez déjà toutes déjà
été alerté par des pompiers de votre
disque qui vous rapportent avoir attendu
plusieurs heures une prise en charge
dans un hôpital ceci n'est pas
acceptable cela conduit enfin à la perte
de sens pour de nombreux
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires ou
professionnels difficultés dans le
recrutement et démission de
professionnels qui ne se retrouvent plus
dans leur métier ce qui est inédit on
constate également des durées
d'engagement plus courtes au niveau des
volontaires et une moindre attractivité
soit dit en passant les exonérations de
cotisations patronales n'y changeront
rien si vous souhaitez recruter comme
vous l'avez déclaré monsieur le ministre
25 000 sapeurs-pompiers supplémentaires
il va falloir prendre des mesures pour
les pour les recentrer sur leur cœur de
mission et ainsi redonner du sens à leur
engagement
il convient donc d'agir en la matière la
loi matras a permis des avancées mais
vous devez monsieur le ministre
poursuivre le travail avec le ministère
de la Santé sur cette problématique pour
ce qui est du changement climatique et
ses conséquences pour nos forces de
sécurité civile je ne vais pas revenir
ici dans le détail je crois que les
événements récents sont une bonne
illustration on voit bien à quel point
le risque s'est étendu géographiquement
et cette intensifié les épisodes de
grêle l'été dernier et dit Dona et
d'inondation en ce moment dans l'Allier
témoigne également de l'accroissement
des événements climatiques extrêmes
auxquels nous devons nous préparer or
force est de constater que nous ne
sommes pas prêts à faire face aux
conséquences du changement climatique
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les
camions-citernes feux de forêt outils de
base contre la lutte dans outils de base
dans la lutte contre les incendies leur
nombre à diminué de
5117 en 2002 à 3143 en 2020 on a donc
moins de matériel et en moins bon état
puisque le taux de vétusté du matériel
mobile d'incendie est passé de 51% en
2011 à 61% en 2021
cette mise en place des pactes capacités
et bienvenue et je la salue mais ne
permettra pas de rattraper le retard
accumulé le coût de ces gens de ses
engins a par ailleurs explosé et il faut
aujourd'hui compter deux ans entre la
commande et la livraison nous se disent
vont devoir procéder à des efforts
d'investissement énorme et les formes
sera pas réparties équitablement car 40%
du parc national des véhicules CCF est
regroupés dans seulement 16 départements
vous l'aurez compris je crois
profondément et c'est le fruit de mes
échanges avec les acteurs de la sécurité
civile que nous devons augmenter
significativement les moyens à louer à
nos 10
voici donc mes propositions relatives au
financement des 10 pour ce qui est de la
taxe spéciale sur les conventions
d'assurance la TSCA je crois qu'il
convient d'en augmenter le taux pour
dégager des moyens supplémentaires aux
10 afin de ne pas faire peser cette
hausse indistinctement sur l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens je pense qu'il serait
judicieux de moduler le taux en fonction
du coût d'achat des véhicules vous avez
évoqué par le passé monsieur le ministre
la mise en oeuvre d'un mécanisme de
péréquation ne pourrait-on pas envisager
de dédier une partie de l'augmentation
de la TCA un fond de solidarité et
d'investissement au profit de nos 10 les
moins bien dotés
surtout nous avons un problème de
lisibilité sur cette ressource les 10
pensent que les départements ne la
reversent pas indiqua intégralement il y
a une opacité une difficulté d'accès à
l'information qu'il faut solutionner
pour cesser d'alimenter les fantasmes
en matière de contribution des communes
qui sont plafonnées à l'évolution de
l'inflation on observe des situations
problématiques comme en Gironde ou la
population a fortement augmenté ce qui a
conduit un accroissement des
interventions du 10 à moyen constant je
sais les difficultés financières
auxquelles les communes sont confrontées
et mon propos n'est pas ici de dire que
les communes ne contribuent pas assez
financièrement je pense néanmoins qu'il
serait intéressant d'augmenter le taux
plafond de la taxe de séjour sur les
hébergements luxueux toujours avec
l'idée de faire contribuer ce qui en ont
les moyens et qui par ailleurs
participent le plus fortement au champ
haut au changement climatique
ceci a fait le permettre aux communes
qui le souhaitent de dégager des moyens
supplémentaires pour le financement des
10 enfin le rapport de l'IGA alerté
notamment sur le fait que les ressources
de financement actuel des 10 soit sans
lien direct avec l'activité des
sapeurs-pompiers les pompiers le
réclament depuis longtemps je crois
qu'il est temps de réfléchir à une
contribution directe de la part des
compagnies d'assurances ces dernières en
ont les moyens elle réalise des
bénéfices importants qui sont en partie
permis par l'action des sapeurs-pompiers
et qui protège les personnes et les
biens je vous remercie pour votre
attention merci
à vous monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur merci pour votre rapport et
votre proposition je vous retrouve dans
beaucoup de choses de ce que vous avez
dit peut-être d'abord une remarque sur
votre longue introduction sur les
missions finalement que font les
sapeurs-pompiers qui n'est pas leur
coeur de mission qui les décourage qui
décourage les 10 qui prennent évidemment
beaucoup d'argent de leur fonctionnement
alors que le meilleur organisations des
systèmes de soins et d'ailleurs générale
des personnes qui sont âgées parce que
il s'agit aussi de beaucoup de personnes
âgées que vous évoquez pour être réglé
autrement moi je partage évidemment
votre votre constat c'est le constat que
font tous les sapeurs-pompiers et tous
les patrons de 10 de France je voudrais
quand même constater la légère léger
paradoxe que le département et la
collectivité qui gère les 10 mais qui
gère aussi la politique de l'âge et du
handicap et que moi je constate dans mon
département du Nord par exemple beaucoup
[Musique]
un agent du conseil départemental mais
pourquoi pas d'autres opérateurs je veux
que le groupe La Poste le proposait
parfois aux élus qui puisse venir pour
vérifier au moins faire la levée de
doute avant d'appeler sapeur-pompiers ça
évite d'engager un véhicule avec quatre
sapeur-pompiers qui en effet ramasser la
télécommande de la vieille dame donc
vous avez parfaitement raison sur le
constat je vais pas me remarquer que la
même connectivité gère deux politiques
publiques qui manifestement parfois sont
en opposition et je pense que c'est un
sujet que devrait régler avec l'État les
départements le deuxième sujet c'est le
manque d'offre de soins finalement le
manque de médecin de de praticien
quel qu'il soit et donc que les pompiers
viennent compenser c'est évidemment un
problème énorme celui des déserts
médicaux c'est sûr que les pompiers bah
aujourd'hui sont ceux qui compensent un
peu la rustine si je veux dire du manque
de médecins ça pose d'autres problèmes
que notamment l'implantation des
médecins dans les zones rurales ou dans
les zones
urbaines très touchées socialement qui
sont aussi des arts médicaux par
certains points de vue donc la
[Musique]
pourrait très bien faire le travail
qu'aujourd'hui ils font les
sapeurs-pompiers et que finalement entre
ça pendant les médecins il n'y a pas
d'intermédiaire alors qu'on sait tous
qu'il y a des réseaux d'infirmières
libérales de puéricultrice de
pharmaciens on l'a vu pour le covid
capable de faire les gestes médicaux
qu'on demande aujourd'hui aux pompiers
qui par ailleurs sont très encadrés dans
un décret alors qu'on sait tous que sur
le terrain c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe donc moi je partage votre constat
qui évoque le fait que sapeurs en très
grande partie font désormais un métier
qui ne correspond pas à celui sur lequel
ils sont engagés des moyens qui du coup
sont pour le secours à la personne pour
pallier d'autres dispositifs publics et
surtout qui décourage dans vocation
parce que c'est pas ce qu'ils avaient
prévu quand ils se sont engagés
évidemment dans dans la carrière
volontaire ou professionnelle donc oui
oui travaillons avec les départements
pour qu'ils soient cohérent dans leur
politique du grand âge du handicap oui
pour que ministère de la Santé fasse ce
travail il est en train de le faire et
oui pour que nous organisons mieux en
effet pour vous renvoyer des pompiers
dans les dans les interventions dignes
de leur section soit la partie feux de
forêt
je partage pas pas tout à fait même si
je peux comprendre le constat tout à
fait d'abord le
les conséquences de ce qu'on a vu l'été
dernier moi je voulais quand me rappeler
que 90% des feux de forêt c'est d'abord
un feu qui était provoqué par l'homme
soit parce que il l'a fait
volontairement soit parce qu'il a fait à
volontairement souvent parce qu'il l'a
fait involontairement et c'est notre
comportement général qui qui est
concerné quand on s'arrête au bord de la
route et qu'on fume sa cigarette quand
on est tapas au barbecue voilà ça c'est
un premier pas il y a beaucoup de
pyromades vous savez par ailleurs donc
d'abord c'est pas tout à fait vrai de
dire que l'augmentation des feux de
forêt c'est une augmentation qui n'est
que du réchauffement climatique il
accélère le comportement c'est-à-dire
que quand vous avez un taux
d'hydrométrie à moins de 10% c'est sûr
que quand vous achetez votre bingo de
cigarette ça prend plus feu que lorsque
il y a pas de sécheresse c'est tout à
fait certain mais le comportement humain
dans le cas des feux de forêts et en
très grande partie responsable de ce qui
se passe et deuxièmement deuxième c'est
pas très complexe à retenir 90% c'est
les humains et 90% c'est les prix les
forêts privés ce qui s'est passé dans
les Landes et en Gironde de sa vie à
Monsieur le Député c'est pas une forêt
public c'est une forêt qui était privée
qui était mal entretenue et pour lequel
il y avait des gens qui à l'intérieur de
cette forêt organisé une forme
coutumière de récupération notamment de
sève mais aussi l'installation de
caravanes qui n'aurait pas dû être là
parce que il y a pas eu de gestion et
parfois les gens se sont reposés à la
gestion de cette forêt il faudrait ça se
gère on coupe du bois on rentre dans
cette forêt les chasseurs le savent à
tous les professionnels de la nature le
savent quel qu'il soit leurs opinions
politiques et 90% des feux de forêts de
l'été dernier c'est des forêts privées
c'est pas des forêts publics donc je
pense que oui oui bien sûr on peut
rajouter des moyens il faut le faire on
peut racheter des avions on va le faire
et on doit augmenter l'impact capacité
sans doute faut-il augmenter la tête la
TSCA oui au fond de par équation moi je
pense que vous avez parfaitement raison
c'est une très bonne une très bonne
chose
j'ai constaté pour me rendre sur les
feux de forêt à chaque fois que des gens
me disent mais moi je suis pompier je
serais venu plutôt si mon emploi dire
m'avait libéré et quand je dis mais je
vais appeler mon employeur il me dit
mais c'est le 10 du département d'à côté
où c'est la commune machin donc avant
même d'avoir de dire au privé de le
faire il faut qu'il le fasse nous-même
employeur public et parfois le propre
ministère de l'Intérieur ne libérons pas
c'est sans doute nos personnels qui sont
ça par pompiers donc la première
vocation c'est celle-ci deuxième
vocation c'est sans doute une un statut
du sapeur-pompier qui doit se qui doit
être plus ou moins en lien avec le
statut qui a par exemple les lieux
municipal dont l'employeur n'a pas à
disposition de savoir si vous libère ou
pas son employé mais doit le libérer en
cas d'obligation par exemple conseil
municipal pour un municipal imaginons en
situation de crise même si il y a des
choses à redire sur l'employeur sur le
conseil municipal association de crise
par exemple sur lequel on devrait
appeler les sapeurs-pompiers j'aurais
quand même terminé monsieur député pour
vous dire qu'il y a aussi dans la
gestion des 10 des améliorations je
prends exemple du 10 Gironde quand nous
sommes arrivés en avec le directeur
général de la Sécurité civile après
plusieurs jours de feux de forêt seuls
6% des effectifs du 10 Gironde était
mobilisés alors il y a d'autres raisons
pour lesquelles ils sont pas
en vacances il y avait des gens qui
étaient sur d'autres interventions enfin
6% c'est très bas et il a fallu qu'on
appelle d'abord des colonnes de renfort
je me rappelle qui venaient de Bretagne
ou qui venaient du Nord de la France
pour venir en Gironde qui perdait du
temps ça coûte cher à tout le monde
alors que le plus simple était sans
doute de mobiliser les pompiers qui sont
issus de la Gironde alors je sais que le
président la Grèce pour le coup le sait
très bien on y travaille c'est complexe
mais il y a dans le mécanisme des 10
sans doute à améliorer d'abord comment
on mobilise nos propres s'appeler dans
chacun des départements ça ça coûte pas
cher puisque c'est déjà le cas et on
voit bien que c'est ce qui nous manque
quand on a moins de 10% effectivement
tu as des feux gigantesques il y a un
truc qui va pas dans notre
fonctionnement je sais que nous y
travaillons collectivement avec les
départements de France en tout cas moi
je vous invite suivi votre rapport et
vos propositions à y travailler avec
nous sur le même d'accord merci Monsieur
meunier juste une petite réflexion de ma
part je suis un petit peu inquiet sur ce
que vous avez dit en termes de
minorisation des risques parce que j'ai
suivi vous dites en gros
90% des des feux sont dus à des
personnes
et puis le reste c'est du par exemple à
la gestion privée des forêts et des
problématiques de forêt
ce qui laisserait supposer que ces
critères-là sont plus importants que le
critère du réchauffement de la
sécheresse sauf que sauf que le problème
c'est que
ce que provoque la sécheresse est-ce que
provoque le le
réchauffement c'est que maintenant c'est
danger là s'étendent à beaucoup plus de
régions de France qui autrefois ne pour
des raisons qui étaient climatiques
n'étaient pas justement susceptible de
s'enflammer entre guillemets et que des
régions comme le Maine-et-Loire
commencent à connaître des feux
importants dans le sens de la France des
feux importants qu'on pense même qu'il y
ait maintenant des risques en Bretagne
et autres on voit bien que là on est
face à un problème alors vous pourrez me
dire bah il faut éviter que l'homme mais
oui d'accord mais sauf que ça ça va pas
se faire ça
cette situation là elle est elle a
existé quand il y avait je sais pas
combien de départements concernés par
des risques de feu parce que ils étaient
dans des climats méditerranéens et
autres à partir du moment où ça devient
sur tout le territoire on est face à un
autre problème et c'est ce qui explique
aussi en partie que alors que la France
était un pays où chaque été on allait
aider des pays européens cette fois-ci
il a fallu demander l'aide de pays
européens pour venir nous aider donc je
crois que
malheureusement il faut préparer le fait
que ça ça va se renouveler on peut vous
avez raison on peut d'ailleurs ça coûte
de l'argent aussi travailler sur la
gestion des forêts on peut travailler
sur les gestion de sécurité etc mais
n'empêche on fera pas l'économie du fait
que année après année dans les années à
venir ça va être de plus étendu et qu'on
aura un problème parce que là vous
parlez d'escadron qui de colonne pardon
qui viennent de Bretagne mais le jour où
il y aura même plus de colonnes qui
pourra venir de Bretagne parce qu'en
Bretagne on aura des incendies et ça
malheureusement si on pense que ça va
pas arriver on se trompe donc je je
permettais de vous alerter là-dessus et
je me demandais d'ailleurs si au niveau
interministériel parce que c'est pas
seulement votre mystère je m'étais
demandé ça des discussions du PLF l'an
dernier s'il y avait eu un travail
d'estimation de coût global de ce qui
avait coûté
l'été 2022 du fait des conditions
climatiques
qu'on a connues j'allais dire de manière
transversale j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure les tempêtes les feux etc parce
que du coup ça nous donnerait un peu une
idée ce qui va faire mobiliser pour les
années à venir sur rapporteur
je suis très mal exprimé
soit vous n'avez pas compris ce que j'ai
essayé d'expliquer c'est que je ne
m'ignore pas le réchauffement climatique
je dis que c'est un accélérateur je le
dis moi-même dans mon introduction donc
le présenter comme vous l'avez faite
n'était pas conforme me semble-t-il j'ai
dit que 90% des feux ça c'est un fait et
chacun est responsable de la situation
des feux chacun est citoyen 90% des feux
sont d'origine humaine ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'avec le réchauffement
climatique le feu prend plus et là où le
jeu de mégot hier prenait pas toujours
désormais il prend quasiment
systématiquement si je devais
caricaturer plus c'est ailleurs alors le
deuxième sujet si je peux me permettre
c'est pas tout à fait le cas monsieur le
Président la difficulté de la Bretagne
du Maine-et-Loire du Jura au des Vosges
ce qui s'est passé cet été puisque 50%
des feux étaient au nord de la Loire
c'était que les moyens des 10 mais je
pense que c'est ce que vous avez en
partie dit Monsieur le Député rapporte
tout à l'heure n'était pas conditionné
au feu de forêt dans le Jura il y a pas
de moyen d'éteindre le feu de forêt donc
évidemment il n'y a pas plus de de
difficultés particulières sur tel ou tel
département ça peut on les dit ce sont
pas équipés à gérer les feux de forêts
ce que faisaient des ises du contour
méditerranéen et et c'est prise de
constat ça a moyen de pacte capacités
puisque on constate malheureusement que
dans les feux d'été une fois n'est pas
coutume sur l'année 2022 on verra bien
ce qui se passera dans les années qui
viennent mais c'est le vent qui est lié
à la sécheresse et le plus grand ennemi
du pompier c'est pas tellement la
sécheresse même si évidemment c'est un
accélérateur de feu que le vent et notre
sujet principal c'est notre absence de
météo et de supercalculateurs
contrairement à d'autres pays européens
qui sont capables de nous prédisposés
les moyens aériens pour lutter contre le
vent à pied parce que là les bateaux les
avions ne savent pas grand-chose dans
ces conditions là alors que d'autres
pays européens arrivent plus
certainement à faire les alertes ce que
désormais possible cette année grâce à
Météo France mais là vous êtes
parfaitement raison si je peux pas
monsieur le Président c'est qu'on voit
bien que la lutte contre les incendies
ou contre les calamités climatiques
venant de la réchauffement climatique
c'est très interministériel c'est à la
fois du curatif ce que nous faisons et
du préventif ce que fait mis ça
d'écologie mais je voulais vous dire que
non je ne minimise pas c'est un
accélérateur mais n'oublions pas que
quand même ne feux sur 10 c'est l'homme
qui l'a provoqué
merci beaucoup moi j'ai bien compris
monsieur
le remercier le rapporteur pour
son rapport dont je partage un majorité
des constats merci aussi d'avoir mis en
valeur le rôle important de des
apports-pompiers qui sont des acteurs
évidemment indispensables de nos de nos
territoires peut-être parce que il
serait que ce sujet a été débattu il y a
quelques jours dans les mystiques
réaffirmer le soutien de l'État des
victimes
os10 à hauteur de 1,5 milliards à peu
près un quart de leur financement alors
que je vous rappelle c'est quand même
une compétence des départements et dire
que nous avons voté dans le cas du PLF
2023 une hausse historique du pack
capacitaire 250 millions d'euros voilà
qui réaffirment notre soutien mérité aux
sapeurs aux sapeurs-pompiers c'est vrai
que les départements c'est normal assume
la plus grande partie de la hausse des
dépenses existent depuis 2003 il faut
aussi noter que sur le rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration d'octobre 2022 que vous
citez on observe une légère baisse de la
contribution nette depuis 2016 en tous
les cas c'est assez stable de questions
vous évoquez d'expertise particulière
donc voilà est-ce que de votre point de
vue cette expertise peut servir à
d'autres départements et comment
organiser ce transfert de compétences
deuxièmement vous en matière de
financement vous
évoquez une contribution supplémentaire
des compagnies d'assurance est-ce que
vous avez interrogé ces compagnies
d'assurance pour savoir si elle ne
répercuterait pas sur les primes
d'assurance merci merci quelqu'un pour
Renaissance
monsieur le Président Monsieur général
monsieur le ministre vous avez souligné
la croissance du risque de feu de forêt
qui frappe désormais successivement les
États membres de l'Union européenne en
France le président de la République a
annoncé le 28 octobre dernier le
rapporteur
les représentants des forces vives
mobilisées lors de la campagne de feu de
2022 à une stratégie nouvelle qui
consiste essentiellement on a vaste plan
de aérien porté à 250 millions c'est
investissement dans 150 millions
supplémentaires à destination des
services départementaux d'incendie et de
secours les principales annonces portent
en trois volets premièrement un point de
soutien volontariat on se souvient des
initiatives prises par certaines grandes
entreprises lors des feux de Gironde
l'an dernier et vous avez monsieur le
ministre et Monique votre réel ambition
pour les sapeurs pompiers volontaires
lors de votre venue au Congrès des
sapeurs-pompiers à Nancy nous avions eu
l'honneur de vous recevoir en octobre
dernier le plan qui serait mis en place
est destiné à longer la durée pendant
laquelle les entreprises pourront
libérer les les pompiers volontaire en
les indemnisant mieux vous avez commencé
à en parler à l'instant deuxièmement le
nombre de colonnes de renforts sera
doublé le rapport que nous examinons
rappelle que 44 colonnes ont été
mobilisées en 2022 soit 20 plus que les
années antérieures
troisièmement la France procédera au
renouvellement de sa flotte actuelle de
12 Canadair à l'achat de 4 Canadair
supplémentaires d'ici 2027 et ce qui
portera leur nombre à 16 d'ici la fin du
quinquennat ainsi qu'à l'acquisition de
deux hélicoptères lourds supplémentaires
de dès 2023 alors comme le rapporteur
général le groupe Renaissance salut
évidemment c'est impulsion décisive vous
venez témoigné de votre engagement sur
ce sujet de nouveau monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur la
commission des finances sur la mise en
oeuvre et notamment le rythme de ces de
mise en oeuvre de ces importantes
annonces le présidentielles
il faut éteindre votre micro
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais revenir sur le sujet
des incendies de forêts et la discussion
intéressante que vous venez d'avoir avec
monsieur le Président une fois n'est pas
coutume vous faites d'accord avec vous
monsieur le ministre sur le les 90% de
cause humaine et là je vais être en
désaccord avec Monsieur le rapport je
pense qu'on aura plus de facilité à
l'avenir à éduquer à
sanctionner parfois les les fautifs de
humains des feux de forêts
je ne dis pas le réchauffement
climatique je dis pas il faut faire des
efforts mais je pense que on n'ira plus
vite dans l'éducation notamment je pense
sur les négligences parce que les alors
je connais pas le pourcentage entre les
négligences et les pyromanes mais je
pense que sur les négligences avec des
menaces de sanctions et de la
communication autour de de ce sujet je
pense qu'on peut réussir à faire baisser
notamment moi en Haute-Saône il y a eu
aussi un feu de forêt l'année dernière
alors qu'avant il y avait pas parce que
effectivement probablement
l'exemple que vous deviez monsieur
béniste le le Bégou jeté effectivement
avant ça n'avait pas d'incidence
aujourd'hui partout en France le Vego a
une incidence mais peut-être faut-il
communiquer et menacé de sanction les
fauteurs de les auteurs de ces de ses
actes de négligence pour pour pouvoir
diminuer le nombre de nationalités
merci qui du MoDem ce qui a toujours le
choix même tard dans le modem je dis ça
parce que c'est exemplaire
une question une heure 23 voilà pour
ceux qui nous regardent encore
concernant notre flotte d'hélicoptère on
a vu qu'on est un peu en souffrance sur
la flotte d'hélico sur la sécurité
civile avec la Cour des comptes qui
pointe un risque sur le marché de
maintenance en condition opérationnelle
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
un mot si c'est possible sur l'avancée
de ce dossier et puis on a évoqué
rapidement le financement des 10 vous
êtes revenu assez longuement sur la TSCA
qui allait faire l'objet d'une question
je vous en remercie par contre avec
votre ancien ministre du Budget
également qu'est-ce que vous penseriez
d'une potentielle remise à plat de la
contribution du bloc communal qui avait
été évoquée donc par le rapporteur qui
me semble être une piste intéressante je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
sur la question du financement je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il faille demander aux
communes davantage de moyens parce que
d'abord c'est souvent les communes les
plus petites qui contribuent en
proportion avec des moyens très limités
je suis pas sûr que ce soit la réponse
au milieu par contre on pourrait
imaginer que les intercommunalités qui
ont davantage de recettes soit au
rendez-vous c'est le cas notamment dans
les métropoles qui ont une partie des
compétences 10 et pourquoi pas des
régions les régions gèrent le tourisme
le développement économique les
conséquences du tourisme et du
développement économique pour les
langues pour la Gironde de des feux
d'été dernier c'est évidemment
désastreux c'est aussi le cas
d'aménagement du territoire pour pour la
Gironde et puis s'occupe pour les
régions et c'est bien sûr parfois des
plans de transition écologique très
important si on fait le lien évident
entre le chauffant climatique qui est
difficulté de sécurité civile voilà je
crois je salue le président de la Région
nouvelle Aquitaine qui dit moi je suis
prêt à contribué à des transitions
fortes qui relèvent de compétences
régionales en plus tout à fait
l'imaginer on a souvent d'ailleurs vous
savez des feux qui sont par exemple
déclenchés le long des lignes TER
pourquoi elles sont déclenchées dans des
vignes TER parce que c'est exactement le
manque de débroussaillage et la vétusté
parfois avec la chaleur tout ça combiné
on fait que nous avons plusieurs feux
l'été dernier du fait des passages de
train de fret ou des passages
extraterrestres donc ils peuvent avoir
des compétences aussi régionales moi je
pense que plutôt d'aller taxer nouvelle
fois les communes plus modestes on
pourrait chercher dans la terre
communalité on va chercher à la région
pourquoi pas sur la base de volontariat
pour les régions je suis sûr que
beaucoup ne souhaiteraient avancés une
contribution sur ce sujet sur la
question finalement de la flotte Air
gagne plusieurs questions qui ont été
posées y compris par vous monsieur
rapporteur j'y ai pas répondu j'en suis
désolé on a on a trois problèmes on a
près de vétusté de la part de nos
appareils on apprend du nombre de nos
appareils et on a un problème de
production de ces appareils sur la
vétusté ce que nous faisons c'est nous
renouvelons la flotte notamment la
flotte vous l'avez le même souligné je
pense évidemment au 36 hélicoptère que
nous commandons à Airbus nouvelle
formule si j'ose dire et qui seront
opérationnels dès 2024 puisque
évidemment les risques sont très
importants les capacités d'ailleurs de
bombardements d'eau de surveillance
augmente avec le temps donc oui c'est un
renouvellement de flotte mais ça donne
beaucoup de sécurité à ceux qui interdit
dans des conditions très difficiles
quand on sait que le vent et des
difficultés les plus les plus
importantes et ça élargit si je veux
dire le largage possible sur la question
des avions donc il y a deux types
d'avions comme vous le savez il y a des
avions de reconnaissance qui peuvent
d'ailleurs pour une partie d'entre eux
avoir du retardant qui est une forme
d'action en Australie on a vu aux
États-Unis des gros avions qui favorent
reconnaissances et largage de retardant
c'est-à-dire poser la question de savoir
s'il fallait que nous fassions pareil et
puis il y a le largage classique type
Canadair sur la reconnaissance on est en
train de travailler avec plusieurs
sociétés
transports aériens de production d'avion
assez connu mais je
avec elle pour savoir si on peut pas
utiliser des avions qui aujourd'hui ne
font pas de la sécurité civile pour en
faire et notamment notre sujet des
patins le largage d'eau que reconnaître
très vite le feu vous avez moins besoin
d'eau quand vous avez reconnu très vite
le feu vous avez beaucoup plus besoin
d'eau quand vous avez pas reconnu très
vite le feu et donc il y a la question
des drones aussi on peut remplacer une
partie de notre flotte aérienne par les
drones militaires nous les liens que
nous avons avec Héphaïstos deuxième
formule parce que c'est drone notamment
les drones nocturnes parce que ces
avions et ces hélicoptères ne peuvent
pas voler la nuit nous permet de repérer
l'intensité du feu et comment on peut
intervenir et à quel endroit on doit
intervenir exactement donc il y a la
reconnaissance et qui ne compte pas
simplement en nombre d'appareils mais
qui est un appareil plus rapide plus
efficace plus moderne plus technologique
et pourquoi pas les drones et puis après
il y a le largage la difficulté que nous
avons de la gage encore une fois c'est
qu'il faut produire l'usine qui produit
des canadaires donc c'est notre
difficulté et c'est les difficultés de
tous les pays européens donc oui vous
avez raison il y en a donc un nombre de
canadaires limité pendant un certain
temps mais il est prévu l'argent pour
vous l'avez voté dans la dans la loterie
pour pouvoir mettre en avant ces
constructions de nouveau de nouveaux
avions il y a une usine qui est capable
de faire ça au niveau européen qui a été
lancé c'est à d'autres pays sont
capables de produire des canadaires
enfin les types de Canada avant nous les
achèterons évidemment bien volontiers
alors oui vous avez raison par ailleurs
pendant cela on loupe et on notamment
des hélicoptères bon mais en même temps
moi ça me choque pas beaucoup parce que
vous dites c'est un coup important mais
c'est un coup on paye pas là maintenant
si on échange de ce coup donc le coût
complet de l'été dernier je fais on l'a
pas fait mais je pense qu'il n'est pas
très différent de si on avait acheté un
hélicoptère et qu'on avait fait la
maintenance parce que la difficulté
maintenant c'est pas une difficulté
simplement de techniciens vous avez vous
me dit que les postes et budgétisés et
qu'ils étaient pas toujours pourvu c'est
que dans un monde concurrentiel de
sécurité privée quelqu'un qui est payé
au prix de la fonction publique c'est
quelqu'un qui maintient un hélicoptère
par exemple en maintenance la nuit il
est très très bien payé dans le privé et
moi bien payé j'ai le salaire de la
fonction publique je ne dis pas que que
nous avons comme problème sur la
sécurité civile donc il y a sans doute à
travailler à la fois sur votre activité
la rémunération mais aussi parfois
pourquoi pas sur le deal en tant que en
tant que la location c'est ce qu'on fait
par exemple l'univers pour protéger les
montagnes il y a des écouteurs de
gendarmerie de la sécurité civile et on
loue parfois aussi d'autres hélicoptères
de reconnaissance avec des sociétés
d'ailleurs qui payent le produit de leur
héroïsme puisque je rappellerai qu'il y
a deux ans à la mort des CRS évidemment
en montagne c'est un hélicoptère de
location avec un personnel de location
qui qui est décédé bien sûr la question
plus vaste évoquée sur la discussion moi
je il n'y a pas de de
contradiction entre dire que le
réchauffement climatique est responsable
une partie de du feu et le fait que
comportement humain est responsable
aussi de the voeux les deux se
conjuguent et je pense que ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que il faut faire à la
fois que je reviens de forêt
à la fois
des moyens très importants de transition
de modèle de sécurité civile pour
répondre aux canalités supplémentaires
que nous aurons et à la fois davantage
de prévention je donne un exemple tout
bête mais la suppression des cendriers
dans les véhicules de conduite selon
tous les pompiers que vous rencontrez
vous explique que ça pose des problèmes
énormes désormais de sécurité de
sécurité civile la présence de barbecue
dans des forêts dans des effets de
broussaillement c'est ça paraît un peu
bête comme ça mais responsable une
grande partie des feux que nous
connaissons et moi non plus je suis pas
capable de vous distinguer ce qui relève
de l'activité criminelle de l'activité
bénévole si je veux dire volontaire
voilà on va dire ça comme ça mais il y a
quand il y a plusieurs feux de forêt de
plusieurs départs de feu de forêt quand
on a une trentaine dans le même massif
au même moment bon même si on retrouve
pas à la fin qui est responsable de quoi
on se doute que c'est pas quelque chose
qui est totalement involontaire je
terminerai peut-être pas dire monsieur
le Président que notre modèle de
sécurité civile il a quand même montré
sa résilience moi je veux bien que on
fasse l'attaque de notre modèle mais
enfin il y a pas eu à mort il y a pas eu
la mort pendant des mégafeux alors que
regardez tous les pays européens qui
nous entourent c'est pas le cas il y a
eu un catastrophe écologique il y a eu
des forêts qui ont été brûlées il y a
pas eu il y a eu il y a eu moins de 15
destructions de maisons alors que dans
un rue chacun a vu en était absolument
meurtrier et il n'y a pas eu une
exploitation économique ou agricole qui
n'a pas été totalement dédommagé et nous
avons su grâce aux agriculteurs
notamment aux collectivités locales
répondre à ça donc oui il y a des
difficultés fortes il faut faire en
transition mais si on se compare on peut
qu'on peut être très fier notre modèle
de sécurité civile et l'héroïsme de nos
pompiers les personnes navigant pas à
mort dans les conditions dans lesquelles
je vois notamment la Gironde et les
Landes les vacanciers ont été entourés
montrent quand même qu'on peut aussi se
dire que nous avons réussi certaines
choses et plus tarder à mon tour me fait
pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit je n'ai
pas contesté le fait que le modèle avait
les qualités notamment les personnels
qui travaillent dessus je dis simplement
que le modèle de manière extensible à
partir du moment où il y aura de plus en
plus de feu partout il y a bien un
moment donné un problème de moyens qui
va se poser
paroles à Florian chouch
je vais répondre à monsieur le
rapporteur général sur la prévention qui
est faite sur le pourtour Méditerranée
effectivement il y a un établissement
public qui s'appelle l'entente valable
qui qui réunit différentes collectivités
et départements du sud de la France et
qui fait un travail formidable sur la
formation des sapeurs-pompiers à
combattre les feux de forêt et aussi un
travail de prévention avec des campagnes
de publicité et c'est effectivement un
modèle qu'on pourrait développer dans
d'autres zones de défense du pays et sur
les compagnies d'assurance il serait
intéressant de faire une étude sur la
valeur du sauver parce que les pompiers
sauvent des vis sauvent des bâtiments
des véhicules tout ça ça a un coût
effectivement ça fait des économies aux
compagnies d'assurance et il serait
intéressant d'avoir une étude là dessus
afin de voir les économies qui sont
réalisées par nos grâce à nos 10 et de
les faire contribuer un peu plus j'ai
par ailleurs une pour nous
sapeurs-pompiers qui soient
professionnels ou volontaire et nous
associations de sécurité civile qui vont
être fortement sollicitées à court terme
lors de la Coupe du monde de rugby 2023
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 je remercie le ministre pour les
réponses qui ont qui ont été apportées
même si
je suis un peu sur la vie de monsieur le
Président le risque climatique fait que
les les feux vont se développer un peu
partout en France au même moment et donc
cette histoire de colonne de renfort
sera peut-être un peu plus compliqué à
mettre en place les années à venir et je
termine en formulant le feu pieux ou non
l'avenir nous le dira que nous puissions
tous approfondir cette discussion
relatives au financement de nos
différents
applications du rapport d'information
est autorisé pas d'opposition on a
terminé avec l'examen de ces missions
aujourd'hui mystère de l'Intérieur
monsieur mini je vous remercie surtout
demain à 9h pour l'audition conjointe
avec la commission des affaires sociales
à l'application du 1 de l'article
premier de la loi 2021 15 77 du 6
décembre 2021 pourtant diverses
dispositions relative ou au Conseil des
finances publiques et à la formation du
Parlement sur les finances publiques de
Monsieur Philippe Martin qui vient de la
président de l'Assemblée nationale
envisage de nommer pour siéger au
conseil des finances publiques chers
collègues bonne nuit